STARTED DUH.
CHAIR TING I WANT TO BE HERE FOR
THE HEARING THIS MORNING AND HE
IS STUCK IN TRAFFIC.
PROBABLY NO SURPRISE TO ANY OF
YOU HAVE BEEN OUT OF THE ROADS
THIS MORNING.
.
SO I HE WAS PARTICULARLY AND IS
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED AND.
THE.
.
ZEV ISSUES THAT ARE FIRST IN
THE.
.
IN THE.
ITEMS TO BE HEARD.
AND SO WE'RE GONNA REORDER THE
AGENDA.
AND HERE THE P. YOU SEE ITEMS
FIRST.
AND WE WILL PASS OVER THE VOTE
ONLY ITEMS UNTIL WE HAVE A
QUORUM.
AND.
SO IF I COULD ASK.
UC.
FOLKS TO COME FORWARD.
WELCOME MISTER SULLIVAN.
AND AND SORT OF AN UNOFFICIAL
CAPACITY
.
ALRIGHT WELL IF.
YOUR READY TO ROCK AND ROLL
IT'S.
MOVE RIGHT HAD.
WELCOME MISTER SO OF TIME YES
ARE GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM I THINK OUR HE QUICKLY
SHORTLY JOINED BY OUR NEW
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. ALICE
STEBBINS
A MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG.
AS YOU MIGHT EXPECT THE.
BUDGET WAS DEVELOPED
UNDER MY TENURE SO I'M.
TAKING THE LEAD ON INTRODUCING
IT.
YOUR STAFF ASKED ME TO PROVIDE
A A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF. OUR
BUDGET WHERE WE ARE.
JUST TO SET THINGS UP AND DOES
A OF.
A SIX PAGE.
HANDOUT ARE BASICALLY.
.
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WE'RE
ALL ON THE SAME PAGE.
OUR MISSION IS BASICALLY
INVOLVES FOR THINGS SUPPORTING
INFRASTRUCTURE ACCESS OF WE.
GIVEAWAY AS LOCAL A ABOUTSIX
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR LIFELINE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ACCIDENT.
INCLUDING A RURAL FUNDS ANOTHER
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION.
FOR GAS PROGRAMS AND IT'S ABOUT
A OF A BILLION DOLLARS A
EMBEDDED IN THE CARE RATE
STRUCTURE.
I AS YOU KNOW THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS ARE PROMOTING SAFETY HAS
BEEN A CORE ISSUE ARE A CORE.
OUT PART OF OUR MISSION AND IT'S
BEEN A HIGHLIGHTED WE'VE
INCREASED OUR INSPECTIONS OF
VIRTUALLY EVERYTHING OUR GAS
PIPELINES AND.
WIRE CENTERS AND THE AND I YOU
KNOW I STUDENT WIRES.
AND WE HAVE A BUDGET PROPOSAL IN
THAT AREA TODAY.
WITH THE PASSAGE OF A RECENT
LEGISLATION WE WE HAVE A
GREENHOUSE GAS.
PROGRAM WE HAVE OUR TRADITIONAL
REGULATION AND THEN WE HAVE
CENTRAL CORE OF ADMINISTRATIVE
SUPPORT WHICH.
I I THINK YOU ALL KNOW THAT
RECENTLY WE I HAD A LOT OF
TROUBLE WITH ARE OVERSIGHT AND
CONTROL AGENCIES WHO WE'VE BEEN
BUILDING UP THAT SECTOR.
PAGE THREE IS JUST.
MAPS THE. THE BUDGET UP TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IT'S IT'S
PRIMARILY THERE FOR REFERENCE.
COULD BASICALLY.
IF YOU TAKE AWAY ABOUT THE
HUNDRED MILLION THAT WE USE TO
CONTRACT OUT FOR THE DEAF AND
DISABLED SERVICES WE HAVE ABOUT
A TWO HUNDRED FORTY SIX.
MILLION DOLLAR OPERATIONAL
BUDGET.
WE TRY TO PROVIDE OUR BCP'S AND
AND LET YOU KNOW WHAT THEY DO.
OUR PRIORITIES ARE THREE
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES BEEN
NECESSARY BECAUSE OF NEW
LEGISLATION THE NECESSARY TO
MEET CHANGING PROGRAM NEEDS.
FOR THEIR NECESSARY.
TO IMPLEMENT.
THE FIBRE FORMS THAT WERE
ADOPTED SOME YEARS AGO THIS YEAR
A. REPORT BOARD OF FOURTEEN
BCP'S.
WITH A TOTAL A NET OF THIRTY
SIX POINT FIVE FTE HE'S EIGHT
LIMITED TERM ARE.
.
PHYSICIANS AND A TOTAL
OPERATIONS ARE PART OF A EIGHTY
SIX.
MILLION DOLLARS AND THEN FOR
FIVE IT'S JUST ANOTHER REFERENCE
SHEET PUT
INCLUDES OUR. OUR OUR LIFELINE
OF PROGRAM AS WELL.
SO THIS IS JUST MEANT TO PROVIDE
AN OVERVIEW A AND OUR CAN
INTRODUCE ALF STEBBINS WHO'S
REPLACING ME AND. WILL SPEND
THIS MONEY THAT PART OF BRITISH
TO REVEAL A BIG SMILE ON YOUR
FACE VISIT SOLOMON.
WELCOME THANK YOU.
WE HAVE THE FOR.
NO MATTER.
ARE. TELLING MARATHI HAS.
AT HAS JOINED US FROM THE OTHER
PARTNER FINANCE AND.
SHE'S LE HEADING UPPER
ADMINISTRATIVE CORPS AND
ACTUALLY.
I KNOWS MUCH MORE ABOUT THIS
BUDGET THAN I WILL EVER KNOW.
A MISTER SULLIVAN.
BUT BEFORE YOU.
STEP ASIDE THERE ARE YOU
STAYING ON FOR A PERIOD OF TIME
LONGER WITH SUCH ONE MORE WEEK
LIKE ONE MORE WEEK.
WHAT QUALIFIES A LITTLE WHILE
LONGER OTHER CLOTHES YES I'M
RETIRING AND?
ARE WE.
YOU DON'T WITH SCHEDULING THEY
WILL PEOPLE WANTED A A LITTLE
OVERLAPPING.
YOU KNOW I HAD GIVEN THAT
BUREAUCRACY I HAD TO COMMIT TO A
CERTAIN DATE IN.
AND COULD NOT JUST YOUR NAY
ARRIVING WE HAVE OF A VERY
BUREAUCRATIC ANSWER.
I DON'T A QUESTIONS LIKE HOW
MUCH LONGERYOU TO BE AROUND BUT
OFFICE SEVEN SEVEN WORKING. IF
MEMORY SERVES ME WELL I AND YOU
WERE ABOUT TO RETIRE A FEW YEARS
AGO.
AND JUST STAYED ON AT A TIME
WHEN.
.
THE AGENCY WAS IN A PERIOD OF
TRANSITION AND SOME AMOUNT OF
FLOOD CONTROVERSY.
EVEN A VERY STEADY LEADER
DURING THAT OF THE PERIOD OF
TIME THAT YOU STAYED ON AND. YOU
COULD HAVE BEEN DOING OTHER
THINGS.
BUT BUT DECIDED TO CONTINUE OUR
PUBLIC SERVICE I WANNA THANK YOU
FOR THAT. AND TO WISH YOU ALL
THE BEST THANKS VERY MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IS SIMILAR I ALSO
WANT TO THANK YOU IN THIS
COMMITTEE.
ONE OF THE REASONS I STAYED ON
IS BECAUSE WE HAVE AN AWESOME
MISSION AND.
I WANTED TO INCREASE ENGAGEMENT
WITH WITH SACRAMENTO WHICH IS
DEEPLY COMMITTED TO OUR MISSION
AND DE AYE WE'VE HAD NOTHING BUT
CONSTRUCTIVE RELATIONSHIPS WITH
OUR. OUR BUDGET OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEES I MEAN FEWER COPS BUT
THAT'S TO BE EXPECTED ARE AND
THE.
IT'S NINE AND I SPENT ALL BREAK
A.
THAT WAS THE WRONG THING TO SAY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR REMINDS.
THE PICKUPS ARE ON THE SENATE
SIDE.
EMPLEO NURSED AT.
WELL PLAYED.
LOVE WELL THANK YOU AGAIN AND
LET'S PROCEED.
AS TIM INDICATED MY NAME IS
ELLEN RODDY I AND.
THE NEW.
DIRECTOR OF ADMINISTRATIVE
SERVICES WITH THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION
REGULATIONS.
THANK YOU.
QUESTION MARK FRESH.
.
SO OUR FIRST AYE BE CP ON YOUR
AGENDA RIGHT REQUEST TO POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN VARIOUS
FUNDS IN TWENTY THREE. PERMANENT
FULL TIME POSITIONS TO
STRENGTHEN THE INFRASTRUCTURE
CENTER TO SUPPORTING THE
PROGRAMS.
IN MEETING AROUND THE COMMISSION
MANDATES IN VARIOUS STATUTORY
MANDATES.
THE AREAS INCLUDE.
HUMAN RESOURCES
OUR FACILITY AND EMPLOYEE SAFETY
PROCUREMENT AND CONTRACTING
SERVICES.
OUR BUSINESS SERVICES WHICH
INCLUDES OUR RECORDS RETENTION
POLICY FORMS MANAGEMENT FLEET
MANAGEMENTS AND ASSISTING
ABILITY.
AS THE NUMBER OF MANDATES
EMPLOYEES HAS GROWN. AND THE
COMMISSION HAS IMPLEMENTED
REFORMS
THERE WERE INFRASTRUCTURE
NECESSARY YES SIR TO SUPPORT
THESE EXPANSIONS AND PERFORMS
HAS NOT KEPT PACE.
IN ADDITION OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS THERE HAVE BEEN A NUMBER
OF AUDIT FINDINGS OF THESE
POSITIONS WILL HELP US FOR.
RESPOND TO THOSE AUDIT FINDINGS.
.
THE AGENDA NOTES OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE MAY WISH TO ASK IF
THERE'S A BETTER WAY TO APPROACH
STAFFING AT THE COMMISSION SO
THAT IS NOT IN A SITUATION OF
CHRONIC UNDER STAFFING.
AS NOTED IN THE BCP.
I'D LIKE TO GO AHEAD AND
ADDRESS THAT QUESTION. PLEASE.
.
SO.
WHAT WE WOULD LIKE TO DO PRO
ACTIVELY IS TO START?
MORE PROACTIVELY CONSIDERING
THE INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
CONCURRENTLY AS PROGRAMS.
AND STAFF ARE ADDED AND OR
GROWN.
WE'RE ALSO EVALUATING WHERE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE UM STAFF A
PARTICULAR ARE LOCATED WE HAVE A
PARTICULAR PROBLEM. FOR THE
HEADQUARTERS IN SAN FRANCISCO
RETAINING ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF.
GENERALLY THERE IN GENERAL
BECAUSE.
CLASSIFICATIONS OF SUPPRESSED A
SPECIALTY CLASSIFICATIONS.
SO GIVEN THE HIGH COST OF
LIVING IN THE AREA IT IS HARD TO
RETAIN PEOPLE WHEN. OTHER
OPPORTUNITY SURVEY OF MADE
AVAILABLE FOR EXAMPLE THE
JUDICIARY IS ALSO LOCATED IN SAN
FRANCISCO SO.
WE SOMETIMES LOSE PEOPLE TO
THEM BECAUSE THEY HAVE A
DIFFERENT PAY SCALES.
AS WELL AS OTHER PRIVATE SECTOR
OPPORTUNITIES.
SOBRE LOOKING IT.
INCREASING OUR ADMINISTRATIVE
PRESENCE IN SACRAMENTO.
WHERE THE COST OF LIVING IS
LOWER AND THERE'S THE LARGER
LABOR POOL OF STATE WORKERS
THAT?
UNDERSTAND HOW TO ACCOMPLISH
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS.
.
WE'RE ALSO.
PLENTY TO LOOK AHEAD AT THE
MAJOR WORKLOAD THAT WILL BE
COMING IN THE NEXT FEW YEARS IN
ASSESSING THE EXTENT TO WHICH
OUR INFO ADMINISTRATIVE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS ADEQUATE TO
SUPPORT THAT.
WE ARE ALSO.
.
BE IS SOMETHING A MORE FORMAL
PROCESS INTERNALLY. WITH LOOKING
AT.
MONEY TO PREPARE FISCAL
ESTIMATE FOR BILL ANALYSES AND
CONSIDERING WITH THE IMPACTS
WOULD BE ON ADMINISTRATION.
SO.
YOU DON'T KNOW SINGLE BILL MAY
NECESSARILY NECESSITATE AN
INCREASE IN ADMIN BUT WHEN YOU
START LOOKING AT THEM AN
AGGREGATE.
THERE'S YOU KNOW LIKELY TO BE
UMP PRESSURE ON ADMINISTRATION
SO THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT.
WERE HOPING TO DO TOO ON
ADDRESSED UMBRAGE CHARACTERIZES
THE CHRONIC UNDER STAFFING.
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THINK YOU ARE. EXCUSE ME ANY
DEFAULT.
BELIAU WERE DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
ALRIGHT WITH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE PRESENT TENSION.
WE'LL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON ALL
OF THE P. C..
ISSUES COLLECTIVELY AT THE END
OF FOR.
OF THE PRESENTATIONS.
SO OUR NEXT ISSUE IS IS THE
CALIFORNIA LIFELINE PROGRAM.
IT HAS RESISTED OPERATIONS
COMPONENT IN A LOCAL ASSISTANCE
COMPONENT.
AT A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO.
AT YOUR STAFF'S REQUEST
ACTUALLY.
WE SHIFTED TO IT ECP PROCESS
RATHER THAN A BCP PROCESS SO.
I'LL BE PREPARING NOVEMBER AND
AND MAY ESTIMATE.
.
AND I. THREE WILL HAVE SOMETHING
IN THE MAY REVISION THAT WITH
UPDATED ESTIMATES DISCUSSION FOR
THE LOCAL ASSISTANCE COMPONENT.
ON ADDITIONALLY REQUESTING ABOUT
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
I THINK FOR POSITIONS.
I INSTEAD OPERATIONS TO SUPPORT
THE PROGRAM ALMOND WIRELESS
SERVICES WERE.
ADDED TO THE PROGRAM A FEW
YEARS AGO.
.
WE HAD A TREMENDOUS INCREASING
CASELOAD AND EXPENSES.
BUT.
THE EGG IT THAT WITH THIS
PROGRAM IT'S FALSE ADMITTED THE
PREVIOUS PCP THERE WAS NO
CORRESPONDING INCREASE
INFRASTRUCTURE NECESSARY TO
SUPPORT.
THE PROGRAM SO THERE'S.
POSITIONS AT A REQUESTED WOULD
WORK TO HELP PREVENT AYE WASTE
FRAUD AND ABUSE IN THE PROGRAM.
IMPROVE THE RENEWAL RATES
ESPECIALLY WIRELESS ON THAT YOUR
STAFF HAS REVIEWED OUR ESTIMATE.
THE RENEWAL RATES.
ARE STRONGER IN THE WIRELINE
PROGRAM VERSUS WIRELESS THAT
WE'RE EXPLORING WAYS TO IMPROVE.
RENEWAL FOR WIRELESS SERVICES
TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
PARTICIPANTS
TO RENEW.
WERE ALSO.
PLANNING TO IMPROVE.
AND MAKE MORE TIMELY A REVIEW
OF REQUESTS.
FROM PROVIDERS TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE PROGRAM AND IMPROVE
BENEFITS.
THAT ARE PROVIDED TO CONSUMERS.
UP WHEN YOU SAY IMPROVE BENEFITS
ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT THE.
OF BUT ON THE LIFELINE SERVICE
THAT A NUMBER OF.
TAX AND THAT AND NUMBER CREATE
A LOT OF GIGABYTES
THAT YES YES SIR
BUT I'D BE INTERESTED IN HEARING
WHAT THE.
UNDERLYING RATIONALE IS FOR THE
CURRENT LEVEL AND.
IF YOU HAVE A
DOESN'T NECESSARILY NEED TO BE
TODAY BUT IF THERE ARE ESTIMATES
EXAMPLE TO MOVE I THINK IT'S IS
IT TWO GIGABYTES.
UNDER THE LIFE.
DATA A IN THE DATA PLAN UNDER
LIFELINE IS THAT RIGHT.
SO JUST GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
JONATHAN LOCKETS AND I'M A
MANAGER IN THE COMMUNICATIONS
DIVISION OF THE CPC.
TO.
PROVIDE TO ENSURE QUESTION AND
TO CLARIFY. THE PROGRAM
CURRENTLY ONLY FUNDS VOICE USAGE
BUT.
CARRIERS HAVE ADDED AND SO THE
CURRENT PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS ARE
THAT TO RECEIVE THE MAXIMUM.
SUBSIDY UNDER THE PROGRAM THEY
HAVE TO OFFER A THOUSAND MORE
MINUTES AND A THOUSAND MORE TAX.
MOST YEARS NOW OFFER UNLIMITED
TAX UNLIMITED VOICE.
KERR'S OF ALSO STARTED OFFERING
DATA FOR TWO REASONS ONE IS TO
COMPETE TO ATTRACT CUSTOMERS TO
SIGN UP FOR THE SERVICE. AND THE
SECOND IS THAT THE FEDERAL
LIFELINE PROGRAM HAS OF SUBSIDY
PROGRAM OF MINE TWENTY FIVE A
MONTH TO QUALIFY FOR THAT THEY
HAVE TO OFFER DATA.
TO RECEIVE THAT FEDERAL
SUBSIDIES SO WHATWE'RE SEEING
IS THAT.
THROUGH A COMBINATION OF THE
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS AND.
COMPETITION FOR CUSTOMERS IN
CALIFORNIA CARES OF VOLUNTARILY
ADDING MORE DATA TO THEIR
PROGRAMS TO MAKE THEM ATTRACTIVE
BUT. THE STATE PROGRAMS NOT
ACTUALLY FUND DATA USAGE AT THIS
POINT IN TIME.
I SEE A SO WHY IF AT SOME POINT
YOU COULD PROVIDE SOME ANALYSIS
ON WHAT. A WHETHER YOU THINK
THAT.
WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW IS
ADEQUATELY ADDRESSING THE
PUBLIC'S NEEDS?
AND TO.
WHAT IT WOULD TAKE TO BOB RAISE
THE BAR ON THAT?
IT WOULD BE HAPPY TO THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
TO HAVE FOR ANY COMMENT FROM
ILLEGAL.
FINANCE RUST BROWN WITH THE LA
NOTES THAT WE HAVE REVIEWED THE
ESTIMATES FOR THE LIFELINE
PROGRAM THAT WERE PROVIDED IN
JANUARY FOR NOW WE THINK THAT
THE REASONABLE BUT AS THE
COMMISSION MENTIONED OTHER WILL
BE UPDATED ESTIMATES IN MAY AND
SO. A WE WILL OF COURSE BE%
TAKING A CLOSER LOOK AT THOSE AT
THAT TIME.
THANK YOU I JUST TO FOLLOW UP ON
MY EARLIER QUESTION.
AYE I THINK ONE OF.
A IT IT'S INCONTROVERTIBLE TODAY
THAT TO ONE OF THE WAYS TO GET
AHEAD IN THE WORLD IS.
TO HAVE ACCESS TO A.
A NEW MOBILE TECHNOLOGY THAT
WORKS AND DATA AND COMPUTER
TECHNOLOGY AND AND AND THE LIKE.
AND SO THE MORE WE CAN
FACILITATE THAT FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS.
.
I THINK THE BETTER THEIR CHANCE
IN AT AGE OF EXTREME INCOME
INEQUALITY THE BETTER THEIR
CHANCES GOING TO BE AFFECT
GETTING ADS ARE REALLY WOULD
LIKE TO. SERIOUSLY EXPLORE THAT
ISSUE AND SEWER WOULDN'T GO WITH
IT.
AND IF THERE'S NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS LET'S MOVE
ON ISSUED A BATTERY.
OKAY ISSUE NUMBER THREE IS A
SAFETY ISSUE AND THIS IS A
COMBINATION OF.
PROGRAMMATIC AND REFORM NEEDS.
WE ARE EXPANDING OUR INSPECTION
PROGRAMS AND REDISTRIBUTING
STAFF. THROUGHOUT THE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
I'M INTRODUCING A.
WHO EARLY?
CHO WHO IS THE.
OPERATING AT MANAGER IN THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
WHO A WOMAN AIMS LEE PALMER AND
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
OFFICE OF UTILITY SAFETY? AND
OVER THE COURSE THE QUESTION OF
THE CONSEQUENCES OF NOT
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL STAFF AT
THIS YEAR. AND WHERE THAT'S
DIGITAL STAFF TO BE LOCATED.
SO FOR SOMEONE SEEK TO THE
WORKLOAD. AND THEY'VE BEEN
ANOTHER MEMBER OF SAFETY EVENTS
IN RECENT YEARS FROM SAN BRUNO
TO LEASE A CANYON TO THE BUTTE
FIRE IN THE FIRES OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. THAT ARE
DEMONSTRATING THE US.
THAT THE PUBLIC EXPECTS A
PROACTIVE APPROACH FROM THE
COMMISSION WHEN IT COMES TO
SAFETY AND PREVENTION OF
CATASTROPHIC EVENTS. THAT REALLY
DOES NEED TO BE OUR HIGHEST
PRIORITY.
UNDER SEVERAL WORK OBLIGATIONS
THAT WE'RE JUST NOT MEETING
TODAY. AND WHICH MUST BE
COMPLETED IN ORDER TO MEET OUR
SAFETY MISSION.
I'M STARTING OFF WITH AND TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN FOR THE GAS
PROGRAM.
AND WE JUST DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO CONDUCT THE NUMBER
OF MOBILE HOME.
PARK AND PROPANE INSPECTIONS
IN CALIFORNIA THAT WE REALLY
SHOULD BE DOING.
WE ONLY INSPECTED THIRTY TWO
PERCENT OF THE MOBILE HOME
PARKS.
AND.
SEVENTY PERCENT OF THE PROGRAM
PARK INSPECTIONS WERE NOT
INSPECTED AYE DEFEATISM CONCEPT
IN TERMS OF THE NUMBERS. THERE'S
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTEEN MOBILE
HOME PARKS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND TWENTY NINE PROPANE
OPERATORS CNC THE SCOPE IF
THERE'S THIRTY TWO HUNDRED TOTAL
BUT WERE ACTUALLY BEING ABLE TO
LOOK AT. THAT FOR THESE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES ARE
BECOMING TO.
A MOBILE HOME PARK INSPECTIONS
PROVIDER ABSOLUTE VITAL SERVICE
TO A GENERALLY SPEAKING
VULNERABLE.
POPULATION.
FREQUENTLY FIND OPERATORS
AREN'T UPDATING THEIR PLANS THAT
ARE UPDATING THEIR USAGE THE NOT
UPDATING. ON WHAT THEIR RESPONSE
IT BE IF THERE WAS AN INCIDENT.
SO IT COMES HIGHLY YOU KNOW
LIKELY THAT IF SOMETHING WERE TO
HAPPEN THEY MAY NOT BE PREPARED.
I IN ADDITION.
DE GAS IT RIGHT RELIABILITY
BRANCH NOW MUST INSPECT.
MISCIBILITY MEANNESS SUPPORT
GAS OPERATORS IN CALIFORNIA SUCH
ME ABOUT A FIFTEEN PERCENT
INCREASE IN THE WORKLOAD OF
INSPECTION AT THE ORDER HAVE TO
PRODUCE.
AND THEN THERE'S NO QUESTIONS ON
GAS AND MOVE ONTO RAIL. BUT I DO
WANT TO ASK A FOLLOW UP QUESTION
THE.
AT THE ISSUES INVOLVING MOBILE
HOME PARKS ARE SPECIFIC TO A
PROPANE.
.
EQUIPMENT THAT RIGHT YES. I AM.
AND NOW LOS ANGELES COUNTY
UNINSURED OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE THERE IS A. A BURGEONING
GOT POPULATION OF HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS ARE LIVING AND A
RECREATION DEL VEHICLES.
.
BUT WOULD THE ISSUES.
WOULD YOU EXPECT THE ISSUES
SAFETY ISSUES TO BE SIMILAR AND
IS THERE AN INSPECTION PROGRAM
THAT YOU'RE AWARE OF.
BUT IS OUR GOAL TO REACH OUT TO
THOSE RIGHT NOW THERE'S NOT
INSPECTION PROGRAM FOR THE
PEOPLE LIVING IN THOSE AND ARE
THESE RECREATIONAL VEHICLES
UNLESS THEY ARE PERMANENT
RESIDENTS OF A MOBILE HOME PARK
AND THEY'RE CONNECTED TO THE ACT
READ. IT TO CONNECT TO THE GREAT
THAN THEIR PARTY THAT SPECIAL
PROCESS.
SO WITH OF. A IF THAT'S THE GOAL
I TAKE IT IS NOT BEING ADDRESSED
IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET. AYE IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU CAN AND.
PROVIDE ME WITH OF AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE WITH ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ON WHAT IT WOULD
TAKE TO.
SPAN THE PROGRAM THAT.
JUST GENERALLY WHAT YOUR
THOUGHTS ARE ON HOW.
DECAL COULD BE ACCOMPLISHED
CATHOLIC THING THAT A.
I'M MOVING ON TO RAIL I'M SO FOR
THE ADDITIONAL STAFF AND LOOKING
FOR RAIL.
TO GIVE YOU SOME CONTEXT AND
BACKGROUND. UP IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN THE NUMBER
NATIONWIDE RAIL RELATE
FACILITIES INCREASED BY NINETEEN
POINT TWO PERCENT.
AND LAST YEAR CALIFORNIA
EXPENSE MORE THAN A HUNDRED
SEVENTY FATALITIES
AND AS A RESULT OF RAIL
INCIDENTS.
ORAL SECTION HAS A NUMBER OF
WORK WHAT ITEMS IS UNABLE TO
COMPLETE.
INCLUDING DEPARTMENT
TRANSPORTATION REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS.
AT THE END OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN.
RAIL CROSSING ENGINEERING
BRANCH STILL HAD A HUNDRED ONE
INCIDENTS IN THE PREVIOUS YEAR
THAT I NEED TO CLOSE UP
INVESTIGATIONS FOR TO GIVE YOU
AN IDEA OF THE THE WORKLOAD AT
THEY'RE DEALING WITH.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN OR
FORTY SIX WITHOUT WOODIES AND
SIXTY THREE INJURED REPORT TO
THE PC REGARDING HIGH WELL
HIGHWAY RAIL CROSSING ACCIDENTS.
SO TO GIVE YOU SOME BACKGROUND
RC RC  BE DOES THAT
INVESTING RAIL CROSSING RELATED
ACCIDENTS THAT FROM THE ROOT
CAUSE PROVIDE SOLUTIONS TO. NOT
ONLY THE RARE ROAD AND HIGHWAY
AUTHORITIES POSSIBLE
GOVERNMENT'S INTERSECTIONS.
AND THEN LASTLY.
APPRECIATE NONE OF THAT SEVEN
HUNDRED PREEMPTIVELY.
RAIL CROSSINGS THE CALIFORNIA
INSPECTED LAST YEAR.
SO PREEMPTED RAIL CROSSING JUST
OKAY SAMMONS UNDERWEAR IS A TYPE
OF SYSTEM THAT ALLOWS NORMAL
OPERATION TRAFFIC LIGHTS IN
INTERSECTIONS NEAR WHERE WILL
CROSSINGS.
I'M TO BE MODIFIED AND WHAT THAT
MEANS IS THE LIGHTS CAN'T CHANGE
PRIOR TO THE GATES COMING DOWN
SO YOU DON'T GET ACCESS CAR
STUCK INSIDE OF THAT.
THAT PASSAGE WAY WHEN THERE'S AN
ONCOMING TRAIN.
SAD THE SEVEN HUNDRED.
NONE HAPPEN CURRENTLY INSPECTED
AND IT'S DUE TO RESOURCING WE
DON'T HAVE THE STAFF TO DO THAT.
ON WINTERS A PAID THAT WITHIN
THE FIRST COUPLE YEARS OF
HAPPINESS STAFF
AS ONE WOULD HAVE TO HIRE THEM
ON TO GET THEM TRAINED.
WOULD BE ABLE TO.
INSPECT TWENTY FIVE PERSPECTIVE
LESS MEANING WOULD BE LOOKING AT
FIFTY A YEAR SPECIALLY WHICH
START THAT PROGRAM AT.
I MENDOZA QUESTION REGARDING
LOCATION OF NEW STAFF.
SO REGARDING LOCATION FOR THE
GAS BRANCH I WOULD BE LOCATING
THREE STAFF IN THE CENTRAL
REGION.
THREE STAFF AND THE SOUTH
REGION AND AND FOR THE PROGRAM A
PROJECT SUPERVISOR THAT WILL BE
DEPENDENT ON WHAT THAT CANADA
COMES FROM OF WHERE WE'RE GOING
TO PLACE THEM.
BUT MORE THAN LIKELY AT AT THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR BE LOOKING THE
PLACE HIM SOMEWHERE IN THE
CENTRAL REGION JUST BECAUSE I
ALREADY HAVE A NORTH AND SOUTH.
I'M AND THEN RAIL OPERATIONS
BRANCH.
THERE MAINLY CAN BE LOCATED
DOWN THE SOUTH FOR THE LARGER
RAILYARDS ARE THAT'S WHAT WE
HAVE THE PRIME A REAL GROWTH
RIGHT NOW SAYS WE WANT BE
PUSHING DOWN. ON THE NEW STAFF
THERE AND THEM FOR THEIR RAIL
CROSSINGS ENGINEERING BRANCH I
WOULD BE LOOKING ONE IN SAN
FRANCISCO ONE IN LA AND THREE IN
SACRAMENTO.
I'M AND AS FAR AS THE ADMIN
BUDGET UNIT PEOPLE LOOKING FOR
THE AGP IS TO BE AND SACRAMENTO
LOS ANGELES PRIMARILY BEING.
MOST FOR SAFETY ENFORCEMENT
DIVISION THE MAJORITY OF OUR
ADMINISTAFF'S LOCATED IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
DOES NOT ALLOW SUPPORT AT THE
SACRAMENTO OR LA OFFICE THAT'S
DEDICATED TO SAFETY ENFORCEMENT
DIVISION. OPPRESSION THAT
ADMINISTAFF OUT THERE RIPPING
INCREASED PRODUCTIVITY OF OUR
ACTUAL ENGINEERS INSPECTORS TO
RELIEVE THEM OF SOME THIS ADMIN
BURDENS.
ANY QUESTIONS.
MON LOCAL.
THINGS CHAIR THINK FOR THE
PRESENTATION OF.
I REPRESENTED DISTRICT.
.
I WORK CALTRAIN IS A CENTRAL A
COMMUTE OPTION AND THERE BEEN A
NUMBER OF UP.
RAIL RELATED INCIDENTS.
IN SAN MATEO COUNTY ON THE ON
THE PENINSULA YOU CITED AN
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF RAIL
RELATED INCIDENTS TO WHAT DO YOU
ATTRIBUTE.
THAT AND I.
I'M GOING TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF.
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
SAFEST I INFRASTRUCTURE POSSIBLY
ALSO REPRESENTS AMBER HOUSE OF
GAS SAFETY ISSUES ARE ARE
CRUCIAL BUT.
THIS THIS ISSUE AROUND RAIL.
INCIDENTS CAN YOU SHED ANY
ADDITIONAL.
LIGHT ON THAT FROM FROM WHAT YOU
KNOW AND I WOULD CERTAINLY
SUPPORT.
ADDRESSING.
THAT THE MYRIAD. OF SOUP
CONCERNS ARE RELATED TO RAIL
THAT. YOU COME. FROM.
FROM WHAT FROM WHERE I SAID. THE
REASON WE'RE SEEING AN INCREASE
I KEEPING IN MIND I'M THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
UTILITY SAFETY SO I PRIMARILY
FOCUSED ON GAS AND ELECTRIC BUT
MY UNDERSTANDING OF THE RAIL. OF
WHAT'S GOING ON IT'S ONLY AN
INCREASE AND JUST POPULATION AN
INCREASE AND THE LINES BUT ALSO
THE NUMBER OF CUSTOMERS USING
THAT LINE. SO NOT ONLY ON
CALTRANS FOR INSTANCE YOU HAVE
FREIGHT MOVING ON THAT LINE AS
WELL SO YOU HAVE MORE
COMPETITION ON THOSE LINES USE
IT MORE OFTEN.
TRADING SITUATION BUSIER LINE
MORE TRAFFIC JUST IN GENERAL
MORE PEOPLE.
AND WE ARE GOING TO BE
ELECTRIFYING CALTRAIN UM'S WHICH
WILL CREATE OUT OF THE SERIES OF
ISSUES NGUYEN IN THE
CONSTRUCTION OF A CORNER Y. THEM
IN A BETTER PLACE UP OF COURSE.
WHEN THAT ALL HAPPENS BUT.
.
AND I IS THE INCREASED WORKLOAD
ALSO RELATED JUST GENERAL AGING
OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE IS
ABSOLUTE AND SORT OF AT THE CORE
OF WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE
ABSOLUTELY SO YOU GET THE AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE WE SEE AT THE
ROUTER UTILITIES AND AND RAILS
ABSOLUTE NO EXCEPTION TO THAT.
TO AS WE GO THROUGH THE UPGRADE
TO THE NEW SYSTEM ME TO ENSURE
THAT OUR STAFF IS TING UPDATE
WITH THE CURRENT TRENDS AND
TECHNOLOGIES BEEN PUT IN PLACE.
ALLOW ME TO ASK A QUESTION OF
THAT PROBABLY BETTER ANSWERED BY
MISTER SULLIVAN ON BUT IT'S
TRIGGERED BY YEAR A COMMENT.
INDICATING THAT YOU BE DOING
SOME ADDITIONAL HIRES AND OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO OFFICE AND I KNOW
YOU'VE. GOT A LOT OF FUN
EMPLOYEES AND SAN FRANCISCO.
I WANT TO KNOW IF A ACTUALLY SAN
FRANCISCO OR ANYWHERE ELSE
AROUND THE STATE. ARE YOU
EXPERIENCING DIFFICULTY IN
RECRUITING.
DO THAT ARE EXTREMELY HIGH
HOUSING COSTS IN VARIOUS AREAS
OF THE STATE.
I.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PLUME SAN
FRANCISCO CONTINUES TO BE OUR
OUR MAJOR PROBLEM AT THE COST OF
LIVING IN SACRAMENTO IS.
.
IS LAUGHS AND SO WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO GET STAFF HERE. OF
FOREST SAFETY PROGRAM WHICH HAS
A VERY DIFFERENT SITUATION A LOT
OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE IS IN THE
REMOTE PARTS OF THE STATE. I AND
NUMBER FARMWORKERS ARE HOME
BASED IMAGES COME INTO OUR A
CONVENIENT CENTER SUCH AS
SACRAMENTO AT BAKERSFIELD FOR
MEETINGS.
THE LOS ANGELES OUR OFFICE IS IN
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES AND WE.
WE ACTUALLY ARE THE HOUSING
MARKET ON THE EAST SIDE OF LOS
ANGELES GOING OUT ACTUALLY. TO
THE INLAND EMPIRE OUT WE CAN
DRAW ON THOSE AND THAT TURNS OUT
TO BE A MORE STABLE AS WELL
SOUGHT BIGGEST PROBLEMS ARE
ACTUALLY OF THOSE IN.
ASSEMBLY CISCO PARTICULARLY FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE WORKERS OUT THERE
PRETTY MUCH OF THE STATE PAY AS
NOT COMPARABLE TO THE PREVAILING
RATES IN SAN FRANCISCO. OUT WE
ARE SOUGHT SOME PROBLEMS WITH
THE COMPUTER TECHNOLOGY PEOPLE
COME TO SAN FRANCISCO TO BE IN
DOT COM ART THE NOT INTERESTED
SO MUCH IN STATE COMPUTING.
RIGHT WELL THANK YOU ED AT AT AT
LEAST TO THE EXTENT YOUR.
ATTRACTING PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE AND THEN DRIVE
INTO OF THE LA OFFICE WHERE IT.
A SOMEWHAT COUNTER PURPOSES NOT
SOMEWHAT WHERE COUNTER PROPOSES
WITHOUT SOME OF THE VERY.
UNDERLYING RATIONALE FOR MANY
OF EUROPE YOU SEE PROGRAMS. AND
DATA.
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR VALIDATING
SOMETHING THAT I THINK WE ALL
READY ALREADY KNOW BUT I WANT TO
KNOW SPECIFICALLY WHETHER IT'S
AFFECTING BECAUSE. OF THE PC IN
ITS ABILITY TO.
RECRUIT TED.
FOLKS AT THAT LEVEL YOU YOU YOU
WANT TO WE WE EXPECT TO ADD SIX
HUNDRED NEW. A AYE SIMI FIFTEEN
NEW POSITIONS IN DOWNTOWN
SACRAMENTO WE'RE ALSO EXPANDING
OFFERED PRINT IN THE THOMAS.
LA WE WILL PROBABLY NEED SPACE
PARTICULARLY UP BECAUSE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OF THOSE THOSE
PLANKS WE WOULD ACTUALLY.
IT'S SINCE LAST JANUARY WE
BROUGHT IN CLOSE TO TWO HUNDRED
NEW EMPLOYEES FROM THE OUTSIDE
OF PROMOTED ANOTHER TWO HUNDRED.
WE ARE WORKING HARD TO FILL A
VACANCIES WE STILL HAVE QUITE A
FEW.
BUT A EXERT THEIR
CLASSIFICATIONS ARE TOUGH OR
THOSE THAT ARE TOUGH STATEWIDE
SEARCHES THE ENGINEERING AND OUR
REGULATORY ANALYST.
HOW ARE WE DID ARE COMPETITIVELY
WARY ACTION MENTION THIS BUT I
THINK WE'VE GOTTEN OUR VACANCY
RATE BELOW THOSE OF THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD? AND THE ENERGY
COMMISSION BUT. I DON'T WANT A
BAD NOTHING.
BUT.
HER RIGHT THANK YOU.
IT IS TO KNOW WHERE TO GO WITH
THAT SHOULDN.
DOES THAT COMPLETE YOUR REPORT.
IT'S GREAT SO THAT TAKES US TO.
ISSUE FOR STICKING.
I'M.
AT IT DID ALEJO AND FINANCE
SEVENTY.
NO COMPLAINTS
COMMENTS RATHER OKAY CON.
ISSUE FOR ITS ELECTORS ARE
ELECTRIC TRANSMISSION RATES
ADVOCACY THIS IS ADVOCACY BEACH
FOR FOR. IT IT TURNS OUT THE
TRANSMISSION COST OF ALL A
CALIFORNIA UP BASILIDES OUR
ELECTRIC SYSTEMS ARE ARE RISING
DRAMATICALLY. AND SCAR
COSTARRING DEFERRED JURISDICTION
NOT OURS.
I THIS IS DOROTHY DOUTOR FROM
THE ENERGY DIVISION ARE SHE WILL
BE.
EXPLAINING THAT THIS PROPOSAL.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING OF YES
AND DOROTHY DUE TO AND IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE THIS
MORNING.
WE HAVE ASKED FOR ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
TO OF FOR FIVE POSITIONS AND
SOME CONSULTING RESOURCE
DOLLARS.
UP TO EXPAND AND.
INCREASE OUR EFFORTS. IN
ADVOCACY IN FOR FEDERAL ENERGY
REGULATORY COMMISSION
TRANSMISSION CASES WHERE THE YOU
ARE UTILITIES IN CALIFORNIA GO
TO WASHINGTON DC TO GET APPROVAL
FOR INCREASED.
TRANSMISSION RATES SO WE ARE
ADVOCATES THEIR.
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA REPAIR
INTERESTS AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE INVESTMENTS OMEN
TRANSMISSION OR. PRUDENT AND OF
THAT GROUP WERE WATCHING THE
DOLLARS. SO.
.
I CAN UP PROCEED I KNOW YOU'VE
ALREADY LOOKED AT.
OR.
PROPOSAL.
PART OF THE REASON WE'RE DOING
A INCREASING OUR ADVOCACY WORK
IS THE COMPLEXITY THERE'S A NEW
TRANSMISSION OWNERS. A MERCHANT
TRANSMISSION OWNERS SO THIS WITH
NEW PLAYERS IN THE MARKET THIS
INCREASES THE NUMBER OF CASES SO
WE'RE FINDING THAT THE STAFF
THOUGH THE.
STUFF THAT WE HAD COMMITTED TO
THIS ARE NO LONGER SUFFICIENT AS
WE HAVE TO BE COME INVOLVED IN
MANY MORE CASES UP BURKE.
THANK YOU THERE SOME RECOMMENDED
REPORTING LANGUAGE SHOULD ANNIE
A CONCERNS OR COMMENTS
REGARDING.
.
THE WE THE INTENT OF THAT
LANGUAGE SPINE.
RETHINK IT MIGHT ALSO BE
VALUABLE TO UNDERSTAND THE
AMOUNT OF DOLLARS THAT ARE BEING
CONTESTED BECAUSE A LOT OF TIMES
THESE CASES ARE NOT RESOLVED
QUICKLY.
WE CAN'T TAKE A POSITION TO WE
ACTUALLY SWEEPS THROUGH THE
ACTUAL LANGUAGE BUT.
THE INTENSIVES REASONABLE AND
IT'S SOMETHING WE CAN ALSO
PROBABLY INCLUDE IN OUR ANNUAL
REPORT.
CREATE
THANK YOU ILIO DEPARTMENT
FINANCE.
WE HAVE NO DIESEL COMMENTS
MISTER
YEAH.
MILLION WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I I'M WE HAVEN'T SEEN
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE SO WE
CANNOT COMMENT NOW EITHER
NATURALLY ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
A IN THE A QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE DICE.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH LULA
MOVED TO A ISSUE FIVE THE FINAL
PIECE THE ISSUE FOR TODAY.
ALL THIS IS OVER A I'M SORRY.
CITY
.
MUSICALS HORIA.
WINNING THINKS YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE.
PLEASURE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN BLOOM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS ELIZABETH ACKLES
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF RATE
PAYER ADVOCATES OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS OUR A.
I WANT TO INTRODUCE MY
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE HERE WITH ME
TODAY OUR PROGRAM AND.
PROJECT SUPERVISOR ANNA MARIA
JOHNSON. AS WELL AS ARE
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS ADVISER
MATTHEW MARKETS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TODAY.
I'LL BE TALKING ABOUT BCP NUMBER
THREE THE GEOGRAPHIC INFORMATION
SYSTEM REQUEST.
OR IS REQUESTING ONE POSITION A
RESEARCH PROGRAM SPECIALIST AS
WELL AS GEOGRAPHIC INFORMATION
SYSTEM G. I. S.. MAPPING
SOFTWARE TO OPEN VIEW AND
ANALYZE GIS DATA FILES PROVIDED
BY THE UTILITIES.
WITHOUT THIS POSITION AND
SOFTWARE OR A CANNOT EVEN OPEN
THE GIS DATA FILES THAT WE
RECEIVED FROM THE UTILITIES IN
THEIR PROPOSALS.
THIS GIS EXPERT WOULD EVALUATE
THE UTILITY PROPOSALS TO ENSURE
THAT THEY ARE COST EFFECTIVE
AVOID STRANDED COSTS MITIGATE
SAFETY RISKS AND BENEFITS LOW
INCOME. HOUSEHOLDS AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
FOR EXAMPLE.
GIS COULD FIND OPTIMAL LOCATIONS
FOR TARGETING SOLAR PROGRAM
FUNDING BY OVERLAIN DEMOGRAPHIC
ECONOMIC AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY INFORMATION. WITH
SOLAR RESOURCE DATA TECHNICAL
GREAT EXPANSION CAPACITY AND
DATA ON WHILE PER THREAT ZONES.
WE ALSO WOULD BE ABLE TO
PINPOINT WHERE PROGRAMS LIKE.
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION
AFFORDABLE SOLAR HOMES ENERGY
SAVINGS.
ASSISTANT PROGRAMS CAN MORE
EFFECTIVELY DELIVER BENEFITS TO
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
IN ADDITION GIS SPATIAL ANALYSIS
ON THE LOCATION OF POLLS.
CONDUIT RADIO TOWERS AND MOBILE
WIRELESS SERVICE TOWERS WITH
OVERLY OF FIRE THREAT MAPS WILL
ASSIST IN IDENTIFYING SPECIFIC
AREAS IN CALIFORNIA THAT LACK
CRITICAL TELECOMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE. INCLUDING LOW
INCOME AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DECIDE LA
OVER.
BERMAN FINANCE
COMMENTS.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE DYESS.
.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE IT BE ABLE TO A
LOT OF GOOD TO HAVE WITH YOU
THAT WITHIN OFFENDING THERE'S A
RECOMMENDATION THAT WE IMPROVE
AS BUDGET AND TO SO I THINK.
WHAT WE'LL DO NOW IS TAKE ROLE
SINCE WE HAVE A QUORUM AND THE
WE HAVE A RECOMMENDATION TO HOLD
OPEN? ISSUES ONE THROUGH FOUR
BUT.
.
TO PROVE HIS BUDGET TO ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE THE OVERREACH.
BLOOM.
HERE FONG.
GARCIA MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
WE HAVE QUORUM BENT TO. IS OUR
MOTION ON ISSUE NUMBER FIVE.
THANK YOU.
BLOOM. YES I DON'T FONG.
GARCIA.
MULLIN PATTERSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE IT.
WELCOME.
AND TO WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO
THE TOP OF OF THE AGENDA NOW AND
IT.
WELL WE'LL SKIP OVER THE A
CONCERT IS GOOD FOR FOR THE
MOMENT THE OF IT ONLY CALENDAR
BUT.
LET'S A.
MOVE FORWARD WITH THE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THANK YOU I THINK WE HAVE THREE
PANELS.
MOVE THANK YOU THANK YOU LOTSA
IS THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUES ONE THROUGH FIVE UNDER
PVC.
AND A PUBLIC COMMENT.
APOLOGIZE WE SHOULD DONE THAT
BEFORE WE VOTED. WELCOME THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DAVID CAN HIM
WITH A GREATER CALIFORNIA LIVERY
ASSOCIATION. REPRESENT THE FIVE
THOUSAND LIMOUSINE OPERATORS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THE PC IS GOING TO RELEASE HIM
TO BE CP. ENCOURAGING THAT THE
HIRING ADDITIONAL ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS.
OUR INDUSTRY SEVERAL YEARS AGO.
VOLUNTARILY INCREASE THE AMOUNT
OF FEES THAT WE PAY TO INCREASE
ENFORCEMENT.
FOCUSED ON PRIMARILY ILLEGAL
OPERATORS IN OUR INDUSTRY.
AND I'M ASKING THE SUPPORT OF
THE COMMITTEE AS WELL AS YOU
MISTER BLOOM.
TO FIND ADDITIONAL ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS
TO INCREASE THE SAFETY OF OUR
INDUSTRY.
WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR MONEY.
THE PC HAS TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS OVER MONTHS IN THEIR OF
OUR FUNDS IN THEIR PATRICK
COUNT.
THERE BUDGET SHE STATES THAT BY
THE END OF THIS NEXT FISCAL YEAR
THEY'LL STILL HAVE TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS.
IN THEIR.
PECTORE ACCOUNT.
AND SO AGAIN I'M SIMPLY ASKING
YOUR SUPPORT WHEN THE BCP COMES
TO THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE GIVE IT.
THOUGHTFUL CONSIDERATION.
TO HELP US IMPROVE THE SAFETY OF
OUR INDUSTRY THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND AGAIN I APOLOGIZE FOR NOT TO
HAVE THE PUBLIC COMMENT OPEN
BEFORE WE VOTED.
BUT.
OUR STAFF WILL TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION AND PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO.
AND SO WE'RE GONNA BEGIN WITHOUT
THE FIRST PANEL ON THE.
BECAUSE OF.
VEHICLE IN INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUE.
REPUBLICAN.
OH YES I'M SORRY YOU'RE HERE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT.
COULD YOU ARE COMES THE MICRO.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER. INDIVIDUALS
WHO WANTS BECOME PUBLIC COMMENT
I'M SORRY THEY WERE AND NUMBER
PEOPLE STAND NAMED DERECHOS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JUST RUIN THIS UP
BADLY NOW IT'S OKAY. BELIEVE ME.
DO THAT I HAVE A LOT OF THE LIKE
GOT HERE THIS MORNING MAYBE
THAT'S THE.
WELL THE MORNING GOOD MORNING
ALL.
AM THE CHAIRMAN OF THE LOW
INCOME OVERSIGHT BOARD WITH
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION HOW
FOR THOSE THAT AREN'T FAMILIAR
WITH OUR BOARD. WE ARE
ESTABLISHED IN STATUTE SOME
YEARS AGO.
IN CONNECTION WITH ADVICE IN
THE COMMISSION ON ISSUES OF OF
ENERGY BOTH ON GAS ELECTRICITY.
TOGETHER WITH WATER
TELECOMMUNICATIONS AND IT'S AN
EXCITING TIME TO BE INVOLVED IN
TERMS OF REPRESENTING
COMMUNITIES IN NEED.
IT CERTAINLY OVER YOU KNOW
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES IN
CONNECTION WITH ENERGY BURDEN
WHICH IS SIX SIGNIFICANT.
SO WE ALL KNOW IN TERMS OF THE
GROWING GAP BETWEEN THE HAVES
AND HAVE NOTS.
THAT.
UTILITY BILLS OR NUMBER TWO IN
CONNECTION WITH THE BURDEN THAT
PEOPLE ARE LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES FACE EVERY MONTH.
SO HAVING SAID THAT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I WANTED TO KIND OF
EMPHASIZE ARE ON I BELIEVE IT'S
WHAT ITEM NUMBER.
I CAN'T REMEMBER THE NUMBER ON
THE.
GAS ELECTRIC IS CONNECTIONS
ONE OF THE THINGS ON OUR BOARD
THAT WE DISCUSSED YOU KNOW AS A
PRACTICAL MATTER AND UTILITIES
DO AS WELL AS THEIR PROGRAMMATIC
RESPONSE TO
S. CONNECTION.
SO OBVIOUSLY RATE ASSISTANCE
THROUGH CARE.
THE.
IN ENERGY SAVINGS ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM.
ARE ONE OF THE WAYS IMMEDIATELY
THAT WE CAN RESPOND BUT THERE
ALSO IS ANOTHER WAY.
AND THE EMERGING SORT OF CLIMATE
CHANGE AREA THAT WE HAVE
ESPECIALLY IN RURAL AGRICULTURAL
AREAS BECAUSE I DO REPRESENT AT.
MICHAEL BUT THE OF A COMPASS
SCENE OUT WHICH IS A STATEWIDE
NETWORK OF FARM HUMAN SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS.
AMENITIES COMMUNITIES LIVE IN
AREAS WHERE TEMPERATURES ARE
EXTREME.
HEAT IS UNBEARABLE AND YOU KNOW
AGAIN EVEN IN CALIFORNIA YOU
KNOW IT'S VERY VERY COLD THE
SPECIALLY THIS TIME OF YEAR.
SO THE REALITY IS THE LEGISLATOR
THE LEGISLATURE'S PAID SOME
ATTENTION TO THE ISSUE.
IN TERMS AMENITIES COMMUNITIES
THAT DO NOT HAVE NATURAL GAS AS
A HEATING SOURCE TRYING TO
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE. BUT I THINK
ONE OF THE MORE SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAMS OUT THERE. IS THE LOW
INCOME WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM
THIS CURRENTLY BEING MAGISTRATE
OR BY CST.
THIS IS LITERALLY TAKING WHAT
THE PC HAS BEEN TRYING TO DO FOR
YEARS WHICH IS THE LEVERAGE OF
THE VARIOUS FUNDING SILOS.
THROUGH A RATE ASSISTANCE
THROUGH.
ENERGY SAVINGS ASSISTANCE IN
TERMS OF APPLIANCE A PLACEMENT
IN RATHER A STATION.
NOW BRINGING AND SOLAR.
AND ADDRESSING SOME OF THE
HARDER TO REACH COMMUNITIES
ESPECIALLY IN THE AREAS THAT I
REPRESENT.
WHICH ARE AGRICULTURAL REGIONS
AND FARM WORKER POPULATION
SIGNIFICANTLY.
SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I WANT
TO DO IS TO BRING THAT TO YOUR
ATTENTION. THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ZEROED OUT LIE WITH.
THE LOW INCOME WEATHERIZATION
PROGRAM.
AND IT WOULD BE A HUGE
CATASTROPHE OF THAT'S NOT
REAUTHORIZE FOR THE NEXT
UPCOMING FISCAL SIMPLY BECAUSE.
YOU GOING IN MY EXPERIENCE IN
DEALING WITH LOW INCOME ENERGY
ASSISTANCE THERE IS NOTHING ON%
THE PLATE RIGHT NOW. THAT WILL
TAKE ITS PLACE.
IF IT GOES AWAY I THINK THAT.
AT SOME POINT WILL REALIZE THAT
WE NEED TO REENGINEER THE
PROGRAM.
AND AGAIN WE WORK WITH THE
PRIVATE SECTOR IN TERMS OF
DEVELOPING. YOU KNOW THE PROGRAM
ITSELF AS WELL AS ADMINISTERING
SERVICES IN JUST THE RESTART UP
ALONE WILL WILL LOSE A YEAR.
SO AGAIN I WOULD BRING IT TO
YOUR ATTENTION.
THAT THE REAUTHORIZATION OF Y.
WHIP IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT I
THINK IT SPEAKS DIRECTLY TO.
THE ABILITY FOR US AS A STATE
AND WE RECOGNIZE.
THAT WE HAVE TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF DISCONNECTION
IN THE IMPACT SO AGAIN IT'S
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THE AT THANK YOU.
.
I WANNA LEARN MORE ABOUT THIS
ISSUE AND UNDERSTAND TO WHY THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS.
OF PROPOSING THAT BE ZEROED OUT
SUB YOU WOULD MIGHT BE IN
CONTACT WITH MY STAFF FOR AND
PRETZELS THAT UP A MEETING BUT
I'D LIKE TO GET MORE INFORMATION
AND UNDERSTAND THE ISSUE. A
LITTLE MORE.
ANGLE MORE GRANULAR THANK
ANNUAL THEIR LEVEL. RIGHT AND
I'LL I WILL LEAVE MY CONTACT
AFFIRMATION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENT.
ANYONE ELSE.
THANK.
OF.
ALRIGHT TO.
SO WERE WERE.
AND MOVING ON TO OUR FIRST STEP
PANEL.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOURPATIENCE
WELCOME CHAIR TING. IT'S GOOD TO
HAVE YOU WITH US TODAY.
PLEASE PROCEED.
GREAT. OKAY WE CAN START GETS
ALRIGHT SO MY NAME IS TYSON
ACTUALLY ON THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE AT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICEOF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. AND OUR ROLE
RELEASED THE COORDINATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE IMPLEMENTATION
ACTIVITIES WORKING HAND IN HAND
WITH ALL OF OUR PARTNER
AGENCIES.
LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS AND
BUSINESSES TO BRING IT ALL
TOGETHER.
IN THE CONTEXT OF TODAY'S
HEARING AND IN RECENT EXECUTIVE
ORDER YOU'RE REALLY TALKING
ABOUT LAYING THE FOUNDATION FOR
A COMPLETE MARKET
TRANSPORTATION.
I'M NOT JUST INCREMENTAL
PROGRESS SO TRANSPORTATION AS WE
KNOW. I ACCOUNT FOR THE COST
ABOUT FIFTY PERCENT OF OUR
GREENHOUSE GASES AS THE STATE
AND ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES ARE A
KEY PART OF OUR STRATEGY TO
ADDRESS THAT.
CONTRIBUTION.
I'M FIVE MILLIONS THAT'S WHICH
WAS LAID OUT BY THE GOVERNOR IN
HIS EXECUTIVE ORDER BY TWENTY
THIRTY IS A CHECKPOINT ON THE
WAY TO A FULLY ZAB FUTURE. THE
REALLY TO GET THERE WE NEED TO
FUNDAMENTAL THINGS TO HAPPEN
FIRST WE NEED PEOPLE TO BE VERY
EXCITED TO BUY. BY PURCHASE OR
LEASE OR OPERATE THESE VEHICLES.
AND SECOND WE NEED THE ABILITY
TO CHARGE IN FUEL THESE VEHICLES
CONVENIENTLY.
I WANT TALK ABOUT INFRASTRUCTURE
WHICH IS ABSOLUTELY FUNDAMENTAL
TO THEM.
TO THE MARKET IS DIRECTLY LINKED
A VEHICLE UPDATE I'M HE GETS
INTO IT OF A LOT OF WAYS LIKE
WHY WOULD YOU BUY A CAR THAT YOU
CAN'T FUEL. BUT IT'S ALSO SHOWN
IN A LOT OF STUDIES HAVE BEEN
LOCATIONS THAT HAVE MORE PUBLIC
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
AVAILABILITY. HAVE A HIGHER
UPTAKE OF VEHICLES.
AND CALIFORNIA HAPPENS HAVE ONE
OF THE LOWEST RATIOS.
AND THEY DID IT OF ANY MAJOR
MARKET.
AND TERMS OF WHEN YOU LOOK AT
ELECTRIC VEHICLES TO NUMBER OF
CHARTER SO OUR RATIO IS ABOUT
THIRTY ELECTRIC VEHICLES TO ONE
PUBLIC CHARTER SO PUBLIC REPLACE
CHARGER.
AND AS COMPARISON AND OTHER
LEADING MARKETS THAT WE COMPARE
OURSELVES TO LIKE NORWAY HAS A
FIFTEEN TO ONE RATIO AND THE
NETHERLANDS HAVE ABOUT A FIVE TO
ONE RATIO.
SO THE RATE RATIO CAN VARY
DEPENDING ON LOCATION IN PARKING
AVAILABILITY.
BUT RIGHT NOW I THINK
CALIFORNIA PROBABLY HAS ONE OF
THE BEST UNDERSTANDINGS OF WHAT
WE NEED IN TERMS OF THAT RATIOS.
AND SO THE CDC HAS RECENTLY
COMPLETED THEIR ANALYSIS THAT'S
BEEN YOUR LONG ROBUST ANALYSIS
WORKING AT THE NATIONAL
RENEWABLE ENERGY LAB. TO LOOK
FOR A BOTTOM UP HERE LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT THIS LATER.
BUT RELIEVED AT THAT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE CHARGING NEEDS AS
THE STATE.
IT WAS ORGANIZED AROUND ONE
FUNDAMENTAL PREMISE
pCONSUMERS TO MAINTAIN THEIR
CURRENT DRIVING BEHAVIOR. BASED
ON ELECTRICITY.
WITH THAT IN MIND WE'RE REALLY
LOOKING AT W. ELEVEN TO ONE
RATIO SO. I'M ELEVEN E. VIS TWO
ONE CHARGER IN THE PUBLIC SO.
WE'VE A LONG WAY TO GO ON THERE
HYDROGEN SIDE.
DIE WERE FULLY DEPENDENT ON
PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE IS NOT A
VIABLE ECONOMICALLY VIABLE HOME
CHARGING SOLUTION YET IN THE
MARKETPLACE.
SO YOU LOOK AT THIS THAT YOU
KNOW WHERE ARE WE THAT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL IF YOU THROW ALL
OF OUR PROGRAMS AT AT AND I'M
WITH THE UTILITY INVESTMENTS
WITH THE SETTLEMENTS WITH THE
ENERGY COMMISSION'S CURRENT
PROGRAM WE GET ABOUT HALF WHERE
WE NEED HALF OF THE WAY WE. NEED
TO GO. OUT IN TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
AND SO WITH THIS CHALLENGE IN
MIND.
GOVERNOR BROWN SET OUT IN THIS
EXECUTIVE ORDER TARGETS THAT ARE
ORGANIZED AROUND THAT TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
GOAL.
AND SO TO GET THERE. WE NEED
ABOUT TWO AND A FIFTY THOUSAND
PUBLIC CHARGERS THAT'S IN THAT
PUBLIC SPACE WORKPLACE AND MULTI
UNIT DWELLINGS.
AND INCLUSIVE INCLUDING THERE
WE NEED THAT TEN THOUSAND DIRECT
CURRENT FAST CHARGERS ROUNDABOUT
TO TO REALLY ENABLE THE MARKET.
I WILL SERVE LOOKING AT DOUBLING
OUR HYDROGEN COMMITMENTS WE NEED
TWO HUNDRED STATIONS THERE UP
FROM OUR CURRENT HUNDRED TARGET.
WE NEED THESE STATIONS SPREAD
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ESPECIALLY
WITH SPECIAL ATTENTION THE
DISADVANTAGED THAT COMMUNITIES
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET ACCESS
THROUGHOUT THEIR.
AND SO REALLY THESE YOU KNOW
TARGETS AND VISION OF THE
GOVERNOR SET OUT ARE HELPFUL IN
ORGANIZING THE MARKET YOU KNOW
WE THREW THOSE OUT THERE I'M.
FOR THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO YOU
GIVE IT GIVE US OFTEN MEASURE
AGAINST AND ALSO KIND OF SIGNAL
TO THE MARKET WHAT WE NEED TO IT
TWO REALLY CATALYZED
DEVELOPMENT.
AYE BUT WE'RE HERE TODAY TALKING
YOU KNOW HAS TAKEN THAT VISION
AND ACTUALLY PUT INTO ACTION AND
TALK ABOUT THE FUNDING TO BACK
THAT UP SO THAT WE CAN HEAD OVER
TO BATMAN.
YEAH AMANDA MARTIN DEPARTMENT
FINANCE MINISTER THAT HE.
A BRIEF OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES A COMPREHENSIVE
PACKAGE TO ACCELERATE
CALIFORNIA'S TRANSITION.
TO THE BEES.
CONSISTING OF TWO PRIMARY
COMPONENTS.
ACCELERATE DEPLOYMENT OF STEVIE
INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGH THE
ENERGY COMMISSION'S ALTERNATIVE
RENEWABLE FUEL AND VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGY PROGRAM THE ACKERMAN
IS A ARE AT THE TPE.
AND ONGOING FOR FUNDING FOR
VEHICLE REBATES THEM AS OUTLINED
IN YOUR AGENDA.
PROPOSAL FOR THEIR MISSION
PROGRAM. INCLUDES NINE HUNDRED
MILLION OVER THE NEXT EIGHT
YEARS WITH TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE MILLION IN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN.
AND NINETY FIVE MILLION ANNUALLY
I'M IN THE REMAINING YEARS NOW
IN ORDER TO DO THE TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE MILLION TO MAKE
AVAILABLE THE PROGRAM EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN THE PROPOSED INCLUDES
BOTH BUDGET BILL ON TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE.
TO APPROPRIATE HUNDRED FORTY
SEVEN MILLION FROM THE
ALTERNATIVE AND RENEWABLE FUEL
AND VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY FUND.
I'M FOR THOSE THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE INITIATIVE WHICH
INCLUDES SEVENTY SEVEN MILLION
FROM THE VARIOUS I'M AB ONE
EIGHTEEN PROGRAMS A TRANSFER OF
FIFTEEN MILLION.
FROM THE AIR QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT FUND FUND BALANCE
AND FIFTY FIVE MILLION OF THE
REMAINING FUND BOUNCE.
IT ALSO AUTHORIZES THE TRANSFER.
OF ENCUMBERED FUNDS OF
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY EIGHT
MILLION FROM THAT NEW SOLAR
HOMES PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM THAT'S
ENDING THIS YEAR.
AND LIFTS THE TWENTY MILLION OR
TWENTY PERCENT LIMIT ON ANNUAL
EXPENDITURES ON HYDROGEN FUELING
STATIONS THAT'S CURRENTLY COULD
THE ENERGY COMMISSION'S PROGRAM.
NOT FOR THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES
ONGOING.
PRISON ONGOING FUNDING FOR THE
CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE PROJECT
WHICH PROVIDES CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS.
WITH REBATES ON THE PURCHASE OR
LEASE OF NEW LIGHT DUTY ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES AND PLUG IN
HYBRIDS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT'S TO
UNDERMINE FROM CAP AND TRADE
FUNDS ANNUALLY.
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
INCLUDING TWENTY FIVE MILLION
SPECIFICALLY FOR LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS.
THE ONGOING FUNDING TO PROVIDE
MORE CERTAINTY.
THE CONSUMERS AND MANUFACTURERS
IN THAT MARKET I'M AND WITH THAT
WE TURN OVER TO SEE YOU SEE AN
AIRPORT TO OPERATE ON THEIR
PROPOSALS.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS TRUE
BONE AND THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION. AND AS YOU HEARD ON
I CAN REPEAT WHAT YOU'VE HEARD
BUT WE ARE FOCUSING ON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE SIDE OF THINGS
WE'VE GOT TEN YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH.
THIS PROGRAM AND WE THINK WE
KNOW WHAT THE PLAYERS WHO THE
PLAYERS ARE AND WHAT WE NEED TO
DO. AS.
YOU HEARD EARLIER WE SPENT THE
LAST YEAR WORKING WITH AND WELL
THE NATIONAL RENEWABLE ENERGY
LAB IN COLORADO AND OUR STAFF TO
DEVELOP A. TOOL WE CALL E. V. I
PRO AND THAT STANDS FOR ELECTRIC
VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTIONS.
THIS LITTLE REVIEWS TO COME UP
WITH THESE NUMBERS SO WHEN WE
SAY WE ESTIMATE WE'RE GOING TO
NEED TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
CHARGERS TEN THOUSAND OF WHICH
WOULD BE FAST CHARGERS TO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S GOALS. OF
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION VEHICLES
BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THIS IS
WHERE THESE NUMBERS COME FROM
AND IS TYSON POINTED OUT WERE
OUR EXPECTATION IS TO IT IS
THAT.
WITH THE INVESTMENTS WERE
CURRENTLY SEEING ON THE HORIZON.
HALF MAYBE LESS THAN THAT WE
THINK WE HAVE CURRENTLY FUNDED
SO THE NUMBERS YOU HEARD FROM
FINANCE ARE THE NUMBERS WE THINK
WE NEED TO SUPPORT THE
ADDITIONAL INFRASTRUCTURE SO
THAT. AGAIN WE'RE TRYING TO
REALLY CHANGE THE WAY PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN BY MOVING FROM PLACE
TO PLACE FOR FOR THE LAST
CENTURY. AND.
WITHOUT PUBLIC INVESTMENT WE
DON'T SEE THE UPTICK UPTAKE
BEING ABOUT WHAT IT NEEDS TO BE.
BRIEFLY ON HYDROGEN WERE IT OVER
FOUR THOUSAND VEHICLES RIGHT NOW
WE'VE GOT THIRTY TWO STATIONS
FUNDED.
IN IN PLACE IN AVAILABLE FOR
THE PUBLIC TO GET.
.
GOD THE PROPER THAT THE HYDROGEN
THAT THEY NEED AND WE'VE GOT
ANOTHER ABOUT THIRTY THAT ARE
FUNDED IN ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
BEING BUILT. AND WE HAVE FUNDING
IN PLACE FOR THE BALANCE OF THE
HUNDRED THAT WE'VE BEEN AFTER
FOR QUITE SOMETIME AND AS YOU'RE
AWARE THE GOVERNOR'S GOAL SEEKS
TO DOUBLE THAT NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED. OUGHT TO REALLY BEFORE
AND HYGIENE WITH THAT ALL.
PASS IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE.
I GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
I'M STEEP CLIFF DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
OFFICER THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD.
AS YOU HEARD WE'RE REQUESTING
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY THREE TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE TO.
SUPPORT THE CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE
PROJECT OR CV RP.
WHICH INCLUDES AT LEAST TWENTY
FIVE MILLION ANNUALLY FOR LOW
INCOME CONSUMERS.
THESE CAN THESE INCENTIVES ARE
A KEY PART OF OUR MULTI PRONGED
EFFORT. TO GROW THIS AT MARKET.
AND HELP MEET OUR GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION TARGETS AND AIR
QUALITY STANDARDS.
THE PRIMARY DRIVER IS OUR
ADVANCE CLEAN CARS PROGRAM WHICH
INCLUDES A ZEV REGULATION
REQUIRING MANUFACTURERS TO
PRODUCE AN INCREASING NUMBER OF
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES FOR SALE
IN CALIFORNIA.
VEHICLE IN INFRASTRUCTURE AND
SENATE SUPPORT THE REGULATION
AND NINE OTHER STATES HAVE
ADOPTED THIS OF REGULATION BUT
NONE HAS SEEN THE MARKET GROWTH
CALIFORNIA HOUSE DUE IN LARGE
PART TO THE SIGNIFICANT
INCENTIVE INVESTMENTS HERE.
VEHICLE PURCHASE INCENTIVES ARE
NEEDED IN THE EARLY YEARS OF THE
MARKET TO HELP BRIDGE THE HIGHER
COSTS FOR CONSUMERS. AND TO HELP
CONSUMERS BECOME COMFORTABLE
WITH THESE NEW TECHNOLOGIES.
THESE INCENTIVES ALSO ENCOURAGE
SALES BEYOND THE MINIMUMS
REQUIRED BY THE REGULATION.
TO FURTHER ACCELERATE THE
MARKET.
THIS IS NEEDED TO MEET THE FIVE
MILLIONS OF GOAL THAT YOU JUST
HEARD ABOUT.
EARLY SIGNS OF MARKET GROWTH A
VERY PROMISING WITH OVER THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSANDS ADS ON
THE ROAD IN CALIFORNIA. AND OVER
FORTY VEHICLE MODELS NOW
AVAILABLE.
ZEV SALES GREW TO FIVE PERCENT
IN CALIFORNIA LAST YEAR.
AND BUT WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO
BEFORE THAT MARKET IS FULLY
SINGLE.
WE'VE SEEN THIS AT MARKET AND
OTHER STATES COLLAPSE WHEN THOSE
INCENTIVES HAVE. BEEN ENDED TOO
SOON.
AND DESPITE THIS POSITIVE NEWS
PREDICTABLE ONGOING FUNDING FOR
THE C. B. R. P. HAS BEEN A
CHALLENGE. WE'VE STRUGGLED TO
KEEP THE PROGRAM FULLY FUNDED.
ENDING UP WITH WAITING LISTS IN
FOUR OF THE PAST. PAST FIVE
YEARS.
AND THE STARTS AND STOPS HAVE
HAD A CHILLING EFFECT ON THE
MARKET A TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS SEEK YOUR P. ANNUAL
APPROPRIATION. WOULD PROVIDE
CERTAINTY IN THE MARKET AND HELP
US CHART A LONG TERM COURSE FOR
C. B. R. P..
WE EXPECT THIS FUNDING WOULD
MEET CONSUMER DEMAND FOR IN THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN FUNDING CYCLE SO
WE WOULDN'T ENVISION ANY MAJOR
CHANGES OVER THE NEXT YEAR. AS
THE MARKET GROWS WILL NEED TO
CONTINUE REFINING THE CVR P.
TARGET. AT TO TARGET THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION TO THE CONSUMERS
MOST INFLUENCED BY THESE
REBATES.
AND THAT COULD. BE CHANGES TO
THE REQUIREMENTSTHAT MIGHT
INCLUDE.
OTHER TYPES OF THINGS SUCH AS
MSRP CAPS OR OTHER TYPES OF
THEM.
I LIMITS TO THE PROGRAM TO STAY
WITHIN THAT TO HONOR BILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET AND OF COURSE WE
WOULD DO ANY OF THAT THROUGH OUT
OF PUBLIC PROCESS LIKE WE DO FOR
OUR EXISTING PROGRAM.
I FOCUS ON THE VEHICLE INCENTIVE
SIDE BUT THESE INVESTMENTS ARE
ONLY FULLY EFFECTIVE IF THEY'RE
DONE IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS YOU
JUST HEARD ABOUT.
AND WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE ENERGY COMMISSION P. YOU SEE
AND GO BEARS TO ENSURE THAT THE
STATE'S SEVEN VESTMENTS STRATEGY
AS WELL COORDINATED.
AND THEN IN ADDITION.
THERE'S OTHER ELEMENTS OF OUR
LOW CARBON TRANSPORTATION
INVESTMENTS THAT ALSO SUPPORT
THIS APP INITIATIVE. WE FUND
CLEAN TRUCKS BUSES AND FREIGHT
EQUIPMENT TO INTRODUCE OUR
MISSION TECHNOLOGIES TO THOSE
SECTORS. AND WE INVEST IN EQUITY
FOCUS PROJECTS
TO INCREASE ACCESS TO CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION AND HELP
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS BENEFIT
FROM ZERO EMISSION TECHNO.
YEAH.
THANK YOU.
ILIO.
ON THE NEXT THE CANNOT. OKAY.
IT JUST ENJOYING THIS ONE.
SO.
AYE MY FAMILY'S RECENTLY BECOME
ONE OF THE FOUR THOUSAND.
OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE A A HYDROGEN
FUEL CELL VEHICLE.
AND I WANTED TO JUST OUT A
COUPLE OF.
CONSUMER COMMENTS.
A ABOUT THE FUELING STATIONS
WHICH I I HAVE TO SAY A ON THE
WHOLE.
.
NOT MANY I FOUND TO BE.
LACKING IN AND.
A A NUMBER OF ASPECTS.
OF A FIRST OF ALL SOME OF THE
STATIONS HAVE EXTREMELY POOR
LIGHTING. OF WHERE THE HYDROGEN
FUEL.
SELF A PUMP IS LOCATED A AND
THE LEADING TO A LESS THAN
INVITING CA A AND ENVIRONMENT.
THERE ARE SOME
THE DESIGN ISSUES THAT I'VE
NOTICED WHICH A. A MAKES THEM.
DIFFICULT ACCESS
BUT THE THAT THE BIGGEST ISSUE
THAT I.
SIMPLY DON'T UNDERSTAND IS THAT
THERE'S
NO SIGNAGE NO STREET SIGNAGE
INDICATING THE HYDROGEN FUEL
CELL. A. HYDROGEN OF FUEL IS
AVAILABLE NOW.
AS DRIVERS WE KNOW WHERE THE
STATIONS ARE BECAUSE THERE'S AN
APP THAT THAT THAT YOU CAN
ACCESS.
BUT IT SEEMED TO ME THAT OF THE
LACK OF SIGNAGE BUTTON THIS IS A
GOLDEN OPPORTUNITY TO INFORM THE
GENERAL PUBLIC THAT THIS IS THE
FUEL. THAT IS BECOMING MORE
UBIQUITOUS AND AVAILABLE.
AND IF WE'RE GONNA.
TRULY BE SUCCESSFUL IN MOVING
THIS PROGRAM FORWARD AND A
INVEST VERY SUBSTANTIAL. UP WE
SHOULD
BE DOING A BETTER JOB OF FULLER.
UP OVERALL HOW WE DESIGNED AND.
A INDICATE TO THE PUBLIC THAT'S
THAT THE STATIONS EVEN EXIST.
THOSE ARE EXCELLENT POINTS
CHAIRED THE UNIVERSE OF UP
PROVIDERS OF THIS TECHNOLOGY IS
VERY SMALL AND WE WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH EACH OF THEM SO
WE'RE GONNA TAKE THESE COMMENTS
BACK AND SHARE THEM WITH.
THOSE FOLKS AND I BUT I THINK
THEY'RE VERY GOOD SUGGESTIONS
I'D BE HAPPY TO BE MORE SPECIFIC
WITH YOU IN A PRIVATE MEETING
BUT I CAN'T LIKE NOT TRYING TO
CALL ANYBODY SPECIFICALLY OUT
HERE.
.
BUT THE IT THE ISSUE OF SIGNAGE.
A IS ACROSS THE BOARD I.
AT AND AND I HAD NOT EVEN BEEN
TO THAT MANY STATIONS.
AT AT THIS POINT WE'VE ONLY HAD
THE VEHICLE FOR ABOUT TO THREE
MONTHS NOW.
BUT THERE HASN'T BEEN A SINGLE
STATION WHERE THE HAS BEEN
SIGNAGE.
SO TO ME THAT I IT SEEMS LIKE
THERE'S.
THERE MUST BE A REASON FOR THAT
AND WE OUGHT TO BE.
FIGURING OUT HOW TO OVERCOME
THAT.
ANY OTHER.
MR MON.
OTHERWISE EXPERIENCES BEEN GREAT
BY THE WAY UP.
I HAVE A QUICK VIEW THAT JUST A
FEW QUESTIONS.
IN TERMS OF.
IDENTIFYING WHERE THESE
CHARGING STATIONS CHO HAU
MCCARTY YEARS BEING USE.
WHERE WOULD YOU HAVE SPECIFIC
AREAS ARE FOCUSING ON DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE STATE?
SO I THINK THEY.
THERE'S A COUPLE IT THERE'S A
LOT OF THINGS HAPPEN THERE'S A
PARTNERSHIP WITH INDUSTRY SO
WITH THE ENERGY COMMISSION
PROGRAM.
THEY PUT OUT FUNDING AND THEN
THAT PARTNERSHIP WITH INDUSTRY
THEY THEN SHE PARTNERS LIKE
DIFFICULT TO FIND THAT LOCATION.
THERE'S A THAT PUSH AND PULL AND
BACK AND FORTH WITH THE STATE
AGENCY THROUGH THE PUBLIC
PROCESS KIND OF WHERE THE MONEY
NEEDS TO GO. THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION YOU KNOW
THAT I'M WORKS CLOSELY WITH THE
UTILITIES AND THE UTILITIES IN
TURN WERE CLOSE WITH THE
COMMUNITIES TO DETERMINE WHERE
THEY NEED TO PUT THAT CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL SO. ALL
OF US ARE TALKING IN
COORDINATION ABOUT FILLING GAPS
THAT BEAR BE IS OVERSEEING THE
VW SETTLEMENT INVESTMENTS AND SO
WE'RE WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
ELECTRIFY AMERICA. TO HELP BOTH
IDENTIFY SITES FACILITY THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THEM BUT ALSO.
FIND LOCATIONS THAT WORK SO
THERE'S IT'S
IT'S A WHOLE ECOSYSTEM OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE TALKING AND RELIEF
TRYING TO IDENTIFY THE BEST
SITES FOR PRIVATE BUSINESS AND
ALSO FOR THE PUBLIC INVESTMENTS.
I I WOULD JUST ADD TWO POINTS
ONE OF SOME COMMUNITIES HAVE
REALLY EMBRACED THIS CHANGE AND
HAVE THEMSELVES INVESTED FUNDS
ARE RECEIVED PUBLIC FUNDS.
TO HELP THEM DO SO TO PLAN WERE
GONNA PUT THIS.
THIS INFRASTRUCTURE AND THEN
SECOND THE TOOL I DESCRIBED
EARLIER THIS EVEY I PRO TOOL
IDENTIFIES PLACES IT'S IT'S NOT
A MAGIC PILL BUT IDENTIFIES
PLACES WHERE THE BEST
INFRASTRUCTURE. SUITS THE
LOCATION SO YOU HAVE THESE DC
FAST CHARGER IS THAT WILL GIVE
YOU A. EIGHTY PERCENT CHARGE IN
TWENTY MINUTES OR SO IT BUT A
LOT MORE EXPENSIVE SUITE ONE PUT
THOSE IN A LOT OF PLACES WHERE
PEOPLE ARE GONNA BE AT WORK IN
THEIR CAR CAN SITTHERE FOR
EIGHT HOURS AND IT DOESN'T
MATTER THAT THEY HAVE A VERY
FAST CHARGER. PUTTING CORRIDORS
SALE WAY TO VEGAS ARE PLACES
WHERE PEOPLE WANT TO GO LONGER
DISTANCES THAT I WANT TO SIT FOR
THREE HOURS TO GET ENOUGH CHARGE
TO GET TO THE HOTEL OR WHEREVER
THEIR DESTINATION IS SO. WE'VE
OR MAKING THOSE DECISIONS VERY
DYNAMICALLY AND WERE LEARN AN
AWFUL LOT AS WE GO FORWARD.
I. APPRECIATE THAT AND I GUESS
THE CHALLENGES THEY HAVE IF THE
INVESTMENTS ARE GOING SAY FOR
EXAMPLE INTO. IN THE BAY AREA
AND TO SAN DIEGO AND YOU'RE
LEAVING THEIR THE MIDDLE PART OF
THE STATE.
YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF A NOT
INVESTING AND CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE I THINK YOU'RE
GONNA SEE IT. A
DISPROPORTIONATE.
YOU KNOW.
BUT I GUESS NON USAGE OF THE
TECHNOLOGY IF PEOPLE CAN GET TO
WHERE THEY NEED TO GO. UP IN
TERMS OF THE THE REBATES OUT
WHAT IS THE CURRENT REBATE NOW
AND WHAT DO YOU.
DEBATED IT
IT DOESN'T NEED TO BE TO REACH
EVER EVER EVER.
SIGNIFICANT GOAL OF FIVE
MILLION.
ZEDS ON THE ROAD BY TWENTY
THIRTY.
YEP THANK YOU AT THE CURRENT
REBATE FOR A FULL BATTERY
ELECTRIC.
VEHICLE IS TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
IT'S FIVE THOUSAND FOUR A
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL.
VEHICLE IT SAID FIFTEEN HUNDRED
FOR A PLUGIN HYBRID VEHICLE AND
NINE HUNDRED FOR ELECTRIC
MOTORCYCLE.
A IN TERMS OF I'M WHAT IT TAKES
TO ACHIEVE THAT GOAL WE'VE LAID
OUT A PLAN.
TO GET US THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE LEVEL OF
INCENTIVE IS CONSISTENT WITH
WHAT IT TAKES TO BUILD THAT
SUSTAINABLE MARKET. THAT IN
COMBINATION WITH REQUIREMENTS ON
MANUFACTURERS TO ENSURE THAT
THOSE VEHICLES ARE BEING MADE.
AND THE INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS THAT YOU'VE HEARD
ABOUT.
SO THAT THERE'S KIND OF GENERAL.
PUBLIC ACCEPTANCE AT DOING FOR
THE ABILITY TO REFUEL. A IN
ADDITION THIS ISN'T THE ONLY
PIECE OF.
WHAT'S NECESSARY IN ORDER TO GET
THE TECHNOLOGY OUT IN THE MARKET
WE NEED TO ENSURE THE PEOPLE
KNOW ABOUT IT AND SO THERE'S A
LOT OF EFFORTS. TO INCREASE
CONSUMER AWARENESS AND EDUCATION
ABOUT THE TECHNOLOGIES INCLUDING
EVENTS SUCH AS WRITING DRIVES
WHERE YOU CAN JUST GET PEOPLE IN
THE VEHICLES. LET THEM
EXPERIENCE THEM I GIVE THEM
INFORMATION ABOUT THEM THE TYPES
OF VEHICLES THAT ARE AVAILABLE
SHOW THEM THAT THOSE VEHICLES
CAN MEET THEIR NEEDS AND THAT
THEY'RE FUN TO DRIVE.
DONE A IN TERMS OF THE PLAN WHAT
DO YOU DO ANTICIPATED AN
INCREASE IN THE IN THE.
THE REBATE AT THE SUBSIDY.
I KNOW WE DON'T EXPECT ANY
CHANGES SINCE
SO YOU EXPECTED THE STATE.
BUT THE TWENTY FIVE FIVE
THOUSAND FIFTEEN HUNDRED NINE
HUNDRED DOLLARS LEVEL.
THAT'S RIGHT FOR THAT FOR THE
NEAR TERM.
IN THE LONG TERM WILL HAVE TO
EVALUATE WHETHER THERE NEEDS TO
BE CHANGES.
BUT IT THIS TIME THAT'S WHAT WE
EXPECT.
IN DIFFERENCE THE CHAIR UP A
WHAT IS THE AVERAGE PRICE OF A
OF A ZEV.
NOT NOT OWNING ONE MYSELF.
.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE AVERAGE
PRICES BUT IT YOU KNOW CAN GIVE
YOU A COUPLE OF EXAMPLES I AM
THE THE THE LEAF WHICH IS KIND
OF A WELL KNOWN.
AS THEIR MISSION VEHICLE IS IN
THE THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLAR
RANGE.
COURSE YOU KNOW OPTIONS
DEPENDING CAN BE MORE OR LESS%
THAN THAT.
AND AND NOT SO A FAIRLY TYPICAL
ONE THEIR LEASE PRICES.
THAT CAN ACTUALLY BE MUCH LESS
EXPENSIVE UNDER TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH AND THEN OF
COURSE IF YOU'RE A LOW INCOME
CONSUMER OR MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR. I'M GETTING
THE HIGHER AMOUNT OF REBATES.
THEN.
THOSE LEASE RATES CAN GO DOWN
QUITE SIGNIFICANTLY SO I JUST SO
I UNDERSTAND THERE'S AT THAT IS
OUR SLIDING SCALE FOR THE REBATE
IN TERMS OF. FOR LOW INCOME TO
BADLY RIGHT GAFFER LOW INCOME
THERE'S A THAT THERE'S SOME
THRESHOLD QUESTIONS THAT WOULD
NEED TO BE SATISFIED BUT THERE
IS A HIGHER REBATE THAT SO TEN
WHAT WOULD THAT BE BABY I THINK.
.
TO US ARE TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS
HIGHER.
IT WAS A LEAD FOR AT FIVE
HUNDRED WITH A HUNDRED AND SEVEN
THOUSAND.
TODAY ADDRESS A INFRASTRUCTURE
GAPPING TO IT OBJECTIVE WITH
JUST ONE OF THE THINGS THAT IF I
THINK BY THIS PROPOSAL'S ACTIVE
DRIVE MONEY AND FILL THE GAPS
YOU'RE MENTIONING SO WHERE. WE
DON'T HAVE HAPPEN IS IS THE DEEP
PENETRATION IN THE COURT MARKETS
AND NOT HAVE IT SPREAD OUT
THROUGHOUT THE REST THE STATE'S
THAT'S REALLY HAD A FUNDAMENTAL
TODAY WITH. THE WAY OF THINKING
OR DOING THAT BOTH IN TERMS OF
INVESTMENT BUT ALSO. WITH
BUILDING SANDERS TO RAISING THE
MINIMUM BUILDING CENTER
THRESHOLD FOR NEW BUILDINGS HAVE
EVEY CABLES LOW SHERIDAN'S BUILT
INTO THAT SURE WE OBVIOUSLY WANT
PEOPLE TO DRIVE TO BAKERSFIELD
SO EXACTLY NEEDED TO.
OPPONENTS.
THINK WE SURE THANK YOU ALL FOR
THE PRESENTATION.
I THINK THE WORD THAT WAS USED
WAS ECOSYSTEM LOTS OF DIFFERENT
PARTIES INVOLVED HERE. AND LA
ARISTA CONCERNED JUST ABOUT THE
OVERALL COORDINATION HERE SO IS
IS THE MONEY THE TWO THIRTY FIVE
IN THIS IS A.
STANGEL INVESTMENT OVER TIME IS
A TO THIRTY FIVE GOING TO THE
ENERGY COMMISSION IN THE ENERGY
COMMISSION WILL BE.
SORT OF AT THE CENTER OF THIS
HUB IF YOU WILL.
IN TERMS OF COORDINATION JUST
THAT AFFIRMATION THAT THAT
THAT'S ACCURATE AND THEN IN
TERMS OF REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
OUR ABILITY TO ACTUALLY MEET
THESE METRICS UP OVER TIME I
MEAN I FULLY SUPPORT WE NEED BE
BUILDING OUT THIS INFRASTRUCTURE
BUT THE QUESTION IS.
YOU KNOW WHAT ARE WE GETTING FOR
THAT TO THIRTY FIVE AND AND ARE
WE ACTUALLY. MEETING OUR
BENCHMARK SO CAN YOU JUST SPEAK
TO THE CORONATION.
AND THE AND THE.
AND THE MEASUREMENT OF OUR
SUCCESS HERE BUILDING OUT THIS
INDUSTRY.
AND SO MAYBE IF THIS ON THE
COORDINATION LIKE WE'RE ALL WE
HAVE REGULAR MEETINGS AT THE
PRINCIPAL LEVEL AND AT THE STAFF
LEVEL. I'M ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT THE EXECUTIVE ORDER
ICTATES IS HAVING UPDATING
THERE'S YOUR MACHINE LEGAL
ACTION PLAN. AND SO THERE'S A
LOT OF IT ACTIONS AT ALL THE
AGENCIES TAKE
TO MAKE THIS MARKET HAPPENED I
THINK IN TERMS OF THE INVESTMENT
THOUGH THE REALLY THE. HUB OF
THIS OVER TALKING AT THAT UNIT
THIRTY FIVE IN THE CONTINUING
ALLOCATION IS THAT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION.
AND YOU MAY BEGIN TALK ABOUT
YOUR PROCESS OF.
ANNUAL UPDATES AND.
DISCUSS YOUR WE WE DO WHAT WE DO
REGULAR ANNUAL UPDATES WITH ALL
THESE STATISTICS TO GIVE YOU A
LITTLE SENSE OF COSTS WHICH WILL
TRANSLATE INTO WHAT YOU GET FOR
AN INVESTMENT OF TURNER THIRTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. WE HAVEN'T
FINALIZED EXACTLY HOW WE THINK
IT'S BEST PARSED OUT IT DEPENDS
IN PART ON READINESS OF SAY THE
HYDROGEN FOLKS AND AND A LOT OF
FACTUAL OR LOOKING AT THAT VERY
CLOSELY RIGHT NOW. BUT TO GIVE
YOU SOME SENSE PRICES VERY AND
THE GOOD NEWS IS JUST LIKE THE
VEHICLES THEMSELVES THE COSTS
ARE GOING DOWN BUT TODAY A ROUGH
COST OF A WHAT WE CALL A LEVEL
TWO CHARGER WHICH IS LIKE TO
TWENTY WHAT RUNS YOUR DRYER AT
HOME. IS ABOUT IN THE FIVE TO
SIX THOUSAND DOLLAR RANGE.
.
THE LEVEL TWO CHARTERS THAT
DELIVER MUCH MORE POWER MUCH
MORE QUICKLY CLOSE TO A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS SO AGAIN OUR
OUR PROPOSAL IS TO BALANCE THE
BULK OF THE CHARGERS BEING LEVEL
TWO. BECAUSE THEY'RE CHEAPER.
BUT MAKING SURE WE CITE SOME OF
THESE.
THESE TO FAST CHARGERS ABOUT
TEN THOUSAND OF MISS THE GOAL
OUT OF THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND IN THE PLACES WHERE IT
REALLY MAKE SENSE TO DO SO BUT
WHAT WILL EACH YEAR TRUE THESE
UP AND BE ABLE TO REFLECT WHAT.
WHAT THE IN INVESTMENT BOUGHT A
HOUSE AND A WHAT THE TARGET
STILL LOOK LIKE?
IN THIS MAYBE FATE THE EVF PRO
THAT WE MENTIONED EARLIER THE
GIVES US IN ONE OF THE. NEWEST
AND MOST EXCITING TOOL SEXY
TRACK PROGRESS SO YOU CAN LOOK
AT THE WHERE THE VESSELS ARE
GOING HOW THE MARKET'S BEEN
RESPONDING HAS LOTS OF VARIABLES
THAT CAN THROW AT IT ACTUALLY.
REFINED AS WE GO THROUGH TIME
AND I THINK THAT'S ON THE PLUGIN
CHARGING SIDE AND ON THE
HYDROGEN SIDE THERE'S THAT A
RESOURCES BOARD HAS IT THAT
COUPLE OF. PARTNER MODELS THAT.
CULTURE IN CHAT CALIFORNIA
HYDROGEN INFRASTRUCTURE TOOL
THAT CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN
ASSESSMENT TOOL IT'S KIND OF FUN
PLAY.
BUT SO THAT THEY WORK TOGETHER
VERY WELL CHEATING CHATTING. BUT
THAT I'M.
AND THE IDEA OF THEIR TWO IS
ALSO THE IT'S IT'S ALL BASED ON
TRAVEL LIKE WHERE WHERE PEOPLE
GOING TO HOW ARE THEY RESPONDING
TO THESE INVESTMENTS AND SO. WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
BEING STRATEGIC AND INTER INTER
OF ABOUT THE PROCESS OF
PREPARING A LOT AS WE GO ALONG.
I'VE IT'S POINTING OUT THAT
ACTUALLY.
THE MECHANISM THIS PROGRAM IT'S
NOT LIKE THE URGE COMMISIONS
GONNA PUT OUT ONE SOLICITATION
FOR TWO HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
MILLION. THE EXISTING PROGRAM
PUTS OUT MULTIPLES WITH HAITIANS
THERE'S A WHOLE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS BETWEEN THE TIME THEY
RELEASE THEIR DRAFT PLAN AND
FINALIZE PLAN. WHICH ALLOWS THE
DIFFERENT SOLICITATIONS TO BE
TARGETED TO SPECIFIC.
ISSUES OR AREAS THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED AND SO I'M WE ARE
ADDRESSING THE GAPS ALSO THAT
WHICH. ALSO INCLUDES STAKEHOLDER
INPUT.
SURE
EVELYN.
JUST ONE QUESTION THAT POPPED IN
MY HEAD I'M. IN TERMS OF IF WE
IF WE DO COME CLOSER AS WEEK
PROGRESSED TO.
POTENTIALLY REACHING THIS GOAL
WHAT IS THE IMPACT A AT THAT
FROM THAT PART FINANCE IN TERMS
OF THAT ON THE GAS TAX REVENUE
BECAUSE IT OF COURSE. HE'S
VEHICLES DON'T PAY A GAS TAX SO
WHAT IS THE IMPACT THE TO IN
TERMS OF THAT.
A METAL ME DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
YES.
AT THE MARGIN.
.
TO THE EXTENT THAT IT.
IF THERE'S A SUBSTITUTION A
FACT.
WHERE?
PETROLEUM BASED VEHICLES ARE.
SHIFTED TO MORE ELECTRIC
VEHICLES THERE WOULD BE LE LET'S
REVENUE THERE BUT.
THAT WOULD BE REFLECTED IN.
THE REVENUE PROJECTIONS OVER
TIME.
ASSOCIATE WITH THE GAS TAX AND.
WE.
.
IT IT WOULD BE.
ADJUST ACCORDINGLY AS THE YEARS
GO ON I GUESS WHAT I WOULD.
WHEN I WOULD SAY IS IS THAT
EVEN. UNDER.
THESE TARGETS IT WOULD STILL BE
A SIGNIFICANT YOU KNOW NUMBER
OF.
.
CARS THAT WOULD STILL BE USING
GASOLINE TOO SO IT'S IT'S A LONG
TERM.
MOVING THE NEEDLE DO YOU HAVE
ANY PROJECTIONS AND IN TERMS OF.
IT FIVE MILLION.
ZEDS ARE ON THE ROAD BY TWENTY
THIRTY GMT PROTECTIONS OF WHAT
THAT WOULD BE OVER TIME BUT I
WOULD HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU ON
THAT BUT I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
FOLLOW UP. I THINK I THINK THAT
THE LARGER CONCERN IS THAT WE
HAVE MORE VEHICLES ON THE ROAD.
THAT.
THAT WE OUT CLEARLY MORE MILES
POTENTIALLY BEING DRIVEN LESS
MONEY COMING IN FOR ROADS AND
THEN OF COURSE.
.
SINCE THE GAS TAX IS REGRESSIVE
THAT YOU HAVE THAT THAT FALL THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE STILL
PAYING THE GAS TAX ARE GOING
BEYOND THE LOW INCOME SCALE.
WE HAVE ABOUT THAT I JUST SHY I
THINK OF ABOUT THIRTY MILLION
VEHICLES ON THE ROAD TODAY LIGHT
DUTY VEHICLES SO IF YOU FIGURE
WE SUCCEED IN GET A FIVE BY
TWENTY THIRTY. MAYBE THAN THE
GRAND TOTAL WILL BE LARGER BUT
GIVE YOU SOME SENSE OF THE
PERCENTAGE IN WHAT WHAT THE
IMPACT MIGHT BE BUT SURE ARE FOR
SIZE WHY I WOULD GUESS THAT YOUR
PUBLIC PLANNING FOR SOME
EXPONENTIAL GROWTH. WHICH MEANS
THAT WILL HAVE AN EXPONENTIAL
REDUCTION IN GAS TAX REVENUE.
BUT THERE'S NO FURTHER QUESTIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEAN BEFORE
YOU.
LEAVE THOUGH.
.
WE'RE GONNA TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
AT THE END OF PANEL THREE.
BUT I'D ASK THAT YOU STICK
AROUND A TO HEAR THE PUBLIC
COMMENT BUT BE.
I MISTER TANK CHAIR TING IS
PLANNING ON RETURNING IN JUST A
FEW MINUTES AND I THINK MY
UNDERSTANDING IS HE HAS SOME
QUESTIONS.
POSSIBLY FOR ALL THREE PANELS
LE BUT TO HAVE.
DEFINITELY FOR YOURS.
TO WILL PROCEED NOW WITH PANEL
TO
.
WELCOME.
PLEASE PROCEED.
BUT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS I'M RUN LENDERS
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE.
BUT DURING OUR COMMENTS ALL BE
REFERRING TO SOME FIGURES FROM
ARE A RESOURCE AND ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION.
REPORT WHICH SHOULD BE
DISTRIBUTED TO YOU UP BY THE
SERGEANT OF THE SECTION. ON THIS
PROPOSAL BEGINS ON PAGE SIXTY
ONE OF THAT REPORT.
SO IT BECAME A THING ARE OUR
MAIN OBJECTIVES OF THE CAR TO.
OUR COMMENTS ON THE
ADMINISTRATION ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE OR ZEV INFRASTRUCTURE
PROPOSAL ARE TWO. EPISODES OF
THIS PROPOSAL REPRESENTS A
SIGNIFICANT SHIFT IN FUNDING AND
THE FUNDING STRUCTURE FOR
VARIOUS GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
AND AIR QUALITY RELATED PROGRAMS
THAT RAISES IMPORTANT POLICY
QUESTIONS.
TO HIGHLIGHT ASPECTS OF THE
PROPOSALS.
IMPLEMENTATION IN COORDINATION
WITH OTHER SIMILAR PROGRAMS THAT
WE BELIEVE LEGISLATURE.
WELL WHAT'S A TO OBTAIN MORE
INFORMATION ON FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION AT THE
HIGHLIGHTS.
FOR CONSIDERATION WHETHER. KEY
COMPONENTS OF THE.
A PROPOSAL LINE WOULD LOOK WITH
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES.
UP BASED ON THOSE OBJECTIVES WE
HAVE THREE KEY RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR THE LEGISLATURE WITH REGARD
TO THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL.
UP FIRST WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECT
ADMINISTRATION TO PROVIDE MORE
INFORMATION TO ENABLE.
A IT TO PROPERLY EVALUATE THE
MERITS OF THE PROPOSAL SECOND.
OUT WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
DIRECTLY ADMINISTRATION TO A
DEVELOP A MORE DETAILED STRATEGY
FOR SPENDING. UP RECORDING
SPENDING FOR THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
ACROSS THE VARIOUS STATE
PROGRAMS.
AND A THIRD WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER A WHETHER
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
USE VARIOUS SPECIAL FUNDS AND
RICK PARA FUNDS TO SUPPORT. AYE
THIS INFRASTRUCTURE IS
CONSISTENT WITH ITS OWN
PRIORITIES.
WITH REGARD TO OUR FIRST
RECOMMENDATION A SPECIFICALLY
RURAL RECOMMENDED.
TO THE LEGISLATURE ABOUT IT
REQUEST ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
ABOUT HOW FUNDING WOULD AFFECT
KEY POLICY OUTCOMES.
US SUCH IS THE GUY GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSION LEVELS. OUR IT'S
ASSESSMENT THE POTENTIAL RISKS
AND COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH A
SUBSTANTIAL EXPANSIVE THERE
HAVE.
A MORE DETAILED JUSTIFICATION
FOR THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
REQUESTED FOR THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE.
A PLAN FOR.
EVALUATING.
THE OUTCOMES AFTER PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION BEGINS.
WE FIND THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL RAISES
KEY POLICY QUESTIONS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WILL WANT TO
CONSIDER BEFORE ALLOCATING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. US SUCH AS
THE COST EFFECTIVENESS OF THIS
TYPE OF INITIATIVE.
COMPARED TO OTHER EMISSION
REDUCTIONS PROGRAMS ESPECIALLY
GIVEN.
BUT THIS PROPOSAL IS DIRECTED AT
AND MISS THE SOURCE WHICH IS
CURRENTLY.
COVERED UNDER THE STATE'S CAP
AND TRADE SYSTEM.
ADDITIONALLY THE LEGISLATURE
WILL WANT TO CONSIDER WHAT ARE
THE PROPOSALS ASSOCIATED RISKS
AND POSSIBLE MITIGATION POLICIES
AS MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY.
A SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE IN JOBS%
COULD.
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED GAS TAX
REVENUE.
OR LEAD TO CHALLENGES FOR GRID
OPERATORS.
TRYING TO BALANCE THE GRID.
DEPENDING ON WHEN.
ELECTRIC ZEV OWNERS CHARTS
THEIR VEHICLES.
A WE NOTE THAT THE MUSIC ENERGY
COMMISSION HAS SINCE.
VERY RECENTLY RELEASED A REPORT
ON ELECTRIC VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTIONS THAT
DOES DISCUSS SOME.
OF THE TYPES OF INFORMATION
RECOMMENDED THE LEGISLATURE
OBTAIN THIS INCLUDES.
DETAILS ON THE METHODS DATA AND
ASSUMPTIONS USED IN ITS GAP
ANALYSIS.
HIGH LEVEL SUMMARY WHICH CAN BE
FOUND ON A. FIGURE TWENTY THREE
UNPAID SIXTY FIVE OF A REPORT.
OUT WHICH IS THE BASIS FOR ITS
ESTIMATES OF FUTURE REQUIRED I'D
SEVEN FOR STRUCTURE ASSOCIATED
PUBLIC FUNDING.
AS WELL AS ITS PLANS FOR
EVALUATING PROGRAM OUTCOMES.
PUNT IMPLEMENTATION.
WELL WE HAVE NOT YET HAD A
CHANCE TO THAT
CLOSED EXAMINED THIS RECENTLY
RELEASED REPORT HOW WE WRECKED
WE WELCOME THAT THE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION AND ANY FURTHER
INSIDE IT CAN PROVIDE TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON. OTHER QUESTIONS
THAT YOU POSED.
WITH REGARD TO A SECOND
RECOMMENDATION WE FIND THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION.
DOESN'T HAVE A OVER ARCHING
STRATEGY FOR CORDONING SPENDING
FOR VARIOUS STATE PROGRAMS.
IF YOU LOOK ON PAGE OF FIGURE
TWENTY ONE ON PAGE SIXTY TWO OF
OUR REPORT.
I IT SHOWS THAT THE STATE
CURRENTLY HAS A WIDE ARRAY
OBSERVE INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAMS
WITH BUDGETS RANGING IN THE LOW
MILLIONS TO HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS. AND FACILITATED BY
SEVERAL DIFFERENT AGENCIES.
ARE WE RECKON REMOVED RECOGNIZE
THAT ARE THE PRIMARY AGENCIES
INVOLVED HAVE INCREASED EFFORTS.
TO COMMUNICATE THEIR INDIVIDUAL.
EFFORTS.
HOWEVER GIVEN THE MASSIVE MULTI
AGENCY EFFORT WE BELIEVE.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO HAVE A
DETAILED PLAN AND ESTABLISHED
SYSTEM OF OVERALL ACCOUNTABILITY
ARE DESCRIBING HOW FUNDING FOR
VARIOUS STATE PROGRAMS WOULD.
NOT BE TARGETED TO THE HIGHS
PARTY LOCATIONS AND TECHNOLOGIES
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT OTHER SOURCES
THE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE FUNDING.
BUT FINALLY WITH REGARD TO OUR
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION'S.
UP PLAN PRIORITISES
FUNDING FOR THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
OVER OTHER POTENTIAL USES.
I FEW COME UP FIGURE TWENTY TO
YOU ON PAGE SIXTY THREE OF
REPORT SHOWS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL WOULD
SHIFT.
ALL OF THE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR A OUR FPTP ALLOCATION TO.
A SEVEN FOR STRUCTURE AND AWAY
FROM VEGAS CLEAN VEHICLE UP
PROGRAMS THAT CURRENTLY FUNDS.
OF WE ALSO KNOW THE PROPOSAL'S
SHIFT SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONE TIME FUND BALANCES FROM
PEORIA A OUR BTP AND AIR QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT FUND. AS WELL AS
REDIRECTS UNSPENT RATE PAIR
FUNDS FROM OTHER EXPIRING NEW
SOLAR HOMES PARTNERSHIP TO THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE INITIATIVE.
I WE BELIEVE THE LEGISLATURE
WILL WANT TO CONSIDER WHETHER
THE SHIPS ARE LINED WITH ITS
PRIORITIES.
OR WHETHER I PREFER IS A
DIFFERENT APPROACH TO A FUNDING
AT THIS INFRASTRUCTURE.
I THIS CONCLUDES OUR REMARKS I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY.
THANK YOU.
DOCTOR BROWN.
WELCOME THANK YOU THINK THAT
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR HAVING ME
AND AUSTIN BROWN I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE UC
DAVIS POLICY INSTITUTE FOR
ENERGY ENVIRONMENT ECONOMY. I'M
I'M WHERE I GOT REALLY LIMITED
TIME BUT I WANT TO GO THROUGH A
BRIEF SUMMARY OF WHAT IS
ACTUALLY A MORE THAN A DECADE OF
RESEARCH.
USE GIVES A BUYER COLLEAGUES
ELSEWHERE ON THE NEEDS AND
OUTCOMES ASSOCIATED WITH EXACTLY
THE SORTS OF PROGRAMS ARE
TALKING ABOUT HERE TODAY.
UNTIL START WITH WITH ONE THING
WE KNOW FOR ABSOLUTE ABSOLUTE
FOR CERTAIN WHICH IS THAT YOU
CAN'T GET TO ARGUE HAS GASKELL'S
OVERALL OR LONG TO VENUS
GASKELL'S WITHOUT. A RAPID.
SHIFT HIS ADS IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR.
NOW IT'S IN SEXUAL IT'S AN
ESSENTIAL INGREDIENT.
AND THERE'S A STRONG NEED FOR
COMPANY POLICIES FOR THESE SORTS
OF VEHICLES IN THE TRANSITION
PHASE WHICH WHERE WHERE WE FIND
OURSELVES IN RIGHT NOW. AND
WITHOUT THOSE ARE TO CUP MANY
POLICIES.
COMPANIES.
I HAVE THE LUXURY OF
PROCRASTINATING AND WAITING FOR
A FOR LATER TO MEET.
TO TO BRING UP CLOSER TO
VEHICLES.
AND WE DEFTLY WOULDN'T HAVE
SEEN THE SAME KIND OF PROGRESS
WE SEE TODAY ABOUT THOSE
COMPLEMENTARY POLICIES.
.
IN PRACTICE WHAT WE SEE IS THAT
LEADING CITIES IN THE U. ANY I'D
STATES AND IN CALIFORNIA AND
LEADING COUNTRIES AROUND THE
WORLD THE ONES THAT SUCCEED
ACTION HAVE A PORTFOLIO OF
POLICIES THEY DON'T USE A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH. AND THEY
DO A WIDER RANGE OF THINGS I'M
WORK MY COLLEAGUES AND THE SOME
OF OUR COLLEAGUES AT EXTERNAL.
NGOS HAVE ASSESSED THE SORTS OF
POLICIES AND THEIR EFFECTIVENESS
AND HAVE FOUND AT LEAST FIVE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF POLICIES THAT
HAVE BEEN USED.
ROUTED TO DIFFERENT AGREES
THERE'S PURCHASE INCENTIVES SUCH
AS A TAX CREDITS OR REBATES LIKE
THAT WE HAVE IN THE UNITED
STATES IN CALIFORNIA.
THERE'S RECURRING INCENTIVES
LIKE ABOUT THAT HOV LANE ACCESS
THAT WE HAVE IN MANY MANY OTHERS
AS WELL POTENTIAL FOR PARKING
INCENTIVES OF SORTS OF RECURRING
THINGS THE EXPERIENCE REGULARLY.
AND THERE'S REGULATORY
MECHANISMS SUCH AS HOW WE HAVE
THAT THIS HAVE MADE IN
CALIFORNIA HEATHER INCLUDE
INCLUDED IN A VEHICLE FUEL
ECONOMY STANDARDS OVERALL.
THERE IS INFRASTRUCTURE
DEPLOYMENT WHICH YOU HEARD A LOT
ABOUT IS ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL
INGREDIENT ARM AND THEN THERE'S
AN EDUCATION OUTREACH COMPONENT
AND I'LL TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT THAT.
DE IT IN A MOMENT.
WE'VE SEEN MANY OF THESE
POLICIES OF ANY USE TO.
TO REALLY A STRONG SUCCESS IN
CALIFORNIA'S WE HEARD A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE OTHER REVIEWS THAT
BEEN AVAILABLE IN COMPLEMENT
WITH THE FEDERAL TAX CREDIT
THAT'S
IT'S STILL AVAILABLE.
THAT'S A STRONG INCENTIVE IT
BRINGS THE IS A RESERVES ON THE
MARKET DOWN TO AFFORDABILITY FOR
A HUGE VARIETY OF PEOPLE ON
WHERE THOSE VEHICLES WOULD
OTHERWISE BE OUT OF THEIR PRICE
RANGE.
AND WE'VE SEEN VERY STRONG
INFRASTRUCTURE DEPLOYMENT AND WE
DID HEAR THAT THAT.
WE HAVEN'T KEPT PACE WITH THE
NEED.
SO I I.
EXPERIENCED THIS MYSELF THIS
MORNING I AYE VOTES STUDIED ZAPS
FOR ABOUT TEN YEARS A LITTLE BIT
AND EVEY ORDER FOR FOR THE LAST
YEAR.
AND ON MY WAY HERE I FOUND THAT
EVERY CHARGING STATION IN THE
PARKING STRUCTURE WAS FULL I
PICKED THAT I GO TO THAT PARKING
STRUCTURE BECAUSE I KNOW THEY
HAVE CHARGERS AND OF COURSE THIS
NEVER ENOUGH LIKE UP THERE
AROUND NINE AND. AND AND ALL ALL
BOOKED UP SO YES WE HAVE
INSTALLED A TON MORE
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT THERE.
THEY'RE STILL FALLING BEHIND
THE ACTUAL NEEDS THESE VEHICLES
ENTER THE MARKET.
I'M BUT WE HAVE SEEN PRETTY
STRONG CHRISTIAN SALES CERTAINLY
WORK WERE LEAVING THE COUNTRY.
COMPARE FAVORABLY TO A LOT OF
COUNTRIES THAT HAVE TRIED THIS A
WORLDWIDE.
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE THIS THE
THE.
SPECIFICS OF THE INCENTIVES WE
HAVE I MEAN WE SEE A LOT MORE
MODELS AVAILABLE THAT'S A REALLY
BIG DEAL HER THERE'S MORE THAT
FORTY ALREADY ON THAT'S UP IF
YOU GO BACK JUST LIKE BACK IN
TWENTY TEN THERE'S ACTUALLY ZERO
MODELS AVAILABLE SIXTY
INCREDIBLY RAPID SHIFT.
I'M IN JUST THE LAST THE LAST
EIGHT YEARS.
I WOULD HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO
STILL SO THOSE MODELS ARE STILL
DISPROPORTIONATELY SMALL
VEHICLES AND SEDANS WE DON'T
HAVE AVAILABLE VEHICLES AND
OTHER TYPES. AND WE REALLY NEED
TO SEE THAT SHIFT.
I'M STUDIES OF DEALERSHIPS FINDS
THAT BIT MOST DEALERSHIPS DON'T
KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THE ZEV THAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED BE SELLING IF
THEY DO YOU KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
THEM THEY KNOW THEY DON'T WANT
TO SELL THEM TO CONSUMERS AND
SIR SECRET SHOPPER APPROACHES
HAVE SHOWN THAT. THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF VERY FEW DEALERS REALLY
HAVE THE TOOLS AND WILLINGNESS
TO TRY TO ACTUALLY SELL THESE
VEHICLES TO PEOPLE. AND THEN
MAYBE THE MOST SOBERING FINDING
OF THE LAST YEAR OF OUR
RESEARCH.
IS THAT SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN
TO BETWEEN TWENTY FOURTEEN AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN PUBLIC
AWARENESS AMONG TALK ABOUT
ATTITUDES BUT AWARENESS OF ZAPS
THE AVAILABILITY OF OF.
ELECTRIC VEHICLES HYDROGELS OF
VEHICLES HASN'T BUDGED NOTHING
MOVED AN INCH
WE FIND THAT WHEN WE SURVEYED
PEOPLE WITH THE SAME QUESTIONS
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THAT VERY SIMPLE STUFF
LIKE.
CAN YOU NAME THE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE WHAT'S FOR SALE TODAY.
OF THOSE NUMBERS IT DIDN'T MOVE
AT ALL.
AND THAT PUTS US TO AN ENORMOUS
AWARENESS AND ENGAGEMENT GAP
PEOPLE DON'T GO INTO THE
DEALERSHIP FOOT FROM THE BY
LARGE ANDSAY I NEED TO BUY AND
YOU WHAT IF YOU GOT. LEGAL WHEN
LOOKING FOR A VEHICLE THAT MEETS
THEIR NEEDS THAT MEETS THE SIZE
THE CHARACTERISTICS THE
PERFORMANCE
STYLETHAT THEY'RE LOOKING FOR
AND THAT IF THEIR WARES OBSERVER
OPTION AT WORK THEY'RE INFORMED
OF THAT BY THEIR DEALER WHICH AS
WE HEARD THE THEY REALLY ARE.
THEN MAYBE THEY WILL CONSIDER
ONE.
SO THIS AWARENESS AND ENGAGEMENT
PIECE IS AN ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL
INGREDIENT THAT WE STILL SEEM TO
BE MISSING. THE NUMBERS ARE VERY
LOW EVEN IN CALIFORNIA.
AND IT'S NOT CLEAR THAT WE HAVE
THE
I INFRASTRUCTURE THAT ENGAGEMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE YET TO.
TO HELP THOSE NUMBERS GROW.
SO IF THERE IS ONE SORT OF BIG
ITS INGREDIENTS I WOULD SAY IT'S
ON THAT ENGAGEMENT AND OUTREACH
PIECE WE NEED SOME SORT OF A. A
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY TO GET
THIS SORT OF INFORMATION INTO
INTO PEOPLE'S HANDS WE FIND THAT
ONCE PEOPLE ROT ONE PUPIL RIDING
OR DRIVE YOU VIEWS THEY HAVE
VERY POSITIVE ATTITUDES THEY
APPRECIATE THE PERFORMANCE. A
ZEV OWNERS SUPPORT VERY HIGH
SATISFACTION IN PART BECAUSE
THEY GET TO DO THINGS LIKE NEVER
GO TO THE GAS STATION WHICH IS
THAT WHICH IS GREAT PRIVILEGE
AND REFILL AT HOME OR AT WORK.
BUT THE.
pGETTING BEYOND THE EARLY MARKET
THAT WE'VE SEEN SO FAR ON IT IS
THAT IS A PRETTY SOBER AND ONE
AND ONE THAT I THINK WE NEED TO
TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY.
FROM THAT AND AND THINKING
REALLY RETHINKING IN A DRAMATIC
WAY WHAT ARE INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS ARE AND I THINK ASSEMBLY
POSITIVE STEPS.
IN THE PROPOSAL THAT THAT'S
HERE OF GOING BIGGER REALLY
DOING MORE CONCERTED EFFORTS
THINKING ABOUT ISSUES LIKE LIKE
HAD WE DECIDED HOW TO ACTUALLY
MAKE SURE PEOPLE ARE AWARE OF
IT.
I CAN I CAN SAY IS THAT AS THAT
YOU'RE THAT'S IT'S STILL AN
ISSUE FOR E. VIS AS WELL AS I'M
SURE IT IS FOR FOR FREE FOR FUEL
CELL VEHICLES. I'M GETTING THE
DATE OUT THERE SEE PEOPLE KNOW
ARE THESE.
CHARGING STATIONS AVAILABLE ARE
THEY WORKING WHAT KIND OF
CHARGING RATE WILL EXPECT AND
HOW MUCH WILL I PAY THIS
INFORMATION IS CURRENTLY REALLY
HARD FIGHT YET WE SOLD A LOT OF
WORK TO DO.
BUT THE THE RESEARCH UP IN
FIRST RIGHT THINK WE ALL KNOW
WHICH IS THAT WERE WERE DOING A
LOT OF THINGS RIGHT AND REALLY
MAKING A LOT OF PROGRESS.
SO FAR.
THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE NICE.
TREVAN.
I IN TERMS OF.
TODAY LEO IN TERMS OF THE
COORDINATED STRATEGY.
OR LACK THERE OF AT THE CURRENT
MOMENT WHAT AND WHAT VALUE DO
YOU RECOMMEND IS.
THEY FEATHER BEST PRACTICES OUT
THERE IN TERMS OF COORDINATION
OR HAD HAD IT HAD IMPROVED. THAT
COORDINATION.
RIGHT.
.
AS AS PREVIOUS MONTH AND THE
ADMINISTRATION DOES OBSERVE
ACTION PLAN AND THAT. DOES LAY
OUT OF IT QUICKLY A LOT OF THE.
HIGHER LEVEL TASKS AND CONVERT
ADMINISTRATIVE ROLES OF THESE.
OF.
WE WOULD LIKE SEIZE.
PERHAPS SOMETHING ALONG THOSE
LINES THAT DIRECTLY TARGETS THE
THE SPENDING AND ALSO.
PLACES MAYBE PREPS MORE VIA.
.
BURDEN OF ACCOUNTABILITY ANA.
OVER ARCHING ENTITY RATHER.
OTHER WE DO RECOGNIZE THERE'S A
LOT OF TALK AND A LOT OF.
KIND OF SHARING OF INFORMATION
WOULD BE.
PREPS HELPFUL TO HAVE.
AND OVER ARCHING.
AUTHORITY OR CAN ABILITY TO TO
MAKE SURE THAT. WHAT IS
HAPPENING IS HAPPENING AND AND
I'M A LAST QUESTION AND AT THE
ONE I POSE?
BEFORE IS IN TERMS OF THE LA
ANNOUNCES DO YOU HAVE NUMBERS IN
TERMS OF THE IMPACT TO A GAS TAX
REVENUE. IF IF WE USE AS WE
PROGRESS AT AND IN TERMS OF
MOORE'S THAT'S ON THE ROAD.
BUT.
NO ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE DO NOT
HAVE THE. PROJECTS AT THIS TIME.
IN JAPAN IF THAT'S OKAY AND JUST
MENTION THAT THERE IS A STUDY
THAT'S UNDER WAY CURRENTLY AT UC
DAVIS WAS CALLED FOR UNDER S. B.
ONE WHICH I EMISSIONS RAISING
THE GAS TAX I IMPLEMENTED A
FIRST EVER. A HUNDRED DOLLAR FEE
ON TV REGISTRATIONS THAT WOULD.
BEGIN TO. INCREASE THE FUNDING
AVAILABLE FROM THOSE VEHICLES
AYE IT LOOKS AT THE IMPACT ON
THE THAT THE GAS TAX REVENUE
GOING OUT.
AS WELL AS EXAMINES ALTERNATIVE
MECHANISMS FOR FUNDING THE ROAD
SYSTEM ONCE OF ADDRESS SOME OF
THE ISSUES YOU MENTIONED BEFORE
LIKE REGRESSIVITY.
THAT THE CENTRAL FINANCIAL
PARTISAN PROGRESS I'M HAPPY TO
GET YOU AN UPDATE ON IT THAT BE
HELPFUL.
THOUGH THE CENTRAL FINDING IS
THAT WERE ONE OF THE HAVE A
FUNNY IS THAT SO FAR AND FOR THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE OF THAT THIS
HAVE PROGRAM. THE IMPACTS ON
REVENUE FROM THOSE VEHICLES.
IS MUCH SMALLER THAN WHAT WE
SEE FROM THE IN IMPACT FROM
INFLATION A PREVIOUS TO TO
INCREASE INDEXING THAT THE GAS
TAX TO THAT TO TO INFLATION AND
THE IMPACT ON FUEL EFFICIENCY. I
INCREASING FUEL EFFICIENCY
POTENTIAL VEHICLES ACTUALLY MUCH
BIGGER.
IMPACT ON THE GAS TAX REVENUE
SO FAR.
AND AND CONTINUES TO BE THROUGH
THE THE BUTTON THAT PROGRAM'S
SET SO THAT I CAN HOURS IF I CAN
OWNERS IF I WANT SQUARE FOCUS SO
YOU'RE SAYING THAT. AS CARS
BECOME MORE FEW FUEL EFFICIENT
NOW THAT'S THE HAVING A LARGE
IMPACT ON THE GAS TAX REVENUE
YET MUCH LARGER BUT IN TERMS OF
THESE ADS RIGHT THAT'S ONLY
GOING TO IMPROVE LIKE. NOTE
WOULDN'T THAT.
EXACERBATE THE PROBLEM YET SO
IT'S CLEAR THAT WOULD THAT IN
THE LONG TERM WE NEED A WAY TO
FUND THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
TAKES ALL VEHICLES INTO ACCOUNT.
OKAY SO THAT SO IN TERMS OF THE
CONCLUSION THE CONCLUSION IS.
S. UNDEFINED I GUESS INTO TO THE
CITY BUT IN TERMS OF THE
HYPOTHESES.
YOU WERE GONNA ANTICIPATED
REDUCTIONS OVER AT THE FINE.
ADDITIONAL REVENUE SOURCES THOSE
THAT WOULD BE THAT IN THE LONG
TERM YOU NEED YOU NEED A WAY FOR
IT TO PAY FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
OKAY. SO THERE IS A REDUCTION
AND GUESS I SEVEN YOU THERE IS A
AND IT'S THERE DEFINITELY IS.
AND BECAUSE ORDERS MORE
VEHICLES ON THE MARKET AYE IT
IT'S JUST RELATIVE TO OTHER
FACTORS IT HASN'T BEEN LARGE WE
DON'T EXPECT TO BE. IN THAT IN
THE LIFETIME OF WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE SORT OF.
TWENTY THIRTY TIME FRAME FELL
AFTER THAT ABSOLUTELY PERFECT
WEEKENDS IN CONCERT.
OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
INTELLIGENCE.
IF YOU DON'T MIND STICKING
AROUND FOR A LITTLE WHILE
LONGER.
I GREATLY APPRECIATE THAT.
AND ARE THE FINAL PANEL ON THE
SET TOPIC IS SIR.
.
REGARDING GOT REAL WORLD SUCCESS
AND CHALLENGE AND WE'VE GOT
THREE PANELISTS COMING UP.
WELCOME TO HOLD IT.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE I'M NOT
SURE WHO'S GOING FIRST.
I I CAN START THANK YOU MISTER
CLEAN AIR AND MEMBERS ANTHONY
HARRIS AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
PUBLIC POLICY FOR CHARGE POINT.
WE ARE THE WORLD'S LARGEST
NETWORK OF THE V. CHARGING PORTS
WE HAVE OVER FORTY SIX THOUSAND
CHARGING POINTS TODAY TWENTY
EIGHT THOUSAND OF THOSE ARE
LOCATED HERE. IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE.
DESIGN MANUFACTURE AND DELIVER
A CHARGING STATION HARDWARE AND
NETWORK SERVICES FOR THE FULL
ARRAY OF DIFFERENT MARKET
SEGMENTS SO FROM. CHARGING IN
YOUR HOME RESIDENTS MULTI FAMILY
ALL THE WAY TO PUBLIC AND
WORKPLACE AND THEN.
AS REFERENCE BEFORE THE HIGH
SPEED DC FAST CHARGERS THAT WE
ARE TO POINT ALONG AYE
INTERSTATE CORRIDORS IN URBAN
HUBS AND AT THAT SCENE
TECHNOLOGIES BEING USED TO
CHARGE THE.
GROWING SECTOR OF MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY OUR VEHICLE
ELECTRIFICATION.
I'M CHUCK POINT WAS UP FOUNDED
AND WE ARE STILL HEADQUARTERED
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WHERE A HOME
GROWN CALIFORNIA BUSINESS THAT
HAS BEEN ABLE TO OUR GROWING
EXPAND AN EXPORT.
.
OUR MODEL BASED ON THE
SUCCESSFUL CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
POLICIES THAT WE HAVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA I'M MOST RECENTLY
LAUNCHING IN FOUR COUNTRIES
ACROSS. EUROPE AND THROUGHOUT
THIS TEN YEAR HISTORY.
WE'VE GAINED A LOT OF
INVALUABLE EXPERIENCE ON BOTH OF
THE.
BEST PRACTICES AS WELL AS
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES THAT COME
WITH DEPLOYING EVEY CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE ON TODAY I WANT
TO FOCUS SPECIFICALLY ON ON
LESSONS LEARNED FROM. A SPECIFIC
PROJECT THAT WE'RE DOING AYE TO
DEPLOY DC FAST CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE ALONG.
HIGHWAY CORRIDORS AND DOWN.
WE WERE LUCKY ENOUGH TO BE THE
RECIPIENT OF A THIRTEEN MILLION
DOLLAR GRANT THROUGH THIS HE
SEES A OUR EFFORT BTP PROGRAM.
WE'RE GONNA BE MATCHING THAT
THIRTEEN MILLION DOLLARS WITH
OVER SIX MILLION DOLLARS AND
PRIVATE CAPITAL INVESTMENT TO.
DEPLOY A.
FAST CHARGERS ALONG THE NORTH TO
SOUTH INTERSTATE FIVE ACCORD OR
HERE IN CALIFORNIA ABOUT SEVENTY
SITES ARMED WITH A CHARGING
STATION DEPLOYED ON NO MORE THAN
EVERY FIFTEEN MILES. THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT FOCUS TO DEPLOY
THESE DC FAST CHARGERS ARM ALONG
THE INTERSTATE IN RURAL AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
AND WE ARE HAPPY TO REPORT THAT
WE BROKE GROUND LAST YEAR AND
HAVE A FULLY OPERATIONAL
ADDITIONAL STATION I IN REDDING
CALIFORNIA.
TOM WHAT WE'VE LEARNED THROUGH
AYE THIS PROJECT IN IN OUR
EXPERIENCE.
SOME SOME MAJOR FACTORS IS THAT
NUMBER ONE THERE IS A HIGH
AMOUNT OF VARIABLE COST
THAT WERE UNANTICIPATED THAT GO
INTO. THE INSTALLATION OF THE
CHARGING STATIONS THEMSELVES
ARMS HEAVY AMOUNT OF
ENGINEERING.
THAT.
YOU DON'T KNOW UNTIL YOU'RE
ACTUALLY ON SITE SO YOU CAN YOU
CAN PLAN FOR THE PROJECTS YOU
CAN PICK IDEAL LOCATIONS BUT
REALLY UNTIL YOU START TO
UNDERSTAND THE GREAT CONDITIONS
BECAUSE THIS IS YOU KNOW. OUR
HOPE ELECTRIC FEELING I'M
WITHOUT THAT WORK.
THERE'S A LOT OF AGAIN ON
VARIABLE COSTS SO.
THAT MAJOR LESSON LEARNED FROM
US IS TO ENGAGE.
THE LOCAL ELECTRIC UTILITY
EARLY AND OFTEN I MEAN IF FROM
FROM THE VERY CONCEPTION PHASE
OF THIS TYPE OF DEPLOYMENT YOU
NEED TO BE IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
WHOEVER'S MENTION THE
DISTRIBUTION GRID. ON IT CANNOT
BE AN AFTERTHOUGHT AND.
I'M I'M HAPPY TO REPORT THAT.
WE ARE CLOSELY ALIGNED AND
WORKING WITH ALL THREE OF THE
MAJOR I'M VETERAN UTILITIES.
ON THIS AND.
REALLY WANTED TO TO HIGHLIGHT A
PARTNERSHIP THAT WE HAVE WITH
WITH TEACHING OBVIOUSLY FOR
STARTING FROM NORTH TO SOUTH
WE'VE ENGAGE THEM FIRST BUT THEY
HAVE A DEDICATED INTERNAL TEAM
THAT HAS BEEN WORKING WITH US
WE'RE COORDINATING ON ALMOST A
WEEKLY BASIS.
IN AND WHY THIS IS IMPORTANT
IT'S ON TO GIVE AND ANECDOTES.
IF WORD APPOINTMENTS AT A FAST
FOOD RESTAURANT ALONG A HIGHWAY
CORRIDOR THAT HAS A MONTHLY
AVERAGE PEAK DEMAND OF.
FIFTY KILOWATTS AND THEN I'M
GONNA DROP TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
KILOWATTS OF FAST CHARGERS IN
THEIR PARKING LOT. I COULD BE
QUADRUPLING THEIR ELECTRIC LOAD
OVERNIGHT.
SO THIS IS SOMETHING WHERE IT'S
AGAIN ESPECIALLY WITH THE FOCUS
ON THE POINT THESE THINGS ALONG
RURAL HIGHWAY.
SECTIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
ON WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WERE COORDINATING WITH THE
UTILITY SO THEY UNDERSTAND AND
AND WE CAN MINIMIZE
THE DISTRIBUTION GREAT IMPACT
AND THEREFORE MINIMIZE COSTS AND
AND. IN HOPES OF PROVIDING
BENEFITS TO THE GREAT.
I SO.
FOR US ARM THAT'S BEEN THAT'S
BEEN A KEY LEARNING AND THEN.
ALSO.
REALLY RELYING ON IN DAYTON
WITH A LOT OF THE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
BECAUSE BOB A LOT OF THESE
ORGANIZATIONS CAN BE GREAT
SALESPEOPLE PRESS IN TERMS OF
HELPING TO ATTRACT POTENTIAL
SITES SO GOING INTO THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
THERE ARE A LOT OF AIR QUALITY
ADVOCATES OTHER CLEAN ENERGY
ADVOCATE GROUPS NEED THESE OTHER
ONES THAT BECOME GREAT PARTNERS
IN HELPING TO PROVIDE OUTREACH
ON THAT YOU KNOW. THERE'S
FUNDING THESE PROGRAMS ARE
AVAILABLE YET CHARGE POINT IS
GONNA BE THE POINT STATIONS WHAT
ARE THE IDEAL LOCATIONS AND SO
IT'S BEEN A GREAT LESSON LEARNED
TO MAKE SURE THAT.
AGAIN IN THE PLANNING PHASE
FROM THE GET GO THAT YOU'RE
ENGAGING GROUPS LIKE THAT.
FOR US ARM I WOULD SAY THAT THE
ABILITY TO BE ENGAGED AND WITH
THIS YOU SEE IN THIS PROGRAM.
BUT THEN ALSO HAVING THE
ABILITY TO BE ENGAGED.
THROUGH.
THE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THAT
UTILITIES HAVE AND THEN ALSO
JUST AS A PIVATE SECTOR
BUSINESS TO POINT STATIONS
BICU THEY WERE PRIVATE CAPITAL.
PREVIOUS PANEL TALKED A LOT
ABOUT COORDINATION WE GET TO BE
A ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE COURTING
IN CITIES AS THE PRIVATE SECTOR
BECAUSE WERE INVOLVED ACROSS THE
BOARD. IN IN ALL THESE
DIFFERENT.
INITIATIVES SO IT'S IT'S REALLY
INVALUABLE TO BE ABLE TO
LEVERAGE ON THE INVESTMENT FROM
THE C. SEE.
TO AYE INCLUDE PRIVATE CAPITAL
NOT AND BUILD UPON.
.
A SCALABLE BUSINESS MODEL FOR US
THAT WERE ALREADY SEEN RESULTS
WITH OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AGAIN
THOSE COMMUNITIES ORGANIZATIONS
OTHER MUNICIPAL UTILITIES. THAT
HAVE ALREADY TALKED TO US
BECAUSE THEY HEARD THAT WE'RE
DOING THIS IN THE C. C. AND
WANTING TO SEE A WAY WE CAN
PARTNER AND EXPAND UPON THIS
INITIAL SEVENTY SITES AND THAT
THAT'S REALLY AS A RESULT OF.
THIS INITIAL SEED FUNDING FOR
THAT FOR THE PROGRAM SO ARMED.
AND THE OF THE OTHER AREA THAT I
THINK.
REALLY THIS THAT THE CC PROGRAM
HAS HELPED I'M GOING BACK TO IS
THE ABILITY FOR US TO MAKE IT
ECONOMICALLY POSSIBLE TO PUT
STATIONS AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. AND THIS IS A HUGE
INITIATIVE CROSS I KNOW IT'S A
HUGE INITIATIVE FOR THE STATE
AND I'M I'LL JUST TAKE THE
OPTION YOU TANK. THANK THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE AT
THIS COMMITTEE FOR SUPPORTING S.
B. NINETY TWO LAST YEAR WHICH IS
GOING TO DIRECT THE VW
SETTLEMENT FUNDING.
A SIGNIFICANT PORTION THAT INTO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT
WE APPRECIATE.
YOUR WORK ON THAT AND.
YEAH I I'LL JUST SAYING CLOSING
THAT ON CHARGE POINT STRONGLY
SUPPORTS ON THE CONTINUATION AND
EXPANSION OF THE CC ZEV
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM AND WE
THINK. THAT.
INITIATIVES LIKE THIS ALONG
WITH.
LEGISLATION LIKE MR KING'S AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVEN WHICH IS
GOING TO US THAT REQUIREMENTS
FOR TWENTY FORTY AROUND ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES ARE GONNA BE
VITAL TO ON REACHING THE
GOVERNOR'S GOALS. OF CHINA FIFTY
THOUSAND CHARGING STATIONS AND
AND FIVE MILLIONS AT SO WITH
THAT THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
TO COME IN AND PERCENT AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE MIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR CAN HOLD QUESTIONS
UNTIL THE END OF THE PANEL THAT
BE GREAT.
MR OVER YEAH THANK YOU FOR
CUTTING ME HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY
ON WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED ABOUT
THE NEED.
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING FROM
OUR WORK WITH THE ANTELOPE
VALLEY TRANSIT AUTHORITY
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS AB T. A. AND
THEIR EFFORT TO BECOME THE
NATION'S FIRST. ALL ELECTRIC
TRANSIT BUS FLEET MY NAME IS
FRED SILVER AND I AM VICE
PRESIDENT OF CAL START.
CALIFORNIA BASED NONPROFIT
FOCUSED ON COMMERCIALIZING PAIN
TRANSPORTATION TECHNOLOGIES AYE
LEADER ABBAS PROGRAM.
I WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT.
AB T. A SERVICE FOR DID FIFTY
THOUSAND RESIDENTS IN THE CITIES
OF LANCASTER AND PALMDALE.
AND AIMS TO HAVE A HUNDRED
PERCENT ZERO EMISSION BUS FLEET
BY TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN OR TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. WITH EIGHTY
FIVE ELECTRIC TRANSIT AND MOTOR
COACH EHICLES THEY CURRENTLY
HAVE FORTY NINE ON ORDER. AND.
MANY OF THEM WILL BE DEPLOYED
IN THE VERY SHORT TERM.
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM.
FUNDING HAS BEEN A SIGNIFICANT
ENABLER FOR THEM TO PURCHASE THE
EIGHT THEIR BUSES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT'S PROVIDED ALMOST FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS OF THE NINETY
MILLION. THAT THEY NEED TO GET
TO A HUNDRED PERCENT ZERO
EMISSIONS.
I WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT TO YOU
SOME OF THE KEY INFRASTRUCTURE
LESSONS WE HAVE LEARNED WHILE
WORKING WITH AB T. A.
WHILE AB K. IS DEPLOYING UP TO
EIGHTY FIVE ELECTRIC TRANSIT
BUSES.
JUST FIFTY ELECTRIC TRAMS BUSES
CAN REQUIRE THREE MEGAWATTS
WHICH IS.
FIFTY PERCENT MORE POWER THAN A
SKYSCRAPER.
LIKE THE TRANSAMERICA BUILDING
AND SAN FRANCISCO.
WE HAVE FOUND THAT ALSO FOUND
THAT ELECTRICITY DEMAND CHARGES
A SEPARATE COMPONENT OF THE
ELECTRICAL ENERGY BILL. CAN
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE ENERGY
EXPONENTIALLY AND CHALLENGE THE
BUSINESS CASE.
IN ORDER TO MITIGATE THESE COSTS
AND AND GROW THEIR ZERO EMISSION
FLEET AB T. A HAS NEEDED THE USE
INNOVATIVE LOAD MANAGEMENT
STRATEGIES.
AND.
A FOOTBALL FIELD OF SOLAR
ENERGY TO MINIMIZE THEIR ENERGY
COSTS.
ANY AB T. A SPENDING ABOUT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS WHICH IS A
REALLY SMALL AMOUNT AS COMPARED
TO OTHER PROPERTIES.
EH.
IT COULD BECAUSE THEY ARE THE
PROPERTIES OF MUCH MORE
CONSTRAINED.
SPACE AB T. A HAS HAD IT EASIER
GIVEN THEIR SIZE AND LAND
AVAILABILITY THAT THEY HAVE. HAD
IT MADE IT EASIER FOR THEM TO
ACTUALLY KEEP THOSE COSTS DOWN
WE EXPECT THAT ARE THE URBAN
TRANSIT BUS OPERATORS WITH
LARGER FLEAS.
I WITH LESS AVAILABLE LAND SPACE
WILL BE SEVERELY OF FURTHER
CHALLENGED BY THE COFFIN COST OF
INFRASTRUCTURE AND MILLION NEW
AND ADVANCED INFRASTRUCTURE
DESIGNS. COSTING TWO TO THREE
TIMES THAT AMOUNT.
MANY OF THESE LARGER BOSS
PROPERTIES USE STADIUM STYLE.
BUS PARKING BACK TO BACK
VEHICLES WITH NO ROOM FOR
CONVENTIONAL CHART ONE CHARGER
FOR ONE BUS.
KIND OF SYSTEM
AND THESE INFRASTRUCTURE DESIGNS
MAY I HAVE TO COME.
DOWN FROM OVERHEAD CANOPIES.
AND EVEN AT HIGHER RATES.
HIGH CHARGING RATES TO SUPPORT
THE LIMITED AVAILABLE SPACE.
AB TEA A AS USING SOLAR AND A
VERY LARGE AUXILIARY IN
ADDITION.
AB T. AS USING OF VERY LARGE
ABSOLUTE POWER GENERATOR
COMBINED WITH THEIR SOLAR FOR
PROVIDING RESILIENCY IN THE
EVENT. OF POWER OUTAGES
THERE IS A REAL NEED FOR CLEANUP
MICHAEL GRADES.
USING SOLAR AND BACK UP PARRIS.
STE BATTERY STORAGE TO.
TO BE DESIGNED TO PROVIDE POWER
DURING DURING THESE AVERAGES AND
ALSO PROVIDE LOWER COST
RENEWABLE ENERGY.
GOING FORWARD BATTERY ELECTRIC
BUS FLEET THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
ARE NOW STARTING TO SCALE UP TO
THEIR ZERO MISSION BUCKS FLEETS
WE ANTICIPATE A LARGE SHARE.
OF THE ELEVEN THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT BUSES TO BE
ZERO EMISSIONS BY TWENTY THIRTY.
TRANSIT BUSES ARE JUST
BEGINNING.
I HAVE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS ARE
CATCHING UP REAL FAST JUST TWO
YEARS BEHIND THEM AS WELL.
INFRASTRUCTURE NOW IS THE MAJOR
BARRIER.
I'VE ABOUT SLEEP TO GET TO LARGE
SCALE OPERATIONS
AND NEW INNOVATIVE EVERY
STRUCTURE TECHNOLOGIES WILL BE
REQUIRED AND INFRASTRUCTURE.
FUNDING IS REQUIRED TO SUPPORT
THEM WE'LL NEED NEW. INNOVATIVE
DESIGN CONFIGURATIONS ADVANCE
PLANNING AND CHARGING
STRATEGIES.
I BELIEVE THAT THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION UNDER THE
ALTERNATIVE FUEL AND VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGY PROGRAM. SHOULD GO
BEYOND THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDING FOR JUST LIGHT DUTY
VEHICLES AND FUND THE
DEVELOPMENT OF NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE DESIGNS
NECESSARY.
PRE ZERO EMISSION BUSES TO GET
TO LARGE SCALE DEPLOYMENTS.
THIS ENERGY COMMISSION'S SUPPORT
COULD INCLUDE NEW MICRO GRADES
FOR BUS OPERATIONS USING SOLAR
ENERGY STORAGE DESIGNS.
INFRASTRUCTURE PLANNING GRANTS
SO IF WE CAN MAKE SMARTER
INVESTMENTS IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THEY NEED TO GET
TWO HUNDRED PERCENT ZERO
EMISSION. AND NEW INNOVATIVE
CHARGER CONFIGURATIONS CHARGING
AND ENERGY MANAGEMENT
STRATEGIES.
ALSO THE CONTINUED I EVER STRUCK
SUPPLEMENT NOW BEING CONSIDERED
BY.
CARB UNDER THE A TREAT PROGRAM
IS HIGHLY VALUED ACCORDING TO
THE MEMBERS OF CALIFORNIA'S
EMISSION BUS COALITION.
AB CARES A MEMBER OF THAT
COALITION OF THAT COALITION OF
MANAGE STIRRED MANAGED BY
CASTRO.
AND IS MADE UP OF THE PIONEERING
TRANSIT FLEETS IN CALIFORNIA IN
ADDITION THIS GROUP IS STRONGLY.
RECOMMENDING THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING BEING
PROVIDED OF THE VOLKSWAGEN
SUPPLEMENT AS WELL THERE IS NO
INFRASTRUCTURE SUPPLEMENT.
FOR BUSES IN THE VOLKSWAGEN
FUNDING.
IN SUMMARY AND A LARGE PART DUE
TO THE.
SUPPORT FROM THE CAP AND TRADE
PROBLEM IT'S BEEN GREAT FOR AB
CARE IT'S BEEN A LONG A
NEIGHBOR.
FOR THEM TO BE ARE BECOME THE
NATION'S FIRST ZERO.
ZERO EMISSION BUSTLING.
I AB KEY A.
IS A PIONEER IN DESERVES A LOT
OF CREDIT FOR ITS LEADERSHIP.
TO HELP OTHER TRANS PROPERTIES
FOLLOW AB CASE PATH ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR BOTH ZERO MISSION
BUS PURCHASES. AND DEPLOYING
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE WILL BE
NEEDED THANK YOU FOR YOUR KIND
ATTENTION TO MY TESTIMONY TODAY.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING.
UNTIL VOICE WITH THE SACRAMENTO
MUNICIPAL UTILITY DISTRICT HAD
BEEN THE MANAGER OF THE ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION.
AT* SINCE TWO THOUSAND ONE.
I WANNA THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE COMMENTS
TODAY.
CURRENTLY AT* WE'VE
DEPLOYED OUR OWN PUBLIC NETWORK
OF DC FASH ORDERS IN THE
SACRAMENTO AREA. AND WE ALSO
HAVE VARIOUS INCENTIVE PROGRAMS
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE FOR CUSTOMERS
WITH REGARDS TO LEVEL TWO
CHARGING.
IN RESIDENTIAL MULTI FAMILY
COMMERCIAL GROUPS.
PERSON LIKE TO THINK OF A
LEGISLATURE FOR ALL THE FUNDING
THROUGH THE YEARS.
AND. AS MENTIONED THEY ARE OF
FBP T. PROGRAM.
THE SHORTER NAME WE LIKE TO
CALL IT IS ALSO THE A. B. EIGHT
PROGRAM SO.
RECOGNIZE THAT THAT PROGRAM
REALLY GOT ITS INITIATION. OF
FROM THIS BODY.
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ON THE NINE HUNDRED
MILLION THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE FOR THE ZERO MISSION.
VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE.
ALSO LOOKING AT KIND OF GAPS IN
THAT GOING FORWARD.
TO MEET THAT GOAL THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA LITERATURE
INTERPRETATION COALITION.
THAN WE'VE WHICH WERE A MEMBER
WERE ALSO LOOKING AT THERE COULD
BE AN ADDITIONAL TWO POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLAR GAP.
TO MEET THE FULL REQUIREMENTS.
OF.
TRYING TO MEET THAT FIVE MILLION
GOAL OUT TO TWENTY THIRTY.
LESSONS LEARNED SUCCESS STORIES
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE UMBERLEIGH
THE BEEN TWO MAJOR ONES THAT WE
REALLY ENCOUNTERED FIRST IS
AVAILABILITY OF FUNDING.
AND SECOND IS PROBABLY INTEREST
TO PROPERTY OWNERS ACTUALLY HOST
INSIGHT.
AT STATION.
WE STARTED THE POINT OR DC
THATCHER GREEN.
GOING BACK ABOUT FOUR YEARS AGO
THE FOR PRIMARY PURPOSE FOR US
AT THE TIME. WAS.
IN RESPONSE TO AN RGB GO
SETTLEMENT.
WHICH WAS IN THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITY SERVICE AREAS DID NOT
ADDRESS THE PUBLIC ON UTILITY SO
WE STARTED UP OUR OWN PROGRAM TO
KIND OF FILL OUR OWN GAP.
IN THAT PROGRAM AND WE'VE
REALLY.
WITH THROUGH OUR OWN FUNDING.
WERE ABLE TO TO GET OUR.
STATION STARTED BUT THE
SECONDARY THING THAT WE FOUND
WAS WHO WAS VERY HARD TO
CONVINCE PROPERTY OWNERS
ACTUALLY WHAT US.
BUILD A STATION ON THEIR
PROPERTY. ON MANY OCCASIONS MODE
WAS GOING TO PICK UP THE WHOLE
TAP PER STATION CONSTRUCTION.%
BUT THE STATION.
PROPERTY OWNERS WOULD BACK OUT
AT SOMETIME DURING THE PROCESS.
THAT WATER CONCERNS ABOUT THE
STATION'S BEING PROFITABLE
ENOUGH FOR THE SITE HOST TO
CONSIDER.
CONCERNS ABOUT LIABILITY RISK
CONCERNS ABOUT AMERICAN
DISABILITY ACT EXPOSURE.
ALSO PARKING CONSIDERATIONS AND
LIMITATIONS.
BY FAR AWAY THOUGH I THINK A
MAJORITY OF AT THE PROFITABILITY
TO THE OPERATOR.
ON SITE HOST WAS THE BIGGEST
QUESTION.
THESE.
STATIONS WE DON'T THINK ARE
VERY BIG PROFIT.
CENTERS CHARGING STATIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL HAVE
USUALLY BEEN INSTALLED THAT A
BUSINESS IN ORDER TO ATTRACT
CUSTOMERS TO THAT BUSINESS.
AND THEN THE BUSINESS MODEL IS
TO MAKE UP FOR RETAIL SALES
WHEN.
PEOPLE COME INTO THAT STORE THE
AT THE PARK THEIR CAR FOR THIRTY
MINUTES AND GO IN AND BUY
GROCERIES SERVES A CERTAIN.
FINANCIAL TRANSACTION THAT THEY
COME BACK OVER.
ALSO IT'S VERY OBVIOUS SOME
AUTOMAKERS TESLA BEING THE
POSTER CHILD HAS SUPPORTED
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE.
UP UNTIL RECENTLY IT'S ALWAYS
BEEN FREE FROM A FOR.
.
SECURELY THE.
OLDER VEHICLES.
ALL THAT WAS IT ESSENTIALLY TO
SELL VEHICLES NOT NECESSARILY TO
PROVIDE THE ENERGY.
SO THE PROFITABLE BUSINESS
MODELS MAKE IT REALLY KIND OF.
ON DISINCENTIVE FOR A LOT OF
FOLKS TO CITE.
THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND WE GO
THROUGH A LOT OF CITING A
SUPPORT WORK.
A SOME OF THE OTHER THINGS THAT
WE'VE DONE.
WE WORK WITH A LOT OF THE
SERVICE PROVIDERS.
ONE THING ABOUT ELECTRIC CUT
TRANSPORTATION THAT'S KINDA
UNIQUE IF YOU ARE NOT TIED TO A
CERTAIN FACILITY.
WHAT WE ESSENTIALLY DO IS HELP
THEM E. VALUE WAIT MULTIPLE
SITES
AROUND A GIVEN LOCATION?
TO TRY TO FIND THE MOST
ECONOMICAL SITE WITH REGARDS TO
WORD ATTACHED TO THE GRID. ON
THIS IS ONE OF THE ONES WHO IT
WHIRL.
YOU KNOW HELP IDENTIFY.
I DON'T KNOW THE METRIC WOULD
PROBABLY BE FOUR TO FIVE
DIFFERENT LOCATIONS FOR EVERYONE
THAT GETS CITED. TRYING TO FIND
THE BEST A PLACE ON THE GRID
ANOTHER THING THAT WE WILL ALSO
DO IS.
HELP WITH THE COORDINATION AT
SMUD WE WORK WITH.
SEVERAL SERVICE PROVIDERS ALL
TRYING TO COME IN AND PROVIDE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE OURSELVES IN OUR OWN
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM.
IN LISTTHEM TO FIND OUT WHERE
THEY ARE NOT INSTALLING
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND SO WERE.
MUCH MORE INTERESTED IN COVER
RENA THOSE AREAS WHICH ARE.
AND BASICALLY.
GONNA HAVE GAPS IN IN THE
COVERAGE.
SOME OF THE OTHER THINGS THAT
WERE SEEN ON MODERN DAY TIMES WE
REALLY ARE SEEN MUCH MORE COST
REDUCTION IN NEW CONSTRUCTION
OPPORTUNITIES.
AS MUCH OF THIS INFRASTRCTURE
IS WE CAN GET INTO A BUILDING OR
A PARKING LOT BEFORE IT IS BILL
SO WE DON'T HAVE TO COME IN AND.
INSTALL IT AFTER THE FACT ON THE
BALLPARK EVEN METRIC WE HAVE IS
IT COULD BE UPWARDS OF A TEN X.
COST REDUCTION. IF WERE ABLE TO
GET THE BASIC INFRASTRUCTURE IN
DURING THE.
IN NEW CONSTRUCTION OPPORTUNITY.
THAT'S REALLY ALSO PROBABLY
MOST IMPORTANT WE FEEL IN THE
MULTI FAMILY ARENA I THINK.
MULTI FAMILY LEVEL TWO IS WHAT
WE'RE ALL KINDA STARTING TO
CONSIDER IS PROBABLY THE
TOUGHEST NUT TO CRACK IN.
EVEY CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
SO NEW APARTMENTS GOING UP THIS
MUCH CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE IS
WE CAN GET SPECT INTO THOSE.
BUILDINGS IS VERY IMPORTANT WE
ALSO SEE THAT THAT OVERLAPS VERY
OFTEN WITH LOW INCOME
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES SO I'M
REALLY KIND WORKS ON THAT
PROBLEM.
IN SO WE THINK THAT'S A A BIG
OPPORTUNITY WERE ACTUALLY
LOOKING AT SOME OF OUR FUNDING
PROGRAMS TO PRIORITIZE IT
TOWARDS NEW CONSTRUCTION.
ANOTHER ONE THAT WE'VE SEEN HAN
THE CHARGING SERVICE PROVIDER.
THAT'S WORKED ON I MENTION THAT
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO CONVINCE
A PROPERTY OWNER TO US CITED
STATION WHAT THEY'VE DONE
SUCCESSFULLY IS THEY WILL GO IN.
GAUGE A LARGE.
PROPERTY OWNERSHIP COMPANY THAT
HAS MULTIPLE PROPERTIES ALL OVER
THE STATE ARE ALL OVER THE
NATION. THEY'LL NEGOTIATE A
MASTER AGREEMENT SO THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO MULTIPLE TYPES OF
PROPERTY SITUATIONS THAT KEEPS
THEM FROM HAVING TO GO ON
NEGOTIATE INDIVIDUAL ONE OFF
TYPES CONTRACTS SO YOU GET. AN
ECONOMY OF SCALE ON THAT ALSO
RECOGNIZES THOSE TYPES OF
BUSINESSES ARE VALUING THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
MOST OF THEM ARE TIED TO A
RETAIL BUSINESSES SO THAT VERY
MUCH.
HELPS BRING IN.
CUSTOMERS TO THEIR.
FACILITIES.
AND.
I GOTTA GET MY LAST PAGE UN.
LASTLY.
MORE ON THE TECHNICAL AND.
.
RIGHT NOW IN DC FAST CHARGING
I'LL JUST MENTION THAT THERE'RE
TWO TO THREE DIFFERENT.
PHYSICAL CONNECTOR STANDARDS
THAT REALLY INCREASES COST IN
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE A
TWO DIFFERENT STANDARDS A
SIGHTED AT EACH LOCATION.
WERE HOPING IN WHERE UP
PARTICIPATING IN FORM SET CAN.
AND TRY TO COMBINE THAT.
BASICALLY GET EVERYBODY DOWN TO
A CON THEN.
STANDARD CONNECTOR
CONFIGURATION SO WE DON'T HAVE
TO HAVE I'LL JUST SAY ONE
DEDICATED FOR ONE TYPE OF
VEHICLE ONE FOR ANOTHER. AND
HAVE TO BASICALLY HAVE CONFUSION
OR I HAVE MULTIPLE UNITS THERE
WHICH IS.
ADDITIONAL COSTS AT EACH SITE
TO BE ABLE TO HANDLE THE ENTIRE
FLEET OF VEHICLES OUT THERE.
THOSE ARE MY COMMENTS WITH
REGARDS TO CUT ITS SUCCESSES AND
THEN.
SOME OF THE THINGS WE THINK
COULD BE BETTER.
THANK YOU JUST A FOLLOW UP ON NO
ON YOUR LAST POINT TO A WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TWO DIFFERENT TO A
VEHICLE MANUFACTURERS OR.
ENTERED THAT CONNECT EIGHT
SICKLY THE THE.
SECONDLY THE JAPANESE USE A
STANDARD CALLED THE CHATHAM
CONNECTOR.
EUROPEAN AND U. S. CONNECTORS.
ARE CALLED THE.
.
BASICALLY THE COMBINED.
J. SEVENTEEN SEVENTY TWO
CONNECTOR.
GETS VERY TECHNICAL BUT THERE'S
TO PHYSICAL AND YOU HAVE TO HAVE
TWO CONNECTORS.
AT EACH
DC FAST CHARGING SITE TO BE ABLE
TO HANDLE EVERYBODY THERE IS
COSTS INCREASE BECAUSE YOU HAVE
TO HAVE BOTH.
CITED.
THANK YOU. ANY QUESTIONS
UPON.
QUESTION I APPRECIATE CHARGE BUT
LET ME TO ART THAT THAT YOUR
FACILITY.
FIFTY MONTHS BACK AT IN TERMS
OF.
.
CRITERIA THAT YOU'RE UTILIZING
WHEN YOU IDENTIFY SITES WHAT ARE
THE IDEAL CRITERIA HERS WAS IDEA
SITES FREE FOR YOU IT ARE THEY
GAS STATIONS THAT EXIST ALREADY
ARE THEY. A RETAIL.
SHOPPING CENTERS
WELL WHAT'S WHAT'S
WOULD YOU CONSIDER AN IDEAL SITE
GET THAT THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION.
SO FOR US FROM.
IN ADDITION TO WHAT I ALREADY
TOUCHED ON WITCHES AND AND.
OUT BILL TOUCHED ON THIS A WELL
AND IN ADDITION TO THE THE GREAT
IMPACTS IN UNDERSTANDING WHAT
THE SITE'S GOING TO BE IN TERMS
AN IDEAL LOCATION TO SET A FAST
CHARGER WE UTILIZE WHAT'S CALLED
THE MODEL WHICH IS. WHERE WOULD
YOU WANT YOUR MOM TO PULL UP IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT WHILE
IT'S RAINING AND ACTIVE BE FOR
HALF AN HOUR TO CHARGE A CAR?
SO FOR US IT'S A ACCESSIBILITY
WELL LIT.
YOU KNOW EASILY IDENTIFIABLE
SIGNAGE ALL OF THESE THINGS
GOING TO INTO THAT LIKE I SAID
SO FOR ALL OF OUR SITE IT HAS TO
MEET THE THAT THE MOM RULE TAX.
PROCEEDED SO WHAT THAT
TRANSLATES INTO BEING IS A LOT
OF THE SIGHTS ALONG THIS HIGHWAY
CORRIDORS ARE. A RETAIL SHOPPING
CENTERS.
A STARBUCKS OF BURGER KING
ALBERT AT THOSE KIND OF THINGS
THAT ALREADY HAVE A LOT OF THAT
ESTABLISHED ON A GAS STATION.
CAN WORK BUT IT HAS TO BE ABLE
TO MEET YOU KNOW ALL THOSE
CONDITIONS AND ALSO MEET THE ON
DISTRIBUTION GRID CONDITIONS AS
WELL AND I AND MY LAST QUESTION
TERMS OF THE THE.
THE INCREASE ELECTRIC
ELECTRICITY USAGE AND LET THEIR
WHAT.
WHAT IS DONE IN THAT
CIRCUMSTANCE WHEN WHEN YOU SEE
OF A QUADRUPLING OF OF?
?
BURGER KINGS OR MCDONALD'S AT
JERSEY USE WHAT WHAT HAPPENS
THERE IS OUR COORDINATION WITH
UTILITIES IN TERMS OF THAT. THAT
ABSOLUTE SO THAT YOU KNOW
THERE'S A VARIETY DIFFERENCE
NUYS THAT'S GONNA HAPPEN IF
IT'S.
WE ARE.
NOT AT A PHASE YET WHERE THIS
HAS TO BE THE SITE MEANING THAT
THERE ARE FOUR OR FIVE DIFFERENT
OPTIONS WITHIN THE SAME REASON
WE CAN DO. IF IT'S COST
PROHIBITIVE OR THERE'S GOING TO
BE.
ESSENTIAL IMPACTS NEGATIVE
IMPACTS OF THE GRADE WE ARE WE
WOULD HAVE TO EVALUATE AN
ALTERNATIVE SITE IF THIS IS THE
SITE AND HAS TO BE THAN WE WOULD
HAVE TO WORK WITH THE UTILITY.
IN ORDER TO UPGRADE THE POWER
IN THERE IS BECAUSE THERE'S COST
THAT'S INSTALLATION BECAUSE AS A
VARIABLE COST THAT.
WE WOULD BEAR IN TOWARDS TO A
IN ORDER TO UPGRADE.
THE ELECTIONS CAPACITY INSIDE.
MR SO OVER A ON THIS IS PROBABLY
A A. A REALLY BIG TOPIC TO TO
COVER BUT IF YOU COULD JUST DE
PERHAPS GIVE ME A SUMMARY ARMED
RESPONSE. A I LEARNED YESTERDAY
THAT CHINA IS OPERATING A FLEET
OF SOME FIFTEEN THOUSAND.
ELECTRIC BUSES WE NEED TO LEARN
FROM THEM OR I
IS IT JUST COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
NOT APPLICABLE OUT WHAT THE
FIRST POST TWENTY THOUSAND ONE
CITY SO I ICE IT'S EVEN GOTTEN
THE AND JUST TO GIVE YOU A SCALE
IS ABOUT A MILLION.
AT SOMETHING LIKE A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THOUSAND TRANSIT BUSES
BORDER YEAR. IN CHINA VERSUS.
ARE BY THOUSAND TRANSIT BUSES
BUT IN THE UNITED STATES
EVERYTHING THERE IS IS DONE ON
STEROIDS I THINK THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN ON MY
SHORTS COORDINATED. AND A
SCANNING TOUR WOULD BE REALLY
VALUED I THINK.
AND GOING THROUGH CHINA.
BUT I THOUGHT SO I THINK THAT
THERE'S A LOT MORE GOING ON IN
EUROPE AS WELL. A EUROPE IS AS
BUYING ELECTRIC BUSES IT AT MORE
THAN TRIPLE THE RATE.
THAT THE U. S.'S OKAY NOT QUITE
AS MUCH AS ASIA PROBABLY A
LITTLE CLOSER. IN THE KIND OF.
PERFORMANCE QUALITY
REQUIREMENTS THAT THE.
U. S. AS AND I THINK A LOT TO
BE LEARNED FROM SCANNING TO
WORK.
OF EUROPE AS WELL EFFECT I JUST
NOTICED RECENTLY ON A ON A.
R. P. THAT.
LA MEJOR HAS OUT ON THE STREET
RIGHT NOW FOR. THE LOOKING FOR
CONSULTANT TO PLAN THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE ALLEY METRO YOU
KNOW IS THE LARGEST TRANSIT
PROPERTY IN THE STATE.
TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED BUSES ARE
THEY HAVE STE THREE.
IT'S GETTING TOWARDS. OVERSEAS.
AND.
AT BAY THEY WANT BUDGET INTO
THAT SO IT HELPED US WOULD BE
OUR TEA. IN THE EARLY MARKET TO
FIGURE OUT WHERE THEY ARE T. CAN
COME FROM OVERSEAS HERE AND I
THINK LEARNING FROM THEM AS
WELL.
SO I WISH I COULD TELL YOU WHAT
THOSE LEARNINGS ARE THE BIGGEST
CONCERN I HAVE RIGHT NOW IS THE
GREAT ISSUES. LOVE TO SEE HAVE A
DEAL WITH GREAT RESILIENCY
BECAUSE.
YOU'RE DEALING WITH PUBLIC.
SAFETY ISSUE HERE THESE
VEHICLES GOING TO CONTINUE
OPERATING. THE GRADES DOWN OKAY
SO I TALK ABOUT THESE MICRO
BRIDGE SOLUTIONS WE TRY TO
UNDERSTAND HOW OUR FOLKS DEAL
WITH THAT I THINK THERE ARE
LEARNING TO BE HAVE I I'M NOT
SURE I CAN TELL YOU EXACTLY WHAT
THEY ARE.
OKAY THANK YOU AND THAT A A IS A
AB T. EXPERIENCING. OF THE KIND
OF RIDERSHIP DECLINED THAT.
ELEMENTARY IT'S BEEN.
REPORTING IN GENERAL I I DON'T
THINK THEY I DON'T KNOW IF
THEY'RE IN THE RIDERSHIP NUMBERS
ARBUS GROWTH AREA A LOT OF
PEOPLE COMMUTING INTO LA.
FOR JOBS THAT GOT TRANSPORTED
WANT TO SANTA CLARA MIGHT BE THE
OPPOSITE TRIED TO THE OPPOSITE
UNIT WOULD BE INTERESTING TO
KNOW AND THEN I JUST KIND OF
UNDERSTAND.
THE IMPLICATIONS THAT HAS FOR
THE TYPE OF SYSTEM WHERE
BUILDING OUT FOR STARTING WITH
NEW INFRASTRUCTURE.
.
I I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT WE LOOK
TO THE FUTURE. AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE TAILORING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO WHAT WE
ANTICIPATE FUTURE NEEDS TO BE A
LOT MADE AN INTERESTING MAHLER
NEIGHBORHOOD BUSES THAT CONNECT
LEARNING.
EXAMPLE OF THAT IS THE ONLY DOT
THE CITY OF LA.
IS LOOKING TO PUT ON.
AND ADDITIONAL HUNDRED FOURTY
FOUR ELECTRIC BUSES AND THEY'RE
GOING TO DOUBLE THE GONNA USED
UP TO ACTION.
DOUBLE THEIR OF.
YOU KNOW REDUCE THE TWELFTH
TIME AND THEY'RE EXPECTING A
HUNDRED PERCENT INCREASE IN
RIDERSHIP AND THAT WAS
QUESTIONED BY THE CALTRANS WE
WENT BACK AND DID ANALYSIS WITH.
AND THEY CONFIRMED ON ALMOST A
HUNDRED PERCENT RIDERSHIP GAINS
IN THE CITY OF LA BY ANY ON
THESE ELECTRIC BUSES THAT
ALLOWED TO.
DEAL WITH A SHORT WHILE TIMES
PATHS GOOD GOOD TO HEAR. MISTER
TECH. GIPSON QUESTIONS AND YEAH
JUST JUST FOR OUR.
MISTER HARRISON I JUST TRY TO
GET A SENSE OF HOW YOU ON.
I KNOW THAT THE COST DIFFERENCE%
WAS FAIRLY HIGH BETWEEN LEVEL
THREE LEVEL TO. AND.
WITH IF YOU FIGURE OUT HOW TO
PROPERLY DISTRIBUTE LEVEL THREE
VERSES OF A TWO. AND A
PARTICULAR. THROUGH THE
QUESTIONS RELEVANT IS FOR FOLKS
THAT MAY NOT HAVE ACCESS TO.
CHARGING IN THEIR HOME BECAUSE.
I THINK THAT CHANGES THEIR THEIR
CHARGING NEEDS WHEN THEY'RE OUT.
IN PUBLIC.
YEAH GREAT QUESTION AS WELL SO.
.
THAT.
ACROSS YOU KNOW LIKE THAT ALL
SECTORS IN IN IN ALL OF OUR
DEPLOYMENTS.
IN THE FIRST QUESTION IS GOING
TO BE AROUND DWELL TIME SO FOR
THE FOLKS WHO ARE GOING TO BE
HERE HOW LONG ARE THEY GOING TO
BE HERE FOR BECAUSE THE
DIFFERENCE IN THIS IN A GAS
STATION IS THIS IS A CHARGE
WHILE YOU PARK. ON SO IT IT DE
SHORTEST TIME POSSIBLE TODAY
WITH THE VEHICLES THAT ARE ON
THE ROAD YOU'RE STILL LOOKING AT
A TWENTY TO THIRTY MEN AND
THAT'S WHAT THE FAST CHARGE.
SO THE FIRST QUESTION IS HOW
LONG YOU HAVE SO IF IT'S A MULTI
FAMILY DWELLING AND THEY CAN
CHARGE OVERNIGHT THAT'S GOING TO
BE THE MOST ECONOMICAL AND THEY
CAN TO WELL THAT LONG SO THEN
LEVEL TWO WORKS PERFECTLY. ON IF
THERE ARE RESTRICTIONS AROUND
THAT AND WE NEED FOLKS TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE HIGH TURNOVER.
SUCH AS A RETAIL CENTER OR EVEN
IN A COMMON AREA OF A MULTI UNIT
DWELLING OR LONG HIGHWAY
CORRIDOR LEVEL THREE IS GOING TO
BE THE PRIMARY APPLICATION THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO WANT TO USE SUCH
REALLY. IF THE FIRST CRITERIA
HOW LONG CAN THAT THE CAR SIT
FOR WHAT MAKES SENSE IN THE
SECOND CRATER IS GONNA BE ON
ECONOMIC I'M ONE OF THINGS THAT
WE DON'T WANT TO DO IS.
FOR FOLKS THAT CANNOT CHARGE AT
HOME.
WE DON'T WANT TO EXCLUDE THEM
FROM CHARGING AFFORDABLE. AND
WHEN I I SAY THAT IS.
LEVEL THREE CHARGING THIS DC
VETERAN IS BECAUSE IT'S THE
HIGHEST ELECTRICAL BECAUSE IT'S
ALWAYS GOING TO BE THE MORE
EXPENSIVE WAY TO CHARGE SO IF
THEY CAN AFFORD.
TOO BUT AGAIN HAVE THE LONGER
DWELL TIME THEN WE CAN OFFER
THEM AFFORDABLE CHARGING
SOLUTIONS AND SO ON AS MUCH AS
WE CAN PROMOTE.
BOTH OPTIONS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S THE CONVENIENCE FACTOR
IN CASE THEY NEED TO GET A QUICK
CHARGE ON BUT HAVE THE
AFFORDABLE OPTION OF A LONGER
DWELL TIME LEVEL TO CHARGE.
BUT THE TYPICAL LEVEL THREE
CHARGE I MEAN I I'VE.
I'VE BEEN SINGED YOUR COMPANY
WITH LEVEL THREES BUT HOW HOW
MUCH WHAT THE TYPICAL CHARGE FOR
LEVEL THREE CHARTER.
THE COST FOR THE CHARGER OR THE
COST FOR THAT ON THE CONSUMER.
IT IS A MINUTE TRIP DE OF THE
FUELING.
AND IT'S
IT IT IT VARIES BECAUSE THERE'S
NOT A COMMENTS YOU KNOW THERE'S
NOT GONNA PRICE BUT IN MOST
APPLICATIONS THE CYCLES OF SELF
SERVE TO TO CLARIFY CHARGE WHEN
DOESN'T SET THOSE PRICES WHOEVER
OWNS THE STATION THE SITE IS
GONNA SET THOSE PRICES. BUT
GENERALLY SPEAKING.
BASED ON A LOCAL ACTORS BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO SET THE PRICING AT
LOWER THAN THE COST OF A
GASOLINE EQUIVALENT PRICE AND
SO.
FOR A YOU KNOW THIRTY MINUTE
CHARGE TO GET EIGHTY PERCENT
FULL.
YOU KNOW IT IT SHOULD BE UP A
COUPLE OF DOLLARS BUT IT JUST
DEPENDS
OKAY.
IT AND I AM MUCH.
MYERSON APART APOLOGIZE I DON'T
HAVE THE EXACT STUDY BY THE
HEARD IS A STUDY THAT JUST
RECENTLY GOT RELEASED DUTCH
SAYS.
ACTUALLY A LOT OF.
HOME.
FOLKS WHO DON'T HAVE CHARGING AT
HOME AND.
CHARGING AT LEVEL THREE.
STATIONS BECAUSE IT JUST OUT
ABOUT IN THE NEED TO GET THAT.
BOSTON THE TO GET A FULL CHARGES
FAST POSSIBLE THAT HAS THAT BEEN
YOUR EXPERIENCE HAVE YOU SEEN
STUDIES OR ANYTHING. THAT DOWN
COULD RESERVE EDUCATE US AS TO
WHAT THE PROPER DEPLOYMENT WOULD
BE.
YEAH IT AGAIN IT'S GOING TO BE
SPECIFIC TO THE AREA FOR US WHAT
WE FIND IS ON.
WE'VE OUT THE ABILITY TO CHARGE
AT HOME OR WORK IF YOU REMOVE
THOSE TWO OPTIONS AND THAT'S
WHERE IT BECOMES EXTREMELY
CHALLENGING AND YOU HAVE TO RELY
ON PUBLIC FASTER AGING BECAUSE.
THEN YOU'RE GONNA LOOK FOR
SOMETHING WHERE I'M GOING TO GO
TO THE GROCERY STORE AND I'M
GONNA BE IN THE GROCERY STORE
BETWEEN FORTY FIVE MINUTES AN
HOUR I WANT TO GET. AS FULL OR
COMPLETELY FULL AS POSSIBLE THAT
TIME AGAIN THIS IS IF I DON'T
HAVE THE OPTION CHARGING HOME
SO.
FOR FOR OUR COMPANY WILL WE
FIND IS THAT.
WE'VE HAD A LOT IN PRIMARY OF
OUR DEPLOYMENTS HAVE BEEN FOUND
IN THE WORKPLACE JUST BECAUSE
THAT BEAT THAT TENDS TO BE A ONE
AREA WHERE YOU KNOW THAT YOU'RE
GONNA BE THERE FOR. EIGHT HOURS
PLUS AND YOU CAN USUALLY CHARGE
EITHER AFFORDABLY OR A LOT OF
WORK PLACES I'D SAY THAT THE
VAST VERY WORKPLACES.
DON'T CHARGE THE EMPLOYEES AT
ALL ON BECAUSE. WHEN YOU'RE
CHARGING FOR AYE THAT LONG
REPEATED TIME THERE'S ACTUALLY
NOT THAT HIVE ELECTRICITY COSTS
A SERIES WITH A SINGLE LEVEL
THREE CHARGE. SO THAT AND THEN
OBVIOUSLY A HUGE NEED IF IF
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT FOCUSING ON
EFFORTS I WOULD SAY NUMBER ONE
BARRIER TODAY IS TENANTS AND
WHERE THEY DO NOT OWN THEIR
PROPERTY THERE IN SOME SORT OF.
MULTI UNIT DWELLING CHAIR
HOUSING.
IT CONTINUES TO BE THE BIGGEST
SIGNIFICANT BARRIER TO EVEN
CHARGING DEPLOYMENT IS THAT
SECTOR.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IF THERE'S NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THIS ISSUE AND THANK
OUR PANELISTS
IT ON ALL THREE OF OF THE THE.
PANELS.
NOW.
PHIL.
IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS FOR THE
OTHER PANEL.
OKAY.
I APOLOGIZE OF MISTER TING. HAD
QUESTIONS FOR SOME OF THE OTHER
PANELISTS.
PANEL ONE CAN WE BRING PANEL ONE
BACK UP.
GIVE ME ON MY TOES HERE TODAY.
THREE TAKE MY APOLOGIES FOR.
STEPPING OUT I THINK I WAS
ARMED.
.
YOU TO QUIT THE QUESTION AROUND
DIE I.
HER THE FIRST PRESENTATION. AND
THERE IS THAT.
.
ONE TWO ELEVEN. RATIO REGARDING
THE.
CHARGING STATIONS TO ELECTRIC
VEHICLES.
TRY TO GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF.
HOW THAT NUMBER WAS DEVELOPED
IN THAT ALSO?
WANTED TO UNDERSTAND. ON HOW
YOU DEVELOPED THE MIX BETWEEN.
LEVEL ONE AND LEVEL TWO FAST
CHARGERS CLICK THINK. WHERE
WE'RE GETTING INFORMATION NOW
LOBBY BECAUSE WE'RE FINALLY
GETTING SOME CRITICAL MASS OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLES ALSO WITH?
BROADER RANGE I THINK THE.
THE LEVEL THREE LEVEL TO LEVEL
ONE DEMANDS ARE STARTING TO.
EVOLVE YES I WANNA GET BETTER
SAY THAT IT'S MILK IT OFF AND
YOU CAN. SO THAT LIMIT ONE IS
ESSENTIALLY A BACK CALCULATION
SO THEY THEN ALICE'S THAT THE CC
DID WAS REALLY DRIVEN AROUND
GETTING ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
SAD SO I BACK ONE POINT THREE
MILLION BE PLUG ELECTRIC
VEHICLES. USE THE NATIONAL HOUSE
WILL TRAVEL SURVEY DATA DID IT.
FROM THE GROUND UP HOW MANY
CHARTERS DO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THESE DIANNE DRIVERS CAN
GET THE ELECTRICITY THEY NEED TO
CONTINUE THEIR NORMAL DRIVING
PATTERNS.
AND SO THE ELEVEN A ONE IS A
COMPARISON TO WHERE WE ARE IN
THE COMPARED TO OTHER
JURISDICTIONS IS NOT LIKE A KEY
FIND OF REPORTS ARE REALLY IF
YOU LOOK AT THAT REPORT ITS ACT.
I'M THE SPREAD BASED ON HOW MUCH
CHARGES ARE SHARED.
IN THE PUBLIC WORKS BUT IN THE
PUBLIC SPACE OF PUBLIC CHARGING
A WORKPLACE CHARGING THAT
REACHES BETWEEN THIRTEEN TO WINE
AND NINE TO ONE DEPENDING.
TO THE AND THAT'S IT CORRESPONDS
THAT SPREAD THAT'S IN THE ETI
PEROT. REPORT THANK YOU AND THEN
THE GAP IS A HUNDRED AND.
TWENTY FIVE TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
FOUR THOUSAND.
YES OVERALL WE'RE PROJECTING YOU
KNOW.
IN THE BELLY  GAP ANNOUNCED
TO BE DONE WITH ABOUT A HUNDRED
THOUSAND CHARTERS YEAH AT ALL
THE PROGRAMS TOGETHER. AND IT
BETWEEN NOW AND TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE IS WHAT WE THINK WE CAN BE
INTO THE GAP WOULD BE ABOUT A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND THAT'S
FOR WORKPLACE PUBLIC AND MULTI
UNIT DWELLING.
AND AND THAT'S BASED ON AN
ESTIMATE OF HITTING ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION VEHICLES BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. BETTER AND THE
TUTOR FIFTY THOUSAND AS.
I'M SORRY BIT SORRY BETWEEN
FIFTY THOUSAND CHARGER TARGETS
BASED ON THE ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION ZEV TARGET IN TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE.
SOME EXTENT. IT DOES BUT JUST
THE MATH DOESN'T SO I GUESS WHEN
I DIVIDE ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
BY ALIVE I GOT A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SIX THOUSAND.
BOISE SO THEY.
SO SINCE IT'S ONE POINT THREE
MILLION SAID THAT THERE'S.
WHAT'S IN THERE THAT'S CONFUSING
IS THAT GONNA FIFTY THOUSAND
INCLUDES MULTI UNIT DWELLINGS.
SO THE RATIO THAT WE COMPARE
TODAY THOSE RATIOS THAT I
MENTIONED FROM.
EXTROVERTED THE INTERNAL THE
INTERNAL AYE CCTV INTERNATIONAL
COUNCIL UNCLEAN TRANSPORTATION.
DID A STUDY FOR US
IT IS PART OF HIS THAT ALLIANCE
AND THEY LOOK AT PUBLIC AND
WORKPLACE CHARGING THOSE OF US
WHO THOSE RATIOS ARE BASED ON.
AND SO WITHIN THE CDC REPORT I
THINK YOU SEE THAT. PUBLIC ON
WORKPLACE CHARGING NUMBERS THAT
WE NEED IS AND I'M NOT GOING TO
MEMORIES OF PLEASE FORGIVE ME
FROM ABOUT NINETY NINE THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND.
AND SO IF YOU DIVIDE THAT BY ONE
POINT THREE MILLION STATE AGAIN.
SO THAT. SO NOT INCLUDING MULTI
UNIT DWELLINGS.
IN THAT PUBLIC SPACE A WORKPLACE
AND.
AND PUBLIC OF BELIEVABLE.
AND I OUT OF PULL NOT THE
NUMBERS ARE ABOUT LIKE NINETY
NINE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
THOUSAND IS THE RANGE THAT THE
ENTERED THE EVA PRO MODELS FOR
IS THE DEMAND.
THAT'S RIGHT.
THAT OF OTHER THAN THAT'S THE
GAP THAT YOU NEED.
JUST IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT PUBLIC
AND WORKPLACE WE ALSO ARE. WITH
THIS EXECUTIVE ORDER TARGETING
MULTI UNIT DRAWINGS WHICH IS THE
KEY.
OKAY I I JUST I GUESS I'D BE
BASED ON YOUR. PRESENTATION IT
DIDN'T QUITE MAKES.
YOUR YOUR.
GAP ANALYSIS DON'T MAKE SENSE.
SO ARM MAYBE WE COULD GET SOME
GREATER DETAIL JR REGARDING THAT
AND I THINK IT WOULD BE HELPFUL
TO.
THEN SEPARATE THE SEGMENTS IF
YOU ARE SEPARATING SEGMENTS
BETWEEN.
WORKPLACE AND PUBLIC. MULTI
FAMILY THAT'S A SEPARATE
STRATEGY ON SEPARATE ANALYSIS
I'D LIKE WE'D LIKE TO.
SEE THAT MORE.
PACIFIC WING YES ARMED.
IN IT I KNOW THAT THIS IS NOT A
PART SPECIFICALLY OF THIS
HEARING BUT. THEY CAN TERMS ON
OF THE.
.
CV R. P. PROGRAM. ON.
WHAT? WHAT GAVE?
?
SORT OF.
WHAT WAS THE ARMY?
YEAH WE HAD TALKED ABOUT THIS
WHEN YOU'RE MY OFFICE.
THINK WEEK OR TWO AGO. ARE.
WHAT NUMBERS DO WE HAVE TO
ENSURE THAT WE COULD GET TO THAT
ONE POINT FIVE AND THE FIVE
MILLION VEHICLE CALLED?
IF YOU I'M SURE YET OF THIS A
STEEP CLIFF IN THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
THAT SO THAT THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION A YEAR WE BELIEVE AT THE
CURRENT REBATE AMOUNTS IS
SUFFICIENT TO COVER THE DEMAND
FOR REBATES. YOU KNOW IN THAT IN
THE NEAR FUTURE WE EXPECT THAT
OVER TIME THOSE REBATES AT THE
REBATE AMOUNTS WOULD NEED TO BE
ADJUSTED IN ORDER TO HIT THOSE
HIGHER TARGETS. AND THAT'S
APPROPRIATE AS THE MARKET
BECOMES MORE SUSTAINABLE THERE'S
MORE UPTAKE OF THOSE VEHICLES
AND WE EXPECT THAT LESS REBATE
WILL BE NECESSARY IN ORDER TO
ACHIEVE THOSE HIGHER TARGETS.
OKAY GREAT. SO I'M JUST.
DOING SOME DIVISION YOU GO TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DIVIDED BY THE
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED YOU GET
EIGHTY THOUSAND TIMES EIGHT.
WHICH IS SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY
THOUSAND.
ADDITIONAL CARS.
WHERE DO YOU GET WHAT WOULD WE
GET THE ADDITIONAL?
CARS.
RIGHT SO USING THE LEVELS OF
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED FOR AN
ELECTRIC VEHICLE M. OF COURSE
THERE'S A MIX BETWEEN PLUGIN
HYBRIDS ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL VEHICLES SO
THAT. THE RANGES VERY.
BUT AS I MENTIONED I THINK OVER
TIME.
IT WILL BE NECESSARY TO
CONSIDER ADJUSTMENTS TO THE
PROGRAM IN ORDER TO STAY WITHIN
THAT TO HER MILLION DOLLAR. PER
YEAR LIMIT.
AND AT THAT POINT IT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE TO REDUCE THE AMOUNT
OF INCENTIVE ON A PER VEHICLE
BASIS OR I'M CONSIDER HOW TO
ADJUST THOSE.
REBATES
TWO ON TARGET THOSE WHO WOULD BE
MOST RESPONSIVE TO THE REBATES
SO WE CAN THINK OF OTHER THINGS
SUCH AS AN ANSWER P. CAPS. WHERE
THERE'S RT INCOME CAPS THAT ARE
IN PLACE RATHER TYPES OF? IN
TERMS OF RIGHT SO FAR WE'VE BEEN
DOING THIS PROGRAM FOR A COUPLE
YEARS NOW WHAT WHAT'S WHAT'S.
YOUR DATA DEMONSTRATE TERMS OF
WHAT'S MOVING PEOPLE IN TERMS
OF.
REBATE AMOUNT.
WELL THE STUDIES
THAT THE REASON THIS TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED AMOUNT WHAT'S SAD IS
THAT THE STUDIES THAT SHOWED AND
THROUGH PUBLIC PROCESS WE
DETERMINED THAT.
THAT AN OVERALL REBATE FOR THE
TYPICAL VEHICLE SUCH AS A NISSAN
LEAF THAT'S OUT THERE TODAY.
WOULD BE ABOUT TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS SO THAT IT WOULD INCLUDE
THE FEDERAL TAX CREDIT WHICH IS
AN INCENTIVE AT SEVENTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS. PLUS THE TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS FROM THE
STATE PROGRAM TO ACHIEVE THAT
OVERALL LEVEL. THAT WAS AND HOW
THE PROGRAM WAS ORIGINALLY
ESTABLISHED BACK IN TWENTY
ELEVEN AND THAT'S STILL
APPROPRIATE WE BELIEVE TODAY
BASED ON WHAT WE'RE SEEING IN
THE MARKETPLACE.
I'M GOING FORWARD.
YOU KNOW THERE'S A QUESTION
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT THAT WOULD
NEED TO.
WHAT HAPPENS WE LOSE THE FEDERAL
TAX GRAY?
SO.
THERE'S WHICH IS A GOOD THING
BECAUSE WE WERE BEING
SUCCESSFUL.
SO THERE'S A COUPLE OF THINGS
THERE AS AS YEAR NOTING THE
FEDERAL TAX CREDIT AS IT'S
CURRENTLY ENVISIONED WOULD GO
AWAY OR WOULD START TO GO AWAY.
IT IT PHASES DOWN IN A
RELATIVELY COMPLICATED FASHION.
WHEN MANUFACTURERS SELL MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
VEHICLES OF.
THAT WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR THE
REBATE AND IT'S ON A PER
MANUFACTURE BASIS.
THERE IS AND THERE HAS BEEN A
PUSH AT AS YOU'RE PROBABLY AWARE
TO EXTEND THAT.
AND IN FACT.
RECENTLY A LOT OF UTILITIES
HAVE BEEN MAKING A VERY STRONG
PUSHING CONGRESS TO EXTEND THAT.
IT AT WILL DISNEY TO MONITOR
THE SITUATION AS IT GOES ALONG.
GREAT I'M IN IN TERMS OF.
STUDIES IS IT YOUR FAITH AT THE
RB THAT'S BEEN DOING THE STUDIES
OR IS IT.
YOU SEE OR WHAT STUDIES ARE YOU
REFERRING TO.
WE HAVE OUR OWN DATA BUT WE WORK
WITH THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
AND OTHERS.
THERE'S A LOT OF STAKEHOLDER
GROUPS THAT ARE DOING WORK AS
WELL GREAT IN THAT DATA THAT YOU
COULD SHARE WITH US YES
ABSOLUTELY PERFECT THAT THERE
WILL BE. GREAT.
.
THEN.
WITH THE GOAL OF GOING BACK TO
THE ARE CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
WITH THE.
PROPOSAL WAS A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION AS OUR.
I'M DOING THIS ON DOING THAT OFF
MEMORIES OUT CORRECT.
VOTE.
FOR THE CHARGING INSTRUCTOR
POLITICS YEAH SO MENTAL ME.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE MILLION IN
BUDGET HERE BUT AN EIGHT YEAR.
INVESTMENT OF NINE HUNDRED
MILLION.
IN THE NINE HUNDRED NINETY WE
GIVE ASSEMBLY CHARGING STATIONS.
IF YOU FACTOR IN THE THE IN
ABOUT A FIFTY PERCENT COSTS
EVERYTHING WE CAN FILL THE GAP.
SO ABOUT YOU KNOW IT AG LEVEL
TWO CHARGING STATION IT IT
VARIES RIGHT WITH UP TO CHARGES
IS ABOUT SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS IF
WE DON'T.
INCLUDE THE BACK AND
INFRASTRUCTURE DC FAST CHARGER
IS.
YOU KNOW CLOSER HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
I'M SO.
WE'RE LOOKING AT IS.
YOU NO WITH THAT I'VE HER
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
ATTRACTING PRIVATE CAPITAL WE
THINK WE CAN FILL THE GAP OF
WHERE WE ARE WHERE WE WERE
PROJECTING TO BE BASED ON OUR
EXISTING INVESTMENTS THROUGH
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND WHERE WE
NEED TO BE.
THAT SUIT.
ABOUT A HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND.
CHARGERS IS THE GAP THAT WE NEED
TO FILL.
OKAY.
OUT OUT OF A TOTAL TO UNDER
FIFTY SO ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE'RE
PROJECTING.
BASED ON EXECUTIVE PROGRAMS
ABOUT A HUNDRED THOUSAND
CHARGERS GIVE OR TAKE AND
THERE'S A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY
THAT NOT A LOT THERE'S A FAIR
AMOUNT OF UNCERTAINTY AND THAT
NUMBER DEPENDING HOW THE
PROGRAM'S ROLLOUT. AND THEN
GETTING TO THE TUNE OF FIFTY
THOUSAND IS THE DIFFERENCE.
SO NINE HUNDRED MILLION GETS ME
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
CHARGERS.
WENT WELL WITH A COCKED CULTURE
FROM THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
THAT BIG GAP THEY WERE TRYING TO
FILL IT BETWEEN ONE POINT TWO
AND ONE POINT.
BILLION
AND WHAT THE THEIR YEAH AND I
AND NINE WERE HOPING FOR NINE
HUNDRED MILLION FROM THE STATE
WILL LEVERAGE. THE ADDITIONAL
PRIVATE FUNDING NEEDS TO GET TO
THE ONE POINT TWO ONE POINT SIX.
TWO ONE POINT SIX BILLION
CHARTERS.
DOLLARS DOLLARS TO GET. OKAY SO
IF WE KEEP AYE I GUESS THIS IS.
YES I I KNOW THIS IS BUDGET
COMMITTEE SO WE DON'T REALLY DO
WELL WITH NUMBERS.
BUT.
.
YOU YOU KNOW NINE HUNDRED.
IF WE GET ANSWERS AS TO HOW MANY
CHARGES THE NINE HUNDRED MILLION
DIPLOMA WE GO TO. WHAT TYPES OF
CHARGERS WHERE WE ANTICIPATE ME
BASED ON OUR BEST GAS WITH THE
RB ANALYSIS?
BECAUSE YOU TALK ABOUT
LEVERAGING MONEY IN THE U. TALK
ABOUT BUYING CHARGERS AND.
THE IT AND AGAIN I I ONLY HAVE
AN IPHONE SO I CAN ONLY DO
DIVISIONS SO. THE DIVISION
DOESN'T QUITE ADD UP AT THIS
POINT.
SO WE CAN GET IS JUST WEEK WEEK
MORE IDEA OF STARVATION UP WE
LAID OUT MORE CLEARLY W. GREAT.
AND ABSENT. ELECTRIC YOU ENDED
UP CAPITAL BUT IT THIS.
THE NUMBERS YOU KNOW THAT BASED
ON OUR BRAVE IS IN ABOUT A
HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND LEVEL TWO
CHARTERS IN ABOUT SEVEN THOUSAND
DC FAST CHARGERS.
IT'S A.
UNDERSTANDABLE WHEN YOU DO
DIVISION BY NINE HUNDRED MILLION
THAT'S A PRETTY GOOD USE
ANSWERED INVESTMENT COMES OUT TO
ABOUT. WE'D WHEN YOU DIVIDE A
HUNDRED AND.
NINE HUNDRED MILLION TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND IT'S LIKE SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
CHARGER.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S QUITE
RIGHT.
WE'LL GET YOU THE RIGHT NUMBERS
JACQUI PERCENT.
ALRIGHT DE THANK YOU.
.
I MEAN TO ASK OF THOSE OF YOU
WHO WORK A WAY TO GET PUBLIC
COMMENT TO BE PATIENT FOR JUST A
COUPLE MINUTES LONGER BECAUSE WE
HAVE A RARE CONFLUENCE OF
HAVING.
FIVE MEMBERS.
PRESENT MR TING IS HERE AS AN
ALTERNATE SO WE'RE GONNA AT A
TAKE OUR VOTES NOW.
A REMINDING Q. ALL THAT.
.
ON THE ITEMS TO BE HEARD IN PART
A OF THE EDGE AND.
EVERYTHING IS A HOLD OPEN ITEM
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF ISSUE FIVE
AND WE VOTED ON ISSUE FIVE
EARLIER SO WILL MOVE NOW IN. A
GO BACK TO THE A VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR. ISSUE NUMBER TWO IN
THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR IS BEING
HOLDEN WILL BE ADDRESSED IF
FUTURE MEETING.
WE WOULD DUH I WOULD APPRECIATE
A MOTION ON ISSUES ONE THREE
NINE TEN ELEVEN TWELVE THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN. AND SIXTEEN.
THAT'S A MOTION TO APPROVE THOSE
ITEMS.
THAT SAID A ON A FOR YOUR
PURPOSES ITEM WE'RE GOING HERE
FOUR FIVE SIX SEVEN EIGHT
SEPARATELY. OF AND SO THIS
MOTION INCLUDES. ISSUES ONE
THREE NINE TEN ELEVEN TWELVE
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN FIFTEEN AND
SIXTEEN.
AND THAT IS THE MOTION THAT IS
BEFORE US.
SECONDED LET'S VOTE.
BLOOM.
I FONG. GARCIA MULLIN.
PATTERSON TING.
TO WORK PULLED AS A GROUP OR
INDIVIDUAL.
RIGHT ISSUE FOR OTHER MOTION.
BLOOM I FONT.
GARCIA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON TING.
IS YOUR FIVE.
BOTH BLOOM I FONG GARCIA.
MULLIN PATTERSON TING.
ISSUE SIX.
MOTION.
THANK YOU.
BLOOM BY PHONE.
GARCIA MULLIN.
PATTERSON. TING.
ISSUE SEVEN.
BLOOM BY FONG.
GARCIA. MULLIN PATTERSON TING.
ISSUE A.
BLOOM I FONT. GARCIA MULLIN.
PATTERSON TING.
AND THE LET'S LET'S.
I LIKE TO DO THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR UNDER PART B..
.
ALSO.
YES AND ISSUES NUMBER ON PART BE
VOTE ONLY CALENDAR.
ISSUES THREE AND FIFTEEN ARE
BEING PULLED THEM WILL BE HEARD
AT A FUTURE MEETING.
AND WE DO COLLECTIVE.
ITEMS.
ALRIGHT SO ISSUES THREE AND
FIFTEEN HAVE BEEN PULLED IN WILL
BE HEARD AT A FUTURE MEETING.
WE'RE GOING TO.
ADDRESS ISSUES TO FOUR FIFTEEN
AND FIFTY.
TWO FOUR SIXTEEN AND NINETEEN.
SEPARATELY AND SO I WOULD
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON ISSUES.
ONE.
FIVE SIX SEVEN EIGHT NINE TEN
ELEVEN TWELVE. THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY.
BELOW. I FALL.
GARCIA MULLIN.
PATTERSON TING.
BECAUSE OUR MOTION ON ISSUE TO.
YOU'RE SUCH.
AMONG.
BLOOM AYE FONG.
GARCIA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
TING.
ISSUE FOR MOTION.
BLOOM AYE FONG.
GARCIA MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
TING.
ISSUE SIXTEEN.
HELLO.
I FALL.
GARCIA.
MULLIN. PATTERSON.
TING.
AND TO FINALLY ISSUE NINETEEN.
THEIR SECOND.
HELLO I FALL.
GARCIA MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
TING.
THANK YOU OFFER OF BEING HERE
WE'RE GONNA HEAR PUBLIC COMMENT
NOW AND THANK YOU SO MUCH OF WHO
BEEN STANDING AND WAITING FOR
BEING PATIENT.
THAT WAS IMPRESSIVELY EFFICIENT.
JULIA LEVELING WITH A.
WITH THE BIO ENERGY ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT MORE
THAN SEVENTY PUBLIC AGENCIES
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND PRIVATE
COMPANIES UP AND DOWN THE STATE
THAT ARE CONVERTING ORGANIC
WASTE TO ENERGY. PRIMARILY TO
REDUCE SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS EMISSIONS.
IT YOU LOOK AT THE STATE'S
TWENTY THIRTY CLIMATE CHANGE
SCOPING PLAN.
MORE THEN HALF OF ALL OF THE
EMISSION REDUCTIONS ARE GONNA
COME FROM THREE SOURCES THE
REDUCTION OF SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS. AND INCREASE
PRODUCTION OF BIOFUELS AND
REDUCTION OF EMISSIONS FROM THE
FREIGHT SECTOR.
SHORT LIVED CLIMATE POLLUTANTS
REDUCTION ALONE IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR MORE THAN A THIRD OF ALL THE
CLIMATE CHANGE REDUCTIONS THAT
THE STATE NEEDS TO ACHIEVE TO
MEET THE REQUIREMENTS OF S. B.
THIRTY TWO. AND SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE. FOR THAT REASON WE
URGED THE LEGISLATURE TO
INCREASE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
FUNDING FOR CALORIE CYCLE. FROM
TWENTY MILLION TWO HUNDRED
MILLION PER YEAR WE ALSO A
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
INCREASE THE FUNDING FOR CAL
FIRE. SINCE WILDFIRE EMISSIONS
NOW EXCEED ALL OF THE CLIMATE
CHANGE REDUCTIONS THAT WE'VE
ACHIEVED IN EVERY OTHER SECTOR
COMBINED.
AND IF IT'S IMPORTANT TO
ALLOCATED PORTION OF THAT TO
FORCE BIOMASS BECAUSE WE NEED TO
DO SOMETHING WITH THE DEAD AND
DYING TREES AND OTHER FORCE
FIELDS. REMOVED TO REDUCE
WILDFIRE RISKS.
WE STRONGLYSUPPORT THE PROPOSED
FUNDING FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGRICULTURE FOR DAIRY METHANE
REDUCTION. AND WE SUPPORT THE
FUNDING FOR OUR INDIAN FOR
BIOFUELS. THE LAST POINT I'D
LIKE TO MAKE ABOUT BIOFUELS.
GIVEN THE IMPORTANCE OF REDUCING
SHORT LIVED CLIMATE POLLUTANTS
AND BIOFUELS TO MEET THE STATE'S
CLIMATE STRATEGY IT IS SHOCKING
THAT THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION HAS PROPOSED. ZERO
FUNDING FROM THE A. R. FTTP ZERO
FOR BIOFUELS PRODUCTION EVEN
THOUGH. BIOGAS FROM DIVERTED
ORGANIC WASTE OR DAIRY IS THE
ONLY CARBON NEGATIVE FUEL IN
EXISTENCE AND THOSE FUELS ARE
CRITICAL TO ME ARE SHORT LIVED
CLIMATE POLLUTANTS STRATEGY AND
REQUIREMENTS.
WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO WEIGH
IN WITH THE ENERGY COMMISSION
AND SAY THAT AB EIGHT WHICH
REQUIRES MAXIMIZING THE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE GREENHOUSE GAS.
AND AIR POLLUTION REDUCTIONS.
THAT THE ENERGY COMMISSION IS
NOT MEETING THAT REQUIREMENT BY
ZEROING OUT THE FUNDING FOR
BIOFUELS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE ONE OTHER
ITEM UNDER UP.
.
I ITEM PARTY OF OUR AN AGENDA
THAT'S CAP AND TRADE BUDGET WE
ARE GOING TO ADDRESS THAT AND
JUST A MOMENT. SPEAKING TO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUE SO JULIE
MALINOWSKI THE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION. IS IT
FIRST WE LIKE TO THINK YOU FOR
THIS PANEL AND THIS.
YOU KNOW THIS LOOKING INTO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUE IT HAS BEEN
A DELAY ARENA OUTSTANDING ISSUE.
AS WE'RE TRYING TO BUILD THE
LEGISLATURE'S GOALS TOFOR EVEY
PENETRATION AND AND OF COURSE
THE ADMINISTRATION'S GOALS SO WE
WE KNOW THIS IS BEEN COMING AND
WE ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT WHAT THE
GOVERNOR IS TRYING TO DO WE HOPE
THAT'S. THIS BODY.
APPROVES THAT A WE WANNA MAKE
TWO POINTS ON THAT THAT THAT
WHAT YOU HEARD TODAY AND WHEN
THE PANEL SAYS YES THIS THIS
MONEY IS ACTUALLY BEING.
SHARED WITH PRIVATE INVESTMENT
YOU KNOW UTILITIES ARE OUT
THERE.
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS ARE
PUTTING LARGE AMOUNTS OF CAPITAL
INTO IMPROVING INFRASTRUCTURE
AVAILABILITY IN CALIFORNIA IN
ALL COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AND THE SECOND POINT I
WANT TO MAKE IS YOU KNOW YOU'RE
BUILDING INFRASTRUCTURE IS
ACTUALLY BUILDING JOBS
SO THERE'S A TRUE ECONOMIC
IMPACT.
A POSITIVE ECONOMIC IMPACT WHEN
WE INCREASE THOSE NUMBERS AND
AND MAKE SURE THAT THE NUMBER OF
CHARTERS AVALA FOLLOWING.
THAT INCREASING NUMBERS OF
VEHICLES SO WE SUPPORT BATON ASK
FOR YOUR SPURS WHILE THINKING
THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA ADVANCED BIOFUELS
ALLIANCE.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE OBJECTIONS TO
THE PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU BY THE
GOVERNOR SIMPLY BECAUSE THIS IS
NOTHING SHORT OF A GOTTEN A
MANNED OF AB ONE EIGHTEEN.
AB ONE EIGHTEEN WAS DESIGNED TO
COLLECT FEES FROM.
CAR OWNERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR THE DEVELOPMENT.
OF ALTERNATIVE FUELS
AND A BALANCED PORTFOLIO OF
ALTERNATE ALTERNATIVE FUELS
ESSENTIALLY WHAT THIS PROPOSAL
IS DOING IS SIMPLY MAKING IT. AN
ELECTRIC VEHICLE OR HIDE
HYDROGEN INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING
PROGRAM.
AT THE DISADVANTAGE
OF ALL THE OTHER BIOFUEL
INDUSTRIES AND SECTORS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND SO REPRESENTING THE
BIODIESEL INDUSTRY.
THAT IS A DROP IN FUEL
REPLACEMENT THAT IS
COLLECTIVELY WITH ALL OTHER
BIOFUELS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA RESPONSIBLE FOR
EIGHTY SEVEN PERCENT. OF THE.
REDUCTIONS THAT WE'VE SEEN SO
FAR FROM OUR TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR WERE NOW BEING HUNG OUT
TO DRY WITH ZERO DOLLARS.
WERE GIVEN TWENTY FIVE MILLION
IN THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM BUT
THAT'S JUST A ONE YEAR DEAL.
FRANKLY WE'D BE BETTER OFF WITH
THE AB ONE EIGHTEEN MONIES
BECAUSE WE KNOW THEY EXIST TO
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR AND AT LEAST
WILL BE ABLE TO FIGHT FOR THAT
TWENTY FIVE MILLION WHICH IS A
PALTRY SUM. WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
LION'S SHARE OF THE WORK THAT
THE BIO FUELS INDUSTRY.
S. CARING SO WE DON'T OPPOSE.
INVESTMENT IN INFRASTRUCTURE
IN FACT WE THINK IT'S NEEDED BUT
WE THINK IT SHOULD BE NEEDED AND
WE SHOULD BE IT SHOULD BE
EVALUATED TO BENEFIT ALL FUELS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE IT ULTIMATELY IF OUR
GOAL IS TO REDUCE EMISSIONS
AND CARBON EMISSIONS
PARTICULARLY IN THE STATE AND WE
CAN DO THAT BY IMPACTING EVERY
VEHICLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. NOT JUST SIXTEEN
PERCENT OF THEM.
SO WE ASK THAT THIS COMMITTEE
WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND
LOOK FOR.
SOME OPPORTUNITY TO ACTUALLY PUT
SOME INVESTMENT BACK IN TO THE
OTHER ALTERNATIVE FUELS THAT ARE
HELPING THE STATE ACHIEVE ITS
GOALS THANK YOU.
HI GOOD MORNING TERRIBLY MEMBERS
THE COMMITTEE I'M RYAN RYAN
KENNY WITH CLEAN ENERGY.
REAL NATION'S LARGEST PROVIDER
OF RENEWABLE NASA GAS
TRANSPORTATION FUEL AND JUST
ECHO IN THE PREVIOUS COMMENTS WE
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. TO DIVERT
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FROM
AB ONE EIGHTEEN.
AND BACK PHILLIP WITH THAT USE
YOUR HALF AS YOU KNOW THAT IS A
FUNDING DECISION A COULD BE
BUILT ON QUICKSAND BECAUSE
FUTURE.
FUNDING DECISIONS CAN ALSO BE
DEPEND UPON EACH YEAR HALF AND
THAT MONEY COULD BE.
DIVERTED VERY EASILY TO DO
OTHER DECISIONS INCLUDING
POLITICAL DECISIONS
ALSO MENTION TO THAT ANY
DIVERSION.
OF THIS THAT MONEY I'D DOES
IMPACT THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY OF
BUSINESS COMMITTEE DOES REACT TO
THESE PROPOSALS.
AND.
.
NO MARKET CERTAINTY IS
EVERYTHING.
IN THE IN THE BILE FEELS.
INDUSTRY SO WE ASK THAT THE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS NOT
BE I REMOVED AND ALSO I BUILT
UPON.
WITH OTHER TO YOUR FUNDS FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PRODUCTION
THANK YOU.
I MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE OUT MY NAME IS
DOCTOR SHANE STEPHENS I'M A
FOUNDER OF FIRST ONLY FUEL. THE
LARGEST OWNER OPERATOR OF RETAIL
HYDROGEN STATIONS IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE HEADQUARTERED IN FOUNDED
DOWN IN IRVINE CALIFORNIA.
IT'S FOR A CALIFORNIA BASED
COMPANY.
I'M A LITTLE OVER THREE YEARS
AGO MY COMPANY RECEIVED ABOUT
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION TO
GO BUILD RETAIL HYDROGEN
STATIONS.
WE PUT THAT MONEY TO WORK AND WE
ACTUALLY BUILT AND OPENED
EIGHTEEN HYDROGEN STATIONS. AT A
SPEED AND SCALE THAT WAS
UNPRECEDENTED ANYWHERE IN THE
WORLD FOR DEVELOPING HYDROGEN
INFRASTRUCTURE.
TODAY A FUEL CELL CAR OWNER
DOWN IN SAN DIEGO CAN DRIVE TO
LAKE TAHOE AND SEVEN AND A HALF
HOURS WITH JUST HIS FUEL CELL
CAR IN A CREDIT CARD.
STOPPING A FIELD OF FIVE
MINUTES ALONG THE WAY.
.
A AND AND MISTER CHAIRMAN WE I
ACTUALLY FOCUS VERY HEAVILY ON
ALL OF OUR STATIONS BEING VERY
WELL LIT SO IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU
HAVE VISITED. OURS SO SORRY
ABOUT THAT AND WE'RE WORKING ON
THE SIGNAGE THING WE ARE. WE
HAVE WHEN I HAVE LEARNED THAT
ALL STATIONS ARE NATALIE YEAH.
.
SO ARE SO SINCE WE OPENED FOR
STATION WE'VE PERFORMED OVER A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND FILLS.
NO THAT EQUATES TO TWENTY EIGHT
MILLION MILES OF GASOLINE.
THAT WERE ELIMINATED AND
REPLACED WITH ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE MILES. AND THAT
TRANSLATES TO SEVENTEEN MILLION
POUNDS OF CO TWO AVOIDED.
SO PEOPLE ARE BUYING THESE CARS
AND PEOPLE ARE DRIVING THE HECK
OUT OF THESE CARS WHICH IS
GREAT.
I AT THE SAME TIME WE'RE SEEING
EVEN THOUGH THIS IS A VERY EARLY
STAGE IN THE MARKET SOME STRESS
HONOR STATIONS.
.
SO OUR OUR FIVE BUSIEST STATIONS
GET MAXED OUT.
A COUPLE TIMES A WEEK TODAY.
ASSEMBLYMAN MULLIN ACTUALLY THE
STATION WE VISITED IN YOUR
DISTRICT IS ONE OF THOSE FIVE
BUSIEST STATIONS SOURCING IT.
GET MAX NOW ON A REGULAR BASIS.
SO THAT'S OPEN OUR EYES TO THE
FACT THAT WE NEED TO ACCELERATE.
TO SCALE AND I KEEP PACE WITH
THE CARS THAT ARE COMING.
WE BELIEVE THAT IF WE KEEP PACE
AND WE WILL ACHIEVE REALLY
COMMERCIAL SCALE THAT BY TWENTY
THIRTY. THERE'S AN OFF RAMP FOR
GOVERNMENT FUNDING FOR HYDROGEN
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND THAT WE CAN BE COST
COMPETITIVE WITH GASOLINE.
AND YOU KNOW FRANK THAT I
BELIEVE THAT SINGLE LINE OF
SIGHT TO THE OFFERING FOR
GOVERNMENT FUNDING SHOULD BE A
VERY IMPORTANT PART. OF ANY
DISCUSSION IN INVESTMENTS FOR
SEVEN FOR STRUCTURE.
.
SO THAT BRINGS TODAY I WE ARE
HUGELY SUPPORTERS OF A
SUPPORTIVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER AND.
THAT BUDGET REQUEST.
WHERE HUSING SUPPORT OF THE
WORK THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION HAS DUG HAS DONE AND
IS DOING TO BUILD OUT THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE? AND WE BELIEVE
THAT WITH HALF THE MONEY IS
OUTLINED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER TOWARDS HYDROGEN
WE CAN KEEP PACE AND GET THAT
EARLY COMMERCIAL SCALE. BY
TWENTY THIRTY IN ACHIEVING
OFFERING FOR GOVERNMENT FUNDING.
SO WE ENCOURAGE TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL APPROACH FOR ZEV.
TO SEE HOW THE MONEY'S GOOD
HYDROGENS THAT WE CAN ACHIEVE
OUR GOALS THANK YOU.
JEAN URBAN REPRESENTING THE
ALLIANCE OF AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURERS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT. THE GOVERNOR'S.
COMMITMENT TO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THERE'S A SEVERE
DEFICIT THERE'S NO QUESTION.
IT'S AN IMPEDIMENT TO THE
DEPLOYMENT IS A VEHICLES. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT INCENTIVES
AND AS MISTER BLOOM KNOWS WE
HAVE STABILIZE THE HOV STICKER
INCENTIVE IS NOW THE TWO POINT
OH PROGRAM.
VIABLE THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE WE HAVE ALWAYS LAMENTED THE
ANNUAL APPROPRIATION FOR THE CV
RP WHICH HAS CARVED TESTIFIED
AND INTERRUPTED ON MORE THAN ONE
OCCASION. WE THINK IT'S A
CRITICAL FEATURE THE TO
INCENTIVES COMBINED. WILL DO
VERY WELL WE THINK HOV ACCESS
AND OR THAT THE STICKER.
ARE AND OR THE REBATE.
THE FIRST TIME EVER WE
PENETRATED THE FIVE PERCENT
SALES ON ONE HALF OF WHICH
APPROXIMATELY ALL DEFERRED A
CARBON THIS REMAIN THE PLUG IN
HYBRID.
SO THEY'RE NOT THE PURE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE THEY REMAIN THE
PLUG IN HYBRID.
BUT WE NEED HYDROGEN
INFRASTRUCTURE WE NEED
ELECTRICAL INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE NEED THE CVR P. ON AN ANNUAL
RELIABLE PREDICTABLE BASIS.
I'M ADJUSTMENTS ARE REFINEMENTS.
SCARE US A LITTLE.
IF THEY'RE DONE TOO QUICKLY OR
TOO SEVERELY WE THINK THAT THEY
NEED TO BE SURGICAL. ON THEY
ALSO NEED TO BE LINKED.
IF WE'RE NOT DEPLOYING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE ON SCHEDULE AS
YOU SUGGESTED MISTER MULLIN.
AND WE SHOULDN'T BE CUT IN THE
REBATE.
SO THEY HAVE TO BE DONE AND A
THOUGHTFUL WAY IN THE FUTURE BUT
ON BALANCE WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS WERE WAY AHEAD OF EVERY
OTHER STATE IN THE NATION.
WE FACE HAD WINS THE LOSS OF THE
FEDERAL TAX CREDIT IS GOING TO
SURFACE IN THE NEXT FEW YEARS.
STUBBORNLY LOW PRICING GASOLINE.
IS A PROBLEM.
BUT NOT IT ALL BUT ALL OF THIS
CAN BE OVERCOME I THINK WITH
DEDICATED REBATES HOV STICKERS
AND THE DEPLOYMENT OF
INFRASTRUCTURE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOSH
PAWN AND WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
REFUSE RECYCLING COUNCIL.
HEART THERE ARE A HANDFUL OF
COMPANIES ALREADY A.
PROVIDING THE RENEWABLE FUEL NOT
THAT IS TAKING OUR ORGANICS.
MIXING. PUTTING THEM TAKING THE
METHANE OUT AND THEN INJECTING
BACK AGAIN.
TO FUEL TRUCKS AND MISTER
MULLIN KNOWS IT'S ONE OF THE
THREE ARE IN HIS DISTRICT.
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE IS CRITICAL
SO WE WOULD URGE YOU.
BECAUSE IT IS A A NET NEGATIVE
BELOW THE ZERO LINE.
.
FUEL
THIS A RENEWABLE GAS WE'D URGE
YEAR TO JUST TO JUST THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET A BET.
I PUT DEATH TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
MILLION AND FOR THAT TYPE OF
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AYE BECAUSE IN THIS WAY WE CAN
EXPAND THE WHOLE AROUND THE
STATE.
TO GIVE YOU AN IDEA AYE IF WE
WERE TO DO THIS WITH SIXTY SEVEN
FACILITIES AROUND THE STATE.
I WE WOULD BE AYE IN THE
CATGORY OF ONE MILLION TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY. THOUSAND TONS
OF THE EMISSION REDUCTIONS.
JUST WITH USING THIS ORGANIC
FRAGMENT AND AT FUELING OUR
TRUCKS
SO WE HAVE THREE COMPANIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT ARE
DOING THAT AYE WE'D URGENT JUST
TO ADJUST THE BUDGET REFLECT
PROPERLY.
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS
BEGINNING TO BLOSSOM
AND EXPANDED.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
TO BRING US DOWN A LITTLE BIT
GERMAN BLOOM AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE SOME
COMMENTS TODAY. MY NAME IS MIKE
LORD I'M AN EXECUTIVE ENGINEER
AT.
TOYOTA MOTOR NORTH AMERICA.
.
FOR SO I WANT TO SAY THE TOYOTA
BELIEVES IN THE ZERO EMISSION
FUTURE AND IS WORKING HARD TO
BRING PRODUCTS TO THE MARKET.
YET THE MARIAH FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLE. AND THE PLUG
INTO A.
VEHICLE THE PREVIOUS PRIME IN
THE MARKET RIGHT NOW. THIS
TRANSITION IS AS DIFFICULT AS WE
ALL KNOW AND. DOES REQUIRE SOME
GOVERNMENT SUPPORT IN THESE
EARLY TRANSITION YEARS.
THAT BEING SAID DOT TOYOTA.
FULLY SUPPORTS THE GOVERNOR'S A
HERE TWO POINT FIVE BILLION
INVESTMENT PLAN WHICH INCLUDES
BOTH THE NINE HUNDRED MILLION.
FOR SEVEN FOR STRUCTURE ON THE
ONE POINT SIX BILLION FOR CV RP.
AND TIED ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORTS
THE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TWO
HUNDRED STATION TARGET.
WE BELIEVE THIS IS THE MINIMUM
NUMBER OF STATIONS NEEDED TO
SUPPORT THE NUMBER OF FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLES EXPECTED IN
THE MARKET.
BOB I JUST WANT TO MAKE ONE
COMMENT ALSO REGARDING FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLES OR SOME
DISCUSSION ON THE DIFFICULTY.
FOR PEOPLE LIVING IN MULTI UNIT
WELLINGS AND FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
VEHICLES ARE A GREAT OPTION FOR
THOSE PEOPLE BECAUSE YOU FEEL.
AT STATIONS OUTSIDE YOUR HOUSE
JUST LIKE A CONVENTIONAL
GASOLINE ELECTRIC VEHICLES A GAS
GUZZLING VEHICLE.
JUST A COMMENT OR TWO ON THE
STATION FUNDING PROCESS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THE CC.
THE ENERGY COMMISSION ON THIS OF
WE HOPE AT ONE WORK WITH THEM TO
MAKE SURE THE FEW THE FUNDS ARE
DISPERSED IN A WAY.
THAT ALLOWS FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
OF STATION NETWORKS.
ABLE TO CREATE ECONOMIES OF
SCALES AND SPUR FASTER MORE
EFFICIENT INFRASTRUCTURE
DEVELOPMENT ACROSS THE STATE.
BUT WE ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT
THE STATIONS SHOULD BE AWARDED A
BY TWENTY TWENTY THREE BECAUSE
IT TAKES ABOUT TWO YEARS. TO GET
THE STATIONS ARE IN THE GROUND.
AND FINALLY WE SUPPORT ALSO THE
CURRENT US CC FUNDING PROPOSAL.
ALLOCATING NINETY TWO MILLION
FOR HYDROGEN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
THOMAS LOST SOME OF THE
CALIFORNIA AFTER GAS VEHICLE
COALITION. A WE ALL LIKE TO LINE
OUR COMMENTS WITH A MISS LEVIN
MISTER BROWN TO MISTER KINNEY.
AND WE ALSO WANT TO SUPPORT.
THE COMMENTS BY ILIO WE THINK
THAT THEY OFFER OFFERED SOME
VERY INTERESTING QUESTIONS THAT
NEED TO BE ANSWERED. A ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WHEN DAD WAS NEW
TO THE DISCUSSION IS.
.
YOU KNOW THERE NEEDS TO BE.
A SIMILAR FOCUS ON THE HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLE.
SECTOR RIGHT WE SPENT A LOT OF
TIME TODAY TALKING ABOUT LIGHT
DUTY CARS.
AND I THINK THAT THAT IS
EXPECTED IT NEEDS TO BE CLEANED
UP AND I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT
I WILL SAVE IT BASED ON A A RP
DATA DATA THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN
OUT THERE. WE KNOW THAT HAVE TO
DO VEHICLES ARE CAUSING THE MOST
DAMAGE SO WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
TRY TO GET THOSE REDUCTIONS IN
THOSE PARTICULAR BUREAU CLASSES
CLASS SEVEN AND EIGHT. AND I'LL
ALSO SAY WE WILL BE REALLY GREAT
FOR I THINK THE MEMBERS AS WELL
STAFF TO HEAR IS A PANEL. THAT
TALKS ABOUT WHAT PRIVATE AND
PUBLIC FEATS NEED TO MAKE THAT
TRANSITION HAPPEN YOU KNOW WE
ARE HAVING A CONVERSATION RIGHT
NOW ABOUT CONSUMERS. AND I THINK
THAT THE LEGISLATURE.
IT'S LONG OVERDUE IN THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE A CONVERSATION
TO BIFURCATE THAT AND HAVE A.
CONVERSATION ABOUT CONSUMERS
TRAFFIC IS GREAT AND HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE PLEASE NEED FOR
THEIR HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE
PURCHASES. THEY PURCHASE
VEHICLES IN A DIFFERENT WAY TO
KEEP THEM IN AND AND A LONGER
AND THEY HAVE DIFFERENT DUTY
CYCLES AND SO CLEAN THOSE UP I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT. AND
HAVING A RESOURCES BEHIND THA
CONVERSATION IS GOING TO BE
COOLEY IMPORTANT WE LOOK FOR TO
ENGAGE WITH YOU ON THAT IN IN
THAT DISCUSSION THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BURRS MELISSA
AND MO ON BEHALF OF THE WESTERN
PROPANE GAS ASSOCIATION WE TWO
WOULD ECHO PRIOR COMMENTS
REGARDING THE NEED TO BE
INCLUSIVE OF. AND EXPAND
INVESTMENT AND BIOFUELS WHICH
PLAY AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN
MEETING THE STATE'S ENERGY NEEDS
AND GOALS THANK YOU.
SCARY MEMBERS DUNCAN MCFETRIDGE
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA ETHANOL
INDUSTRY I DO WANT TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF MY BIOFUELS.
COLLEAGUES WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
NOTE THAT DOWN. AS MANY OF YOU
MAY KNOW.
ETHANOL AND BIOFUELS HAVE BEEN
THE WORK WORKFORCE OF THE LC FS.
WITHOUT THOSE FUELS WE WOULD NOT
BE WHERE WE ARE IN TERMS OF THE
CARBON ISING.
THE MARKET UNFORTUNATELY ON ON
FOR MOST OF OUR FUELS IN
PARTICULAR ETHANOL.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THOSE FUELS
ARE COMING FROM OUT OF STATE WE
PRODUCE PROBABLY ABOUT TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF.
TODAY'S ETHANOL IN CALIFORNIA
WHICH CONSTITUTES ABOUT TEN
PERCENT OF EVERY. GALLON OF
GASOLINE IN EVERY CALIFORNIA
CAR.
WE HAVE A LOT OF ROOM TO GROW WE
HAVE MORE JOBS TO. OUR CREATE WE
HAVE MORE TECHNOLOGY TO INNOVATE
AND WE HAVE NEW FEED STOCKS THAT
WE CAN.
INTRODUCE INTO THE MARKETPLACE
DUSTY CARBON ISING.
IF YOU'LL EVEN MORE. WE OPPOSE
DIVERTING THE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS.
TO CAP AND TRADE WE THINK WE
SHOULD KEEP
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS GROW
THAT AND ALSO ADD TO THE CAP AND
TRADE.
WE WOULD WHO CLEARS COMMITTEES.
CONSIDERATION OF THAT REQUEST.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
BIRDS ARE CORBELS ON BEHALF OF
THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
ASSOCIATION JUST WANT TO QUICKLY
SAY I OF COURSE WERE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF GOVERNOR BROWN'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER ON HE CHARGING
AND THE ENERGY COMMISSION'S.
AUGMENTED FOCUS ON.
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE I JUST QUICKLY
ADD.
MUCH LIKE MR SOBRE FROM CAL
STAR POINTED OUT THAT THE.
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
MEDIUM HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES IS
STILL A TOUGH NUT TO CRACK. AND
WE TWO WOULD WANT TO SEE SOME
KIND OF FOCUS ON A
INFRASTRUCTURE SOLUTIONS FOR
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES
GIVEN THAT.
THAT'S A WHOLE NOTHER BAG OF
ISSUES THAT REQUIRE SOME
INNOVATIVE THINKING AND
INTERESTING IDEAS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR
COMMENTS SO WERE ARE GOING TO
NOW I HAVE REPRESENTATION ON
THAT THE.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN CAP
AND TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN.
THIS IS A HOLD OPEN ITEM WILL
HAVE PLENTY OF TIME.
TO CONSIDER THIS AS WE AS WE GO
FORWARD OVER THE COURSE OF.
THE BUDGET SESSION.
WELCOME STRONGLY THANK YOU.
NAM LET ME QUICKLY CHANGE MY
OPENING COMMENTS FROM GOOD
MORNING TO GOOD AFTERNOON.
A GOOD AFTERNOON A MAN ONLY
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
A OF ONE POINT TWO FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR A CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN. FOR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
OTHER PRIORITIES FOR THE CAPITA
EXPENDITURE PLAN WERE INFORMED
BY SEVERAL CONSIDERATIONS.
UP ONE OF WAS CONSISTENCY WITH
FEE A. B. A THREE NINETY EIGHT
EXPENDITURES PRIORITIES.
A LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE
ENACTED A BETWEEN NINETY EIGHT
WHICH SPECIFIED THE FOLLOWING
EXPENDITURE PRIORITIES.
A AIR TOXIC CAN CRITERIA
POLLUTANTS.
LOW ZERO A CARBON TRANSPORTATION
ALTERNATIVES.
SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURAL
PRACTICES.
HEALTHY FORESTS.
SHORT LIVED CLIMATE POLLUTANTS
CLIMATE ADAPTATION RESILIENCY
AND CLIMATE AND CLEAN ENERGY
RESEARCH.
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL IS
CONSISTENT WITH HIS PRIORITIES
IDENTIFIED IN AB THREE NINETY
EIGHT.
IN ADDITION OF THE CAN.
ONE OTHER FACTOR OF
CONSIDERATION OR BENEFITS TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
OUR EXISTING LAW REQUIRES THAT
AT LEAST TO THIRTY FIVE PERCENT.
OF CAPITAL EXPENDITURES BENEFIT
DISADVANTAGED AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES
IN THATTHE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL COMPLIES WITH THIS
REQUIREMENT.
AVAILABILITY OF OTHER FUNDING
SOURCES WAS ANOTHER.
FEDERATION.
FOR EXAMPLE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL ACCOUNTS
FOR THE FACT.
S. B. FIVE
THE PROPOSED PARK SOME WATER
BOND INCLUDES FUNDING FOR
SEVERAL PROGRAMS SUCH AS URBAN
GREENING URBAN FORESTRY.
THAT HAVE BEEN FUNDED PREVIOUSLY
FROM CAP AND TRADE.
SO BASED ON THESE CONSIDERATIONS
THE ADMINISTRATION'S CARPENTRY
PLAN DOES TWO THINGS.
ONE THEY'RE BUILT ON THE
FRAMEWORK OF THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN CAP INTRIGUE PACKAGE
INTO IT SUPPORTS SEVERAL NEW
INITIATIVES.
IN TERMS OF BUILDING ON LAST
YEAR'S CAP AND TRADE PACKAGE.
THE PROPOSAL.
CONTINUES THE COMMITMENT TO THE%
GOALS OF SIX SEVENTEEN.
AND IT PROVIDES A PROPORTIONATE
FUNDING TO LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION HEALTHY FOREST.
IN CLIMATE SMART AGRICULTURE.
IN ADDITION THE PROPOSAL SO
SUPPORT SEVERAL NEW INITIATIVES
INCLUDING ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
INITIATIVE THAT. WAS JUST
DISCUSSED.
A CALIFORNIA A INTEGRATED
CLIMATE INVESTMENT PROGRAM.
IN THE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE CHANGE
TECHNOLOGY AND SOLUTIONS
INITIATIVE.
A NO I WAS INTENDING TO TURN THE
MICROPHONE OVER TO US SEVERAL OF
MY ADMINISTRATION COLLEAGUES.
HERE.
TO DISCUSS US OF SEVERAL OF
THESE ANDA NEW INITIATIVES A
VERY BRIEFLY IN MORE DETAIL BUT
BEFORE I DO THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY. TO LET
THE SUBCOMMITTEE NO THAT LAST
WEEK.
THE ADMINISTRATION RELEASED ITS
ANNUAL REPORT ON CAPTURING
AUCTION PROCEEDS
THIS REPORT A IS PROVIDED
PURSUANT TO AB FIFTEEN THIRTY
TWO.
OUT WHICH REQUIRES AN ANNUAL
REPORT ON THE STATUS OF PROJECTS
FUNDED BY THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND IN THE OUTCOMES.
THESE REQUIREMENTS ESTABLISHED A
FRAMEWORK OF TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE CAPITA
RATE PROGRAM.
SOME HIGHLIGHTS ARE THE TO DATE
A THREE BILLION DOLLARS HAS BEEN
AWARDED.
TWO BILLION DOLLARS SINCE BEEN
DISPERSED TO APPROXIMATE A TWO
HUNDRED. EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
PROJECTS.
AND.
OVER THE LIFETIME OF THESE
IMPLEMENTED PROJECTS THESE
INVESTMENTS ARE ESTIMATED TO
REDUCE A A TWENTY THREE MILLION
TONS OF GHG A MISSIONS.
SO WITH THAT A LET ME.
TURN IT OVER MAYBE FIRST TO.
WIN THE WINSTON FROM THE
STRATEGIC OF COUNSEL.
I THINK YOU MATIN THANK YOU.
SIMMERING AND IN A COMMITTEE.
AS MATT MENTIONED RENTAL ONCE
WITH THE STRATEGIC O. COUNCILMAN
DESCRIBE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE CHANGE TECHNOLOGY AND
SOLUTIONS INITIATIVE. A AND THIS
REALLY IS AN EVOLUTION OF OUR
EXISTING CLIMATE CHANGE RESEARCH
PROGRAM WHICH OF YOUR
APPROPRIATE ELEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
BUT WITH A NEW FOCUS ON. A
ACCELERATING THE DEPLOYMENT AND
COMMERCIALIZATION OF LOW
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
TECHNOLOGIES TOOLS AND
APPROACHES.
OUR INTENT HERE IS NOT TO
DUPLICATE EFFORTS BOTH WHAT'S
HAPPENING ACROSS STATE
GOVERNMENT AND COST ACROSS UBER
LEADING INSTITUTIONS IN THE
STATE. BUT REALLY TO PUT A
SHARPER FOCUS ON DRAWING FROM
THE BEST OF OUR STATES ACADEMIC
AND PRIVATE SECTOR INNOVATORS TO
MEET OUR CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS.
ALTERNATIVES TWO THINGS QUICKLY
HERE'S ONE DESCRIBE WHAT WE'VE
DONE SO FAR WITH THE ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS.
SINCE THAT IS REALLY SORT OF
THE.
THAT THE BRIDGE TO THAT OF
THIRTY FIVE MILLION AND QUICKLY.
OR THINKING WITH REGARD TO
GOVERNMENTS AND PUBLIC PROCESS
AND SO WITH THE ELEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE CLIMATE CHANGE
RESEARCH PROGRAM A WE FIRST HAVE
TO DEVELOP OF RESEARCH
INVESTMENTPLAN IN. AND PUT UP
FILL FOR PATIENT A RESEARCH
INVESTMENT PLAN WAS REALLY BUILT
ON THE STATE'S TWENTY FIFTEEN
CLIMATE CHANGE RESEARCH PROGRAM.
WE DEVELOPED A DRAFT BACK IN
NOVEMBER.
TOOK PUBLIC COMMENT AND
WORKSHOPS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
ADOPTED THE RESEARCH PROGRAM ARE
AT OUR JANUARY TWENTY NINTH
COUNCIL MEETING.
RELEASED A SOLICITATION IN
FEBRUARY RELIEF EVERY TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT AND THEN WILL HAVE
DEADLINES FOR A PROPOSAL ON
APRIL THIRTEENTH. AND THEN MAKE
AWARD RECOMMENDATIONS TO OUR
COUNCIL AGAIN THIS IS FOR THE
ELEVEN MILLION DOLLARS ON A JULY
THIRTY FIRST THAT RESEARCH
PROGRAM.
POINTED TO FOR PRIORITIES.
AND THE REALLY MENTION A FIFTH
PRIORITY THAT REALLY GETS AT THE
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ONE
SUPPORTING PROTECTING AFFORDABLE
COMMUNITIES FROM THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE A POINT THAT. I WILL GO
OUT
WITH TO RESEARCH GRANTS IN IN
THIS ROUND REALLY TYPES ONE
RESEARCH PROJECT GRANTS REALLY
EAT GEARED TOWARDS INDIVIDUAL
RESEARCHERS AT A. FOCUS ON
SPECIFIC TOPICS AT A SMALLER
SCALE HUNDRED THOUSAND TWO
MILLION DOLLAR RANGE AND IN A
SECOND CATEGORY OF AWARDS FOCUS
ON RESEARCH PARTNERSHIP GRANTS
IN THE RANGE OF ONE TO FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS APPROXIMATELY.
IN THIS IS REALLY LOOKING TO
FUND RESEARCH CONSORTIUM
PARTNERSHIP'S COLLABORATIVE'S.
TO GET MORE CROSS CUTTING
TOPICS BOTTOM.
AND RESEARCH ENDEAVORS AT NOW
TO JUST BRIEFLY HERE DESCRIBE
WITH THINKING BY WAY OF
GOVERNANCE AND AND PUBLIC
PROCESS FOR THE THIRTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL OF
COURSEWE GO THROUGH A PUBLIC
PROCESS TO FULLY DEVELOP. THAT
PROGRAM OF THE WITH THE ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE FORMED AN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE CONSISTING OF.
ACADEMIC. RESEARCHERS AND THOSE
WHO HAD EXPERTISE WITH REGARD TO
EACH OF THE PRIORITIES THAT I
MENTIONED A AS WELL AS
INTERAGENCY COMMITTEE.
CONSISTING OF OUR STATE.
STAFF
EXPERTS ACROSS THE VARIOUS TOPIC
AREAS AND WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION IN THEIR EPIC PROGRAM
THOSE AIR BEES RESEARCH DIVISION
AND THE SP ONE. RESEARCH EFFORTS
IN ORDER TO TO TO TO FORM THAT.
HAPPY ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND I
THINK YOU.
IF YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT CHAIRMAN
BLOOM IN THE OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS TO BE A BARNES I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT BANK WHICH
WE FINALLY CALL AYE BANK.
AND WE ARE HERE TO REQUEST A
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS.
FROM THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUN.
TO FINANCE.
PROP UP CLEAN ENERGY PROJECTS
UNDER AYE BANKS.
A CLEAN CENTER THAT STANDS FOR
OUR CALIFORNIA LENDING FOR
ENERGY AND ENVIRONMENTAL NEEDS
CENTER.
AT THAT FINANCING WOULD BE
PROVIDED TO US MUNICIPALITIES
AND PUBLIC UNIVERSITY SCHOOLS
AND HOSPITALS WE CALL MUCH.
MARKET.
THE AND THE EASE OF FINANCINGS
ARE.
.
UP PROVIDED ON A LOW COST BASIS
AS AN ADDED INCENTIVE TO
ENCOURAGE A THE FINANCING OF
THESE PROJECTS THAT HAVE BEEN
OUT DEFERRED FOR MANY YEARS.
THE CLEAN CENTER PROJECTS
INCLUDE GENERALLY ENERGY
EFFICIENCY RENEWABLE ENERGY.
ENERGY STORAGE WATER ALTERNATIVE
ENERGY TECHNOLOGIES ALTERNATIVE
FUEL. AND CLEAN TRANSPORTATION.
BOTTOM THE FOCUS SPECIFICALLY
BUT THIS TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
WILL BE ON.
MITIGATION OF GREENHOUSE GAS.
THAT EMISSIONS AND TO IMPROVE
CLIMATE RESILIENCY SO THAT'S WHY
WE CALLED THE PROGRAM AN
INTEGRATED PROGRAM TO DO BOTH OF
THESE THINGS IT'S AT ITS VERY
IMPORTANT. FOR THE SISTINE
ABILITY.
UP THAT THE PROGRAM AS WELL AS
THE SUSTAINABILITY OF THESE LIFE
CYCLE. UP PROJECTS.
WE. IN PROVIDING THE.
LOW COST FINANCING.
WE LOOK AT THE LOCATION WHERE
THE PROJECTS WILL BE.
BUILT.
AND WE LOOK AT THE LEVEL OF
EMISSIONS FROM THE A VIRUS
SCREEN.
AND TO THE EXTENT THERE'S MORE
POLLUTION IN THIS COMMUNITY WE
CAN PROVIDE ADDITIONAL SUBSIDIES
TO ENCOURAGE A.
THE PROJECTS BEING COMPLETED.
AND WITH THAT I.
WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE BEEN SO I I.
INADVERTENTLY FILL TO ALLUDE TO
ONE OTHER A PROPOSAL THAT IS A
NEW PROPOSAL OF RELATIVE TO
OTHER CAP AND TRADE PROPOSALS
YOU SEEN BEFORE AND THAT IS A
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
A WE ASKED TO FUND. ADDITIONAL
FIRE.
ENGINES OF FOR THE SUPPORT OF
THE MUTUAL AID SYSTEM OF
REPRESENTS HIM OH YES ARE IN THE
AUDIENCE IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS ON THAT.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS.
BUT I HAVE ONE THAT.
IT PSALM.
COMING FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
.
AND AN UNDERSTANDING LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. HOME WE KNOW THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE CALLING ON OUR
LOCAL CITIES AND DATA AND DO
CALLER LOCAL CITIES AND COUNTIES
TO IMPLEMENT A LOT OF OUR. A
CLIMATE CHANGE PROGRAMS AND A
FURTHER OUR GOALS.
BUT MANY OF THE CITIES DON'T
HAVE THE.
DEPTH OF KNOWLEDGE YOU'RE A A
IN HOUSE.
ABILITY TO IMPLEMENT THOSE
PROGRAMS THAT THERE IS THERE ANY
FUNDING. UP PROPOSED IN THE UC A
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM TO ADDRESS
THAT KIND OF ISSUE.
THAT IT ARE YOU A CLARIFICATION
I ARE YOU ALLUDING TO THE.
REQUIREMENTS OF SET OF.
AB SIX SEVENTEEN
OR.
GONNA REMOTE FOR THE SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENT INTERNALLY SIX OKAY.
NOT PARTICULARLY BUT I THINK
WHAT WE DO HAVE A AND.
RESIDENT FROM THE I THINK A
LOOTED IN THE FACT THAT A LOT OF
THESE PROGRAMS.
ARE GOING TO LOCAL AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT OF LOCAL AGENCIES
A TO TO IMPLEMENT.
.
MULTIPLE PROJECTS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. A I WOULD ALSO SAY THAT
AS PART OF OUR PROPOSAL WE ARE.
PROVIDING FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
TO NOT NECESSARILY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS BUT A LOCAL
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS.
TO.
.
AS PART OF.
THE PUBLIC PROCESS AND TO
PARTICIPATE IN A PUBLIC PROCESS
OF FOR A ACTIONS THAT TO AFFECT
THE.
OKAY. GETS SICK PLEASE AYE AYE
IT ALSO JUST WANT TO ADD THAT
THERE'S. NO ADDITIONAL FUNDING
BEING REQUESTED FOR THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE BUT I BANK
JUST.
AT AS HOW WE OPERATE PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ALONG THE
WAY. TO ADD THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT WE ARE WORKING
WITH TO DO A FINANCING SAID THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IS MORE IN
LINE WITH. HELPING THEM TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY NEED TO DO
THE FINANCING REMINDING THEM
ABOUT SEQUEL. AND AT REMINDING
THEM OF AYE THERE. AT
REQUIREMENTS THAT THEY MAY HAVE
BEEN HELPING THEM TO GET TO THE
RIGHT. A.
ADVISERS WE DON'T PROVIDE THE
ADVICE SPECIFICALLY BUT WE HELP
THEM THROUGH THE PROCESS AND
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND.
WE DO NOT THAT'S JUST
HOW WE OPERATE WE DON'T NEED
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR.
I CAN'T BELIEVE I'M SAYING THIS
OUT LOUD BUBBLY TONE HERE BUT
IT'S ENOUGH FUNDING FOR THAT SIR
THAT RECORD NOW.
YOU MAY BE THE FIRST THIS YEAR.
AND THE LAST.
NO BUT THE HAVE THANK YOU FOR
THAT AND THAT THIS IS JUST
SOMETHING I THINK WE MIGHT WANT
TO BE THINKING ABOUT.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD THROUGH THE.
THROUGH THE CYCLE MISTER MULLIN.
MISS SHARE I COULD JUST ADD UP
MY VOICE TO THAT SINCE WE'VE.
OPEN UP THE AB SIX ONE SEVEN. A
WINDOW HERE I WAS CONTACTED BY
THE BAY AREA AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT. NO WE PUT
SOME ADDITIONAL BURDENS ON THE
WORK OF THESE REGIONAL.
AND LOCAL ENTITIES.
THERE'S DISCUSSION OF THIRTEEN
MILLION IN THE FIRST YEAR
FOURTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION AN
ON GOING COSTS THAT ARE NOT
FUNDED.
I OUT OF THE EXPENDITURE PLANS
SO I THINK WE OUGHT TO JUST GIVE
SOME ADDITIONAL ATTENTION TO.
YOU KNOW THE REQUIREMENTS THAT
WE PUT IT UP ON. LOCAL ENTITIES
FROM THIS BUILDING TO MEET OUR
GOALS AND IT SHOULD BE REFLECTED
APPROPRIATELY IN THE AREA
EXPENDITURE PLAN SO I'D LOOK FOR
TO IT SOME ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
ON THAT TOPIC. THANK YOU AND I
THINK WE HAVE SOME COMMENTS FROM
THE ALEJO AFTER WHICH WILL HAVE.
PUBLIC.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AND JUST BEFORE I BRIEFLY GO
OVER OUR MAIN COMMENTS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS ON WHAT IS GOING
TO PROVIDE JUST A BIT MORE
CONTEXT ON FOR THE OVERALL
SPENDING PACKAGE I KNOW THE
FOCUS IS HERE IS PRIMARILY ON
KIND OF THAT DISCRETIONARY PEACE
AND SO. IT'S TO GIVE YOU A
LITTLE BETTER SINCE I DIDN'T
BELIEVE MY COLLEAGUE HANDED OUT
A COPY OF OUR.
BUDGET REPORT AYE IN THAT
REPORT ON PAGE ELEVEN WE HAVE A
TABLE THAT SUMMARIZES BOTH LAST
YEAR SPENDING PLAN AS WELL AS
THIS ONE ZERO ABLE TO COME TO
COMPARE HOW THE TWO. ARE ALIKE
AND DIFFERENT I ALSO INCLUDES
KIND OF THE CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATIONS WHICH ROLE ARE
STILL ON GOING AS WELL AS A
LAYING OUT SOME OF THE EXISTING
COMMITMENTS ABOUT A HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION THAT WERE MADE AND
PREVIOUS PIECES OF LEGISLATION
SO. OVERALL THE ENTIRE PACKAGE
IS ABOUT OUT TWO POINT EIGHT
BILLION SORT OF UNDER THE
ADMINISTRATION'S REVENUE
ASSUMPTIONS SO.
JUST ONE INTO A KIND OF.
SET THE STAGE THERE ARE MOVING
JUST DISCRETIONARY PIECE AND I
THINK OVERALL IT OUR VIEW IS
THAT THE. PLAN FINDS A LOT OF
THE.
THE SAME PROGRAMS THAT WERE
FUNDED AS PART OF LAST YEAR'S
PLANS WAS VERY SIMILAR IN A LOT
OF WAYS.
SOME OF THE KEY DIFFERENCES
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT.
A COUPLE OF OTHERS WE WANT TO
JUST HIGHLIGHT REAL QUICK OTHERS
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS LASTS FOR
FREIGHT AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE
INCENTIVES AND LAST YEAR'S
PROGRAM SO THAT'S ONE. AREA YOU
YOU MIGHT WANT TO COME TO TAKE A
LOOK OUT IN A. PROBE ABOUT KIND
OF THE RATIONALE FOR THAT.
.
THERE'S ALSO SOME PROGRAMS THAT
RECEIVE FUNDING LAST YEAR THAT
DON'T RECEIVE FUNDING IN THIS
YEAR'S PLAN INCLUDING SOME
CLIMATE ADAPTATION PROGRAMS.
WHICH MAY BE RECEIVING FUNDING
THROUGH SOME OTHER POTS BUT WHEN
A DEATH LIKE THAT AS WELL AS
SOME OF THE LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM WHICH
YOU.
HEARD ABOUT EARLIER TODAY.
I ALSO JUST WANT OTHER NOTABLE
FEATURE OF THIS PLAN AND YOU
ALSO HEARD ABOUT THAT IN EARLIER
ITEM. OF THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN.
MULTI YEAR FUNDING SO INSTEAD
OF JUST THE ONE YEAR FUNDING
WHICH HAS BEEN TYPICAL AS PART
OF THIS PROGRAM. ABOUT TWENTY
MILLION FOR THE CD R. P.
PROGRAM.
AND MULTI YEAR FUNDING SOULS A
COUPLE OTHER PROGRAMS THAT I UP
TO ABOUT TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION INCOME MULTI YEAR
FUNDING AND SO. I JUST LOOKING
AT THE OUT YEARS A OF SPENDING
IF YOU'RE ASSUME THAT OF THE
REVENUE ASSUMPTIONS THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS ASSUMES CONTINUE
GOING FORWARD IN THE OUT YEARS
OF ABOUT TWO POINT FOUR MILLION.
THE COMMITMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE SO FAR ALREADY AND IF THIS.
PROPOSALS ADOPTED WOULD TOTAL
ABOUT ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION ON
KIND OF AND.
ON ANNUAL BASIS AND SO EIGHT
ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION EXCUSE
ME.
AND YOU KNOW IF IF REVENUES ARE
ABOUT TWO POINT FOUR BILLION
THAT LEAVES ABOUT YOU KNOW SIX
HUNDRED MILLION OR SO AND OF ON
GOING FOR THESE OTHER TYPES OF
PROGRAMS THE LEGISLATURE HAS
BEEN FUN IN THE PAST SO THAT
JUST.
I THINK SOME IMPORTANT PEOPLE
MIND THROUGH THE LONG RUN WHAT
YOU'RE COMMITTING TO WONDER.
UNDER THIS PROPOSAL WHAT YOU
WOULD BE COMMITTING TO UNDER
THIS PROPOSAL.
SO OUR OUR GENERAL
RECOMMENDATIONS OUR FIRST JUST
TO ENSURE THAT THE ALLOCATIONS
ARE CONSISTENT WITH YOUR
PRIORITIES ARE NOT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS A VARIETY OF
PRIORITIES WHEN THINKING ABOUT
THE. FUNDING PLAN BOTH
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AS WELL
AS LOCAL AIR POLLUTANTS CLIMATE
ADAPTATION OTHER THINGS SO JUST.
I'M SURE THAT KIND OF THIS
PACKAGE KIND OF AND MEETS THOSE
PRIORITIES AND FITS.
WITH THOSE PRIORITIES.
IN THE BUDGET YEAR AS WELL AS
AS THE OUT YEAR WHICH I TALKED
ABOUT JUST A MINUTE AGO.
HOW ARE AND KIND OF IN ORDER TO
ACHIEVE THAT JUST BASED ON WHAT
THOSE PRIORITIES R. WE THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO FOR THE
LEGISLATURE THAT GOOD
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT THESE
PROGRAMS ARE ACCOMPLISHING AND
WHAT THE OUTCOMES ARE?
MISTER ONLY MENTIONED THEIR
RECENTLY RELEASED ANNUAL REPORT.
THAT TRIES ESTIMATES SOME OF
THE GHG OUTCOMES
I'LL ONE THING THAT WE HAVE A
NOTED JUST GIVEN SOME OF THE
INTEREST IN A LOT OF THESE
PROGRAMS.
THAT REPORT STILL DOESN'T
ESTIMATES THAT CO BENEFITS
THINGS LIKE A REDUCTIONS IN
LOCAL AIR POLLUTANTS
OTHER TYPES OF BENEFITS
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT CLIMATE
ADAPTATION OR WATER OR OTHER
THINGS LIKE THAT. I KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS INDICATED
THEY'RE CONTINUING TO COME TO
WORK ON THAT BUT THAT'S AN AREA
WHERE YOU MIGHT WANNA ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION TO.
COMMENT ON ITS PROGRESS
INVESTMENT IN THOSE THINGS
ECONOMIC BETTER SENSE OF WHAT.
THESE PROGRAMS ARE
ACCOMPLISHING.
AND THEN FINALLY.
WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER ITS OPTIONS FOR
ENSURING FUND'S SOLVENCY SO SOME
OF THE NUMBERS HERE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ASSUMING TWO
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS IN
REVENUE IN THE CURRENT YEAR. TWO
POINT FOUR BILLION IN THE BUDGET
YEAR.
AND UNDER THE SPENDING PLAN IT
WOULD SPEND.
ALMOST ALL OF THE AVAILABLE
RESOURCES IF THAT'S THE REVENUE
THAT COMES AND LEAVING ARE A
VERY VERY SMALL FUND BALANCE.
AND SO THE LEGISLATURE GIVEN THE
VOLATILITY IN REVENUE IN THE
PAST WE THINK.
IS REVENUE ESTIMATES ARE
REASONABLE AND ACTUALLY WE THINK
REVENUE IS LIKELY TO BE A LITTLE
BIT HIGHER THAN THIS BUT GIVEN
THE VOLATILITY THERE'S QUITE A
BIT OF.
THERE'S STILL SOME UNCERTAINTY
AROUND REVENUE AND SOME CHANCE
THAT REVENUE COULD COME IN A
LITTLE BIT LOWER THAN.
EXPECTED SO THINK ABOUT HOW TO
DEAL WITH THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WE THINK IT'S
BEFORE TO A REASONABLE PROPOSAL
FOR MOST OF THE PROGRAMS OF
REVENUE COMES IN LOWER THERE
WOULD BE A OF PROPORTIONAL
REDUCTION AND SOME OF THE
ALLOCATIONS.
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE.
WITH A COUPLE OF EXCEPTIONS.
PROGRAMS OPERATED THROUGH CAL
FIRE THE HEALTHY FOREST PROGRAM
AS WELL AS THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD PROGRAMS WOULD BE MADE
WHOLE WOULD BE KEPT HOLE IN THE
OTHER PROGRAMS WOULD BE REDUCED
PROPORTIONATELY SO. AGAIN I
THINK THAT'S JUST AN AREA WE
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT FOR YOU
THAT'S A FEAT THAT'S A. AN
ASPECT OF THIS PLAN THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WILL WANT TO
CONSIDER. WHETHER OR NOT NIKADA
PRIORITIZING THOSE PROGRAMS IN
AND IN IN A SCENARIO WHERE
REVENUE COMES IN LOWER IS
CONSISTENT WITH HOW THE
LEGISLATURE PRIORITIZES THOSE
PROGRAMS RELATED TO THE OTHER
ONES THAT WERE NOT A PART OF
THIS PACKAGE.
SO WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU COULD.
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE I
UNDERSTAND THAT SOME OF YOU
THINK THAT THE.
ADMINISTRATIONS REVENUE.
PROJECTIONS ARE REASONABLE EVEN
THOUGH THE.
MOST RECENT AUCTIONS HAVE BEEN A
LITTLE MORE A LITTLE ROSIER
THAN.
THAN ORIGINALLY PROJECTED AND
THAT'S BECAUSE OF SOME
VOLATILITY. AND THE.
OUT YEARS THAT'S RIGHT YEAH I
MEAN WE WE THINK THEY'RE KIND OF
REASONABLE GIVEN THE UNCERTAINTY
AROUND WHAT REVENUES CAN BE AND
I THINK OUR BEST ESTIMATE IS
THAT THEY WROTE THERE ARE LIKELY
TO BE ALL OF THE HIGHER A FEW
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS HIGHER
THAN WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION. IS
PROPOSING BUT AGAIN YET GIVEN
THAT VOLATILITY WOULD YOU THINK
THEY'RE KIND OF WITHIN A
REASONABLE RANGE.
IN THE A QUESTIONS.
CSUS IF THERE'S ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT.
AND.
APPARENTLY THERE IS.
FOLKS WERE.
WE'RE WE'RE RUNNING. LATE INTO
THE DAY AND.
WE HAVE LOTS OF TIME TO
CONSIDER ALL OF YOUR ISSUES SO.
I WANT TO HEAR FROM ALL OF YOU
BUT KEEP IT AS CONCISE AS
POSSIBLE A POSSIBLE PLEASE.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS MELISSA
ROMERO WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUP CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE
AND HERE TO TALK ABOUT CAL
RECYCLES FUNDING UNDER THIS
PROGRAM. DESPITE PROVEN SUCCESS
AND AND SUSTAIN DEMANDS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BUDGET HAS
PROPOSED TO CUT POWER CYCLES
FUNDING AND HALF
AT A TIME WHERE WE ACTUALLY NEED
TO INCREASE THE SPENDING. THE
PROJECTS UNDER THIS PROGRAM
PROVIDE THE CRITICAL PUBLIC AND
INVESTMENT THAT CITIES NEED TO
MEET THEIR ORGANIC WASTE
RECYCLING AND EDIBLE FOOD WASTE
PREVENTION AND RESCUE
REQUIREMENTS SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE. MOREOVER THE COLLAPSE OF
THE CHINESE RECYCLING MARKETS.
ARE AFFECTING EVERY CITY AND
COUNTY IN THE STATE.
AND THIS HAS SHOWN THE
IMPORTANCE OF CREATING
SUSTAINABLE MARKETS.
AT DOMESTIC MARKETS
AND WE BELIEVE IT'S CLEAR THAT
THE FUNDING FOR CAL RECYCLES
PROGRAMS IS A REALLY GREAT
INVESTMENT BUT WITH THEY'VE ALSO
PROVEN TO BE AMONG THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE. AND.
OVERSUBSCRIBED OF ANY
DEPARTMENT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE.
AND MISTER CHAIRMAN WHEN WE
COME BACK WE'LL SEE THE
RECORDING.
I DID WANT TO JUST MENTION I'M
HERE ON THE MONEY WASN'T OF THAT
I'M I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF A.
TREE DAVIS TODAY.
IN SUPPORT OF A LARGE COALITION
ASK.
WHICH WE DISTRIBUTED THE THE
OFFICIAL LETTER TO TO ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
FOR THE FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
NATURAL RESOURCE INVESTMENTS.
WHICH AS STAFF POINTS OUT IN IN
THE COMMENTS.
WAS LEFT OUT OF THE
MINISTRATION PROPOSAL.
AND WE DO AGREE THAT THAT IT
DOES MERIT.
INCLUSION IN THE FINAL PACKAGE
THAT COMES TOGETHER.
AND SPECIFICALLY UM'S CITY.
OR TREE DAVIS.
WORKS A LOT WITH YOUR BEFORE
SHE PROGRAM.
AND ALTHOUGH OUR NAME SAYS THAT.
TREE DAVIS WE DON'T JUST DO WORK
IN THE CITY OF DAVIS WE DO WORK
IN THE ENTIRE EAGLE COUNTY.
INCLUDING A LOT OF THE TO*
COMMUNITIES AND WHAT SACRAMENTO
AND WOODLAND IN OTHER PARTS OF
THE COUNTY.
WHERE THIS PROGRAM HAS BEEN
ESPECIALLY BENEFICIAL AND
RELEASED ONE HIGHLIGHT THAT THIS
PROGRAM?
IT'S CRITICAL THAT NOT TO THE
GROUPS THEMSELVES BUT TO THE
COMMUNITIES IN WHICH WERE DOING
THE WORK.
SO WHAT URGE CONSIDERATION OF
THE OF THE REQUEST AND I THINK
YOU'VE WRITTEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON PAUL MASON FOR
PACIFIC FOREST TRUST WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE HUNDRED
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
HEALTHY FORESTS AND RELATED
ACTIVITIES A CLEARLY.
COMMISSIONS ARE FOREST HAVE GONE
RIGHT OVER THE TOP AND NOT SEE
ENORMOUS GREENHOUSE GAS IMPACTS
AND OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS
FROM THAT. WE WOULD ALSO CALL
OUT THOSE THAT THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL REDUCES A LOT OF THE
OTHER IMPORTANT NATURAL WORKING
LAND INVESTMENTS TWO ZERO AND
LOOKS TO THE PARK BOND AS BACK
FEELINGS OF THOSE ACTIVITIES.
WHAT IS IMPORTANT TO MAINTAIN
THOSE INVESTMENTS IN THE GDR
AFTER POSE LOW OVER SUPPORT OF
OF THE ASSEMBLY THAT THE ASK
FROM A DOZEN ASSEMBLY MEMBERS?
OUTLINING A FORERUNNER BILLION
DOLLAR PACKAGE
SO I URGE YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
THAT THANK YOU MUCH.
KAREN BURNES AND ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES THE CYCLE BE VERY
BRIEF BECAUSE I BELIEVE I
KNOCKED OVER A FEW FIRE CHIEFS
TO JUMP BRUNO HIDES APOLOGIZED
FOR THAT.
WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT OR A
NUMBER OF PROGRAMS WITHIN THE
OVERALL ALLOCATION FIRST AND
FOREMOST THE FOREST HEALTH AND
RESILIENCY FUNDS OF COURSE THIS
IS VERY. IMPORTANT TO IMPROVING
THE HEALTH OF OUR FORESTS INTO
AVOIDING SOME OF THE
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE VINCE THAT
WE'VE EXPERIENCED THIS YEAR SOME
VERY MUCH APPRECIATIVE FOR THAT.
IN ADDITION WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
THE TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM BUT WOULD
URGE.
AN ADDITIONAL ALLOCATION TO
THIS PROGRAM AS YOU'VE HEARD
THERE'S A TREMENDOUS NEED AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL THIS I FUND IS.
OVER EXPENDED AND WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE BROADENING THAT
PROGRAM ALSO TO REACH THE TOP
TWENTY FIVE A DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WITH IN CALIFORNIA
AND THEN FINALLY WOULD CONCUR
WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE THAT
WE ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
APPROPRIATE ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO
THE WASTE DIVERSION SECTOR. AS
THERE IS.
GREAT NEED TO DEVELOP THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NECESSARY TO
DIVERT THE ORGANICS OUT OF OUR
LANDFILLS THE COSTS WERE LOW
CLIMATE POLLUTANTS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON AERIAL HIM ON THE
HAVE TO TREAT PEOPLE AND SHE
PEOPLE IS A LOS ANGELES BASED
NONPROFIT WITH OVER FOUR DECADES
OF EXPERIENCE ADVANCING.
EXPANSION OF URBAN FOREST
IMPROVE SOIL HEALTH AND CLEAN
LOCAL WATER THROUGH ENGAGEMENT
COMMUNITIES AND WITH
POLICYMAKERS.
CITIES AND COMMUNITIES IN LOS
ANGELES RELY ON NATURAL
RESOURCES FROM THE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUND IMPLEMENT
PROJECTS THE BILL THE CLIMATE
RESILIENT REGION.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT ALLOCATION
OF FOUR HUNDRED MILLION FROM THE
FUND FOR NATURAL RESOURCES
PROGRAMS AND URGE MEMBERS IN THE
ROOM TO ADOPT THIS PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
DANIELLE LYNCH REPRESENTING A A
FEW ORGANIZATIONS TODAY I'M
FIRST I'D LIKE TO ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES NEIGHBORHOOD
LAND TRUST. URGE THAT FUNDING DO
DOES BE DEDICATED TO URBAN
GREENING WHICH RIGHT NOW IS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE PROPOSED BUDGET
FOR GDR AFTER.
OF THIS IS A CRITICAL PROGRAM
AND WE'VE BEEN PROUD RECIPIENTS
OF THIS PROGRAM IN THE PAST
WHICH HAS ALLOWED US TO. BE ABLE
TO CREATE.
TAILORED PARKS FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA I'M SECOND ON BEHALF
OF COMMUNITY NATURE CONNECTION
AND THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF LOCAL CONSERVATION CORES. WE
WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT THE FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR G. EUROPE
FAST TO ENSURE THAT WE DO GET
CRITICAL FUNDING FOR VARIOUS
NATURAL RESOURCES. PROJECTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE REALLY LOOK AT
THE BIG PICTURE AND ALL THE
DIVERSITY OF.
POSSIBLE PROGRAMS AND
INVESTMENTS THAT TOUCH PEOPLE'S
LIVES EVERY DAY AND THEN THIRD
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION COURSE WOULD LIKE
TO ALIGN OURSELVES WITH THE
COMMENTS MADE BY MISTER MARROW
FROM CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE.
OUR LA A CONSERVATION CORPS HAS
RECEIVED A FOOD WASTE RESCUE
GRANT.
ART RECENTLY WHICH IS GOING TO
ALLOW YOUTH IN THAT AREA TO BE
ABLE TO RESCUE FOOD THAT WOULD
EITHER GO OTHERWISE GO TO THE
LANDFILL AND PROVIDE IT TO THEIR
NEIGHBORS THAT ARE IN NEED SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO. HOPEFULLY BEING
ABLE TO EXPAND THIS PROGRAM.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON MY NAME IS
ERIC NICKEL ON THE FIRE CHIEF
FOR THE CITY OF PALO ALTO AND
STANFORD UNIVERSITY I'M HERE
TODAY REPRESENTING. A DISASTER
READINESS FOR SAFER COMMUNITIES
WHICH IS MADE UP OF A VERY BROAD
COALITION OF FIRE AGENCIES
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS.
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA METRO
CHIEFS FIRE DISTRICTS SUBSTATION
AND THE LEAGUE OF CITIES FIRE
CHIEFS DEPARTMENT.
I'M HERE FIRST TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONTINUED LEADERSHIP AND
SUPPORT ARE CERTAINLY THAT THE
FUNDING THAT WAS PROVIDED LAST
BUDGET YEAR THE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S ALLOCATIONS IN HIS
PROPOSED BUDGET. FOR THE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY MILLION FOR THE
HEALTHY FOREST INITIATIVE AND
WORKING WITH OUR PARTNERS A
CALIFORNIA. AND WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THAT THAT THE TWENTY
FIVE MILLION.
ALLOCATED TO CAL O. YES OF FOR
REPLACEMENT OF THEIR FLEET.
SO SECRET THIS LAST YEAR
WE'VE REALLY GOTTEN BEAT UP IN
THE STATE CALIFORNIA ARE
BUSINESSES RADICALLY CHANGING I
MEAN IT IS YEAR ROUND DISASTER
SEASON IN FACT AT A. LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE PRE DEPLOYED ON
THE FRONT LINES IN SANTA BARBARA
AND VENTURA COUNTIES
IN ADVANCE OF THIS ATMOSPHERIC
RIVER EVENT THAT WILL STRIKE. OF
THE THOMAS FIRE BURNED AREAS
AGAIN WILL LIKELY RESULT IN
ANOTHER DEBRIS AND MUD FLOW.
WE'VE BEEN PRE DEPLOYING
RESOURCES THROUGH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
FUNDING AND WE ARE ASKING THE
GOVERNOR THIS YEARTO
APPROPRIATE ADDITIONAL FUNDS
EIGHTY SEVEN MILLION.
TO SUPPORT ON GOING PRE
DEPLOYMENT ACTIVITIES IN THESE
EVENTS IT'S NO SECRET THAT THE
AGENCIES THAT PRE DEPLOYED IN
ADVANCE OF THE THOMAS FIRE IN
DECEMBER. HAD A MUCH DIFFERENT
OUTCOME.
THEN THE AGENCIES THAT WERE
UNABLE TO PRE DEPLOY IN CINEMA
COUNTY WITH WITHOUT THE TUBS
FIRE IN OCTOBER NIGHT AND DAY
DIFFERENCE WERE ALSO ASKING FOR
AN ADDITIONAL THIRTEEN MILLION.
TO BE ALLOCATED TO IMPROVE AND
ENHANCE THE STATE'S MUTUAL AID
SYSTEM THE MUTUAL AID SYSTEM IS
THE MODEL THE WORLD BUT IT'S.
HOLD ITS TIRED IT NEEDS SOME
UPDATING
SO WE WOULD COLLECTIVELY ASK OFF
THAT TOTAL IS IS A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS DEREK DOLPHY ON BEHALF
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES AS
STATE WORKS TO IMPLEMENT ITS IN
STORE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
GOALS LOCAL AGENCIES ARE
CRITICAL AND WILLING PARTNERS IN
THIS EFFORT. WE APPRECIATE MUCH
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED A
GIRAFFE ALLOCATIONS BUT REQUEST
THE EXPANSION OF THE FOLLOWING
PROJECTS
FIRST WE LIKE TO ECHO SEE SEX
COMMENTS REQUEST A HUNDRED
MILLION FOR THE TRANSFORMATIVE
CLIMATE COMMUNITIES PROGRAM.
WHICH PROVIDES MULTI BENEFIT
PROGRAMS FOR THE MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
SECOND WE'D LIKE TO ALSO REQUEST
HUNDRED MILLION FOR WASTE
DIVERSION AS THE STATE WORKS TO
IMPLEMENT THE S. B. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE ORGANIC WASTE
DIVERSION TARGETS.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS NEED TO
SUPPORT THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO
PROCESS THESE MATERIALS AND
THIRD WOULD LIKE TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY CHIEF ERICH
NICKEL WHO IS THE PRESIDENT
BELIEVES OF FIRE CHIEFS
DEPARTMENT. WITH A REQUEST FOR A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR FIRE
PREVENTION THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU CHEN MEMBERS NIKITA
CREDIT WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL WE TO
SUPPORT ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
THAT CRITICAL NATURAL RESOURCES
PROGRAMS PARTICULARLY FOR
PROJECTS THAT PROVIDE IMPORTANT
CO BENEFITS AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. WE'D LIKE TO SEE
FUNDING RESTORED TO THE LOW
INCOME WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM IS
ONE OF THE ONLY STATEWIDE
PROGRAMS THAT IS DESIGNED TO
MAXIMIZE CHICHI REDUCTIONS IN
BUILDINGS WHILE ADDRESSING SOME
OF THOSE CRITICAL BARRIERS TO
CLEAN ENERGY ACCESS FOR LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES. ADDITIONALLY
WOULD LIKE TO SEE FUNDING FOR S.
B. TEN THIRTEEN BY SENATOR LARA
WHICH AMONG OTHER THINGS WILL
INCENTIVIZE EARLY ADOPTION OF
CLIMATE FRIENDLY COOLING SYSTEMS
TO REPLACE THE USE OF HSCS. IT
JUST THESE ARE THE FASTEST
GROWING SOURCE OF GIGI IS IN
CALIFORNIA AND AROUND THE WORLD
AND CAN BE THOUSANDS OF TIMES
MORE POTENT THAN CO TWO AND
THEIR HEAT TRAPPING AND CLIMATE
WARMING. AND ABILITIES FINALLY
WE'D LIKE TO SEE SOME FUNDING
FOR S. B. FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR STERN TO HELP
INCENTIVIZE MARKET
TRANSFORMATION FOR A LOW IN ZERO
EMISSIONS BUILDING TECHNOLOGY
IS.
BUILDING THE BUILDING SECTOR IS
ONE OF THE PIECES OF THE CLIMATE
PUZZLE THAT LACKS THE CURRENT
PRETTY LIKE THE COMPREHENSIVE
STRATEGY. AND WE'D LIKE TO SEE
IS AN ZERO EMISSION I'M BUILDING
TECHNOLOGY IS IN PLACE TO HELP
JUMP START THE MARKET THANK YOU.
STILL NO GOOD AFTERNOON A HAVE
TO COME US MAKE US DEFAULT COPY
OFF WITHOUT THAT SIMMERED IN A
COUNTY BOARD SUPERVISORS. ALSO
LIKE TO URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THE HER MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
TRANSFORMATIVE CLINIC
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM. AND
MAINTAIN THAT THE PROGRAM HAS
ITS THAT BEEN STRUCTURED. ON A
DIFFERENT.
TOPIC UP YOU HAVE TO THE CENTER
FOR TRANSPORTATION ENVIRONMENTS.
THERE BENEATH Y. NONPROFIT THAT
DOES FOR COMMERCIALIZATION FOR
HEAVY DUTYAND MEDIUM DUTY.
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES.
.
SUPPORT AND AND AN INCREASE IS
POSSIBLE THE FUNDING FOR A LOW
CARBON TRANSLATION PROGRAM A
CARP NOTIFIED AS MUCH MONEY AS
POSSIBLE FOR THE H. IT REBATE
PROGRAM WHICH IS GOING TO
CRITICAL FOR. TRANSIT OPERATORS
TO TRANSITION IS YOUR MISSION
BUT ALSO CONSIDER FUNDING
PROGRAM FOR THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
YOU'VE HEARD EARLIER IF THE
NEED FOR INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THAT
MEDIUM HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES.
THERE'S NEVER STRUCTURES NOT
JUST LIMITED TO THE FEELINGS
SYSTEMS BUT IT'S ALSO FOR THE
MAINTENANCE FACILITIES UPGRADES
AS WELL AS WORKFORCE TRAINING SO
HURT YOUR SUPPORT FOR THAT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS BILL MCGOVERN WITH THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR ALSO
SPEAKING ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE EQUITY
COALITION WHICH SEEKS TO CHANNEL
CLIMATE INVESTMENTS INTO OUR.
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE HISTORICALLY FACED BOTH
DISINVESTMENT AND A
DISPROPORTIONATE BURDEN OF
POLLUTION. AYE YOU HAVE OUR OUR
LETTER WITH THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS.
OUT WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE TRANSPORTATION
EQUITY PROJECTS THAT ARE
BRINGING CLEAN MOBILITY TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
UNFORTUNATELY THE GOVERNOR'S
COMMITMENT ON LIGHT DUTIES US IS
NOT MATCHED ON THE HEAVY DUTY
SIDE. AS YOU'VE HEARD FROM BOTH
ALEJO AND YOUR OWN STAFF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WOULD
ACTUALLY CUT THE HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLE FUNDING IN HALF.
FROM THE CURRENT YEAR WHICH
WOULD LEAVE NO MONEY FOR PORT
AND FREIGHT EQUIPMENT.
SO WE ARE ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR THAT PROGRAM TO
REDUCE THE DIESEL EXHAUST. THAT
IS CHOKING OUR COMMUNITIES
WE ALSO AGREE WITH THOSE WHO
HAVE SPOKEN IN FAVOR OF THE LOW
INCOME WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM.
WHICH ALSO BY THE WAY INCLUDES
ROOFTOP SOLAR.
FOR LOW INCOME PEOPLE.
THIS PROGRAM REDUCES ENERGY
BILLS ANTS EMISSIONS AND ALSO
CREATES JOB OPPORTUNITIES.
WE ALSO A DISAGREE WITH THIS
HEARING OUT OF THE FUNDING FOR
URBAN FORESTRY IN URBAN
GREENING.
WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT THOSE
NEEDS ARE FILLED BY PROP SIXTY
EIGHT.
ARE THESE ARE STREET LEVEL
PROGRAMS
THAT WILL COMPLEMENT THE PROP
SIXTY EIGHT PROGRAMS AND DESERVE
TO BE FUNDED.
AND FINALLY WE AGREE WITH OTHERS
WHO HAVE CALLED FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION OLLARS FOR
TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES A VERY INNOVATIVE
PROGRAM THAT SEEKS TO INTEGRATE
VARIOUS CLIMB INVESTMENTS TO
TRANSFORM NEIGHBORHOODS THANK
YOU.
GOT IT YOU'VE GOT NEW NOT
TERRIBLY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS RYAN KENNY
WITH CLEAN ENERGY WE'RE NATION'S
LARGEST PROVIDER OF RENEWABLE
NASA GAS TRANSPORTATION FUEL.
AYE WE DO.
BELIEVE THAT THERE SHOULD BE
MORE MONEY ADDED TO THE LOW
CARBON TRANSPORTATION.
ITEM WITH WITH THAT THE GGF
PLAN. OUT WE DO BELIEVE THAT
IT'S SO FAR IS UNBALANCED
AND THAT A SHORT TERM AND LONG
TERM STRATEGY SHOULD BE
ESTABLISHED. A LOT OF MONEY
RIGHT NOW IS GOING TOWARD SAYS
REMISSION VEHICLES MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY.
AND THAT IS GONNA TAKE UP TO. A
LONG TIME AT THE TEN YEARS
POSSIBLY OR MORE TO REALLY GET
THE INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE RANGE
AND.
THE TECHNOLOGY UP TO SPEED AYE
IF THE LEGISLATURE WANTS TO LOOK
AT AN URGENT REDUCTION AND COST
EFFECTIVE REDUCTION FOR
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
KNOCKS. OUT WE DO BELIEVE THAT
LOW KNOCKS VEHICLES WITH
RENEWABLE FUEL.
WOULD BE THE WAY TO GO.
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES CAN COST
FIVE TIMES MORE THAN AID LOW
KNOCKS OUT OF THE TRUCK.
MEDIAN DETER HEAVY DUTY SO WE
DO URGE INCREASE IN A TOLL
FUNDING FOR LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BRISTOL IN OF
OUR SOME PATH URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA HERE TO REQUEST
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE
CHANCE FORM OF CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM SIMILAR TO
SEE SACRAMENTO THE. A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TOTAL THIS IS A
PROGRAM THAT GOES DIRECTLY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ONLY PROGRAM
TARGETED TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
AT THERE'S TWENTY FIVE MILLION
ARE RECOMMENDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET LAST YEAR
THERE WAS A HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION SO WE WOULD JUST ASK FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO RIDE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT ADDITIONAL
NEED.
A EVEN OR DOES NOT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IS IMPORTANT TO FUND
THESE PROJECTS ADDITIONAL ALLY
MYSELF WITH THE COMMENTS FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR ORGANICS.
APPEAR UNDER SOME PRETTY UP
STRICT DEADLINES UP FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TWENTY TWENTY BEING
WANT THE FIRST THE DEADLINES
AND.
AND SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE AND
WE JUST NEED MORE INFRASTRUCTURE
TO MEET THAT DEMAND YOU WANNA
HELP LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WE NEED
THE INFRASTRUCTURE SO DO YOU CAN
MEET THOSE.
HIGH GOALS THAT SAY HAS FOR US
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS CHUCK MOSTLY
CALIFORNIA RELIEF WE ARE MEMBER
OF THE SUSTAINABLE COMMITTEES
FOR ALL COALITION AND WE HEAR
MORE ABOUT THAT PLATFORM FROM A
MISTER START LATER. BUT I WANT
TO FOCUS FOR A MINUTE OR SO ON
THE.
FOREIGN TO MILLION DOLLAR
REQUEST FOR NATURAL RESOURCES
AGAIN HAS BEEN ALREADY
REFERENCED HERE. I WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF HEALTHY FORCES IS
ZERO IT OUT FOR THE SECOND SICK
CONSECUTIVE YEAR IN THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL. AYE
LAST YEAR THROUGH THE LEADERSHIP
OF THE CHAIR AND THE US SPEAKER
AND AND ASSEMBLY.
WE WERE ABLE TO GET SOME MUCH
NEEDED INVESTMENTS IN NATURAL
RESOURCES OUR LOOKING FOR THAT
LEADERSHIP AGAIN THIS YEAR.
HAS ALREADY BEEN MENTIONED.
THIRTEEN MEMBERS OF THE STATE
ASSEMBLY HAVE SIGNED ON TO A
LETTER SEEKING FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. FOR NATURAL
RESOURCES INVESTMENTS I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THESE ARE NATURALLY FORCE
RESOURCES INVESTMENTS ACROSS THE
BOARD OF THIS BECAUSE OF
EVERYTHING THAT WAS ON. BEEN
SUPPORT SO FAR IN THE CAPITAL
EXPENDITURE PLAN RANGING FROM
URBAN FORCING EVERY GREENING
DOWN TO WETLANDS TO ALL OF THE
NEW ADAPTATION PROGRAMS THAT
WERE ADDED INCLUDING THE ONES
FOR THE COMMISSION AND THE SF
BAY DEVELOPMENT. COMMISSION AS
WELL SO I URGE YOUR SUPPORT AND
LEADERSHIP ON THIS AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME.
AFTERNOON CHEERING MEMBERS TOM
ALISON WITH THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT.
I. WE'RE HERE TO AYE.
EXPRESSED CONCERNS ABOUT EIGHTY
SIX SEVENTEEN IN THE LACK THERE
FOR A FUNDING IT YOU KNOW FOR
THAT PROGRAM.
LAST YEAR AT HISTORIC DOT
PASSAGE OF THE CABIN TRADE
EXTENSION.
I AB SIX SEVENTEEN.
MAY PROMISE. ARE PROMISES TO
ADDRESS THE LOCALIZED AIR
POLLUTION IN OVER BURDEN
COMMUNITIES IT'S THE BIGGEST
CHANGE IN FEDERAL OR STATE AIR
QUALITY LAW OF THE LAST THIRTY
FIVE YEARS.
NOW THOSE PROMISES.
I HAVE HUGE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
EQUITY.
POTENTIAL BENEFITS.
ARM IN ITS LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS
WERE TO HURT WITH IMPLEMENTING
THE LARGE MAJORITY OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION WORK OF EIGHTY
SIX SEVENTEEN.
AND YOU HEARD ABOUT.
SOME WONDERFUL PROGRAMS PROPOSED
FOR FUNDING IN THIS BUDGET I BY
THE ADMINISTRATION WITH CICI ARE
RALPH WHAT'S OF GREAT THINGS
YOU'VE HEARD REQUEST FOR
ADDITIONAL THINGS TO BE FUNDED.
ONE THING THAT YOU HAVEN'T
HEARD.
IS THAT THERE IS ZERO DOLLARS
PROPOSED IN FUNDING FOR LOCAL
AIR DISTRICTS TO IMPLEMENT AB
SIX SEVENTEEN.
PLEASE HELP US KEEP OUR PROMISE
TO THESE COMMUNITIES AND DO THIS
WORK WE'VE BEGUN THIS WORK IN
THE BAY AREA WE HIRED STAFF.
WERE HAVING NIGHT MEETINGS IN
OUR COMMUNITY IS.
WERE COORDINATING WITH PAYER THE
WEST COMMUNITY GROUPS.
OUT WERE HOPING THAT DONE THE
LEGISLATURE.
DELIVERS ON THAT PROMISE THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JEAN HURST HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
OF THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ASSOCIATIONS REQUESTS FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IN THAT.
TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM.
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE SENIOR
CRUZ COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
I THAT I COUNTY IS VERY
INTERESTED IN SEEING THE WHAT'S
MY PRODUCTION PROGRAM RECEIVE
SOME FUNDING. OF THAT.
THAT PROGRAM WAS I'M COULD OF
MONEY CAN FLOW THAT DIRECTION
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE OF
WELCOMING UNDER WITHOUT OF MY
CALIFORNIA ALSO SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF.
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE WE ALSO
WANT TO ALIGN OURSELVES.
WITH THE COMMENTS FROM OUR
COLLEAGUE AT RELIEF.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE FOUR
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS
INVESTMENTS INTO NATURAL
RESOURCES WHICH IS EXTREMELY
CRITICAL FOR OUR ACHIEVING OUR
CLIMATES GOAL STATE CLIMB ITS
GOALS.
WE BELIEVE THAT INVESTMENTS IN
THE IN THESE PROGRAMS.
EVERYTHING FROM WETLANDS TO
URBAN FORESTRY TO.
IRVING GREENING HELP.
COMMUNITIES MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAVE.
ACCESSIBLE GREEN SPACE.
BUT ALSO ADDITIONAL.
YOU KNOW
ACCESS TO CLEAN AIR THANK YOU.
KILLING ON ASK BOBBY HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL FOR LOW
CARBON TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
PROVIDED FOR THAT. WE DO ONE
ECHO.
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT
YOU'VE HEARD BASED ON OUR
ANALYSIS THAT WE DON'T THINK
THAT THINK WE THINK THE NUMBERS
NEED TO BE ENHANCED.
THEY DON'T QUITE GET US TO THE
TARGETS THAT WERE WORKING FOR.
ESPECIALLY THE POPPY LARGEST.
DELTA IS IN THE MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY SECTOR BUT ALSO IN
THE LIGHT DUTY AND THE EQUITY
PROGRAMS AND ENCOURAGE YOU TO
LOOK AT THOSE NUMBERS AGAIN. AND
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BIOMASS ENERGY ALLIANCE WE
WANTED TO SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL TO FUND CONTINUE
FUNDING THE HEALTHY FORESTS
INITIATIVE.
WE THINK THAT THOSE ARE GETTING
AT SOME UP PROJECTS THAT
PREVIOUSLY WERE ECONOMICALLY
CHALLENGED NOW YOU CAN GET IN
THERE. UMMC DO FORCE CLEAN UP
EFFORTS AND AND MAKE SURE THAT
IN SOME OF THE CASES MAKE SURE
THAT THAT MATERIALS ACTUALLY
GETTING OUT THE FORCE INTO
BIOMASS FACILITIES.
AND GETTING A BENEFICIAL USE
OUT OF THAT WASTE PRODUCT THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND STAFF RICO MUSTARD
AND AUTO WITH OF TRUST FOR
PUBLIC LAND.
WE ARE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE
FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS OR FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR ASK.
BEING CIRCULATED IN THE
ASSEMBLY. I DID WANT TO MAKE A
COUPLE OF OTHER POINTS.
LAST WEEK WE LEARNED OUR AND
SENATE SUBCOMMITTEE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION BUDGETED PROP
FIVE.
ARE BECAUSE OF THE SENSE OF
URGENCY TO INVEST IN THESE
LANDSCAPES
I'M I COULD NOT AGREE MORE WE DO
HAVE A HUGE SENSE OF URGENCY OUR
FORESTS ARE OVERGROWN. OUR
CITIES ARE GREEN ENOUGH THEY'RE
GOING TO BE PRONE TO
CATASTROPHIC FLOODS
OUR AND HEAT WAVES.
WE ARE A HUMAN CATASTROPHE
WAITING TO HAPPEN.
R. C. LEVELS ARE RISING.
TO ME THAT SUGGESTS
THAT PROP.
SIXTY EIGHT IS ADDITIVE.
WE NEED TO KEEP THESE JGR OF
PROGRAMS THAT ARE CLIMATE
FOCUSED
A HALF OF WHAT'S BUDGETED IN FOR
PROMPT S. B. FIVE. IS A FOUR
HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
A LOCAL PARK PROGRAM THAT IS FOR
TO CREATE PARKS AND PARK POOR
LOW INCOME. A AREAS THAT IS NOT
THE URBAN GREENING PROGRAM WHICH
IS CLIMATE FOCUSED ON ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION AND MULTI BENEFIT
GREEN INFRASTRUCTURE. THE LAST
POINT I'LL MAKE IS.
PER THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN A ARE
BI ANNUAL REPORT I THINK YOU
WILL NOTE THAT.
NATURAL RESOURCE INVESTMENTS
ARE AMONG IF NOT THE BIGGEST
BANG FOR THE BUCK IN TERMS OF.
OUR DOLLARS INVESTED AND.
CARPET TONS OF CARBON REDUCED.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN BIRTH
NINE MILLION OF US BECAUSE I'M
HERE BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA BAR
METASTASES ALLIANCE AROUND AN
ALLIANCE BASED OF TANK COMMUNITY
BASED. ORGANIZATIONS AND
SPECIFICALLY ON ALLY MY COMMENTS
TO MY COLLEAGUE BILL MY GAFFER
IN THE COMMENTS AYE HE PROCEEDED
BUT ALSO ONE THAT SPECIFICALLY
ON WITH THE COMMENTS ON AB WAS
SIX ONE SEVEN. WE WITH SINCE I
HAVE BEEN ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN
THE REGULATORY IMPLEMENTATION
BUT ALSO AT THE LEGISLATIVE SIDE
AND WANTED THE THROUGH IT WE ARE
ENCOURAGED THAT MONEY SHOULD BE
GIVEN TO THE ADDRESS TO AIR
DISTRICTS BUT WITH CLEAR. AND
TRANSPARENT GUILIN'S ON THE
MONEY IS GOING TO BE.
USE AND ALSO IS WHAT IT IS
COMMUNITY EMPIRE THAT'S GOING TO
BE ACTUALLY OUTLINED FOR US TO
GIVE MEANINGFUL COMMUNITY AND
PUT IN THESE PLANTS. AND THAT'S
WHY THINGS FOR US IS HOW THE
MONEY IS GOING TO BE.
DISTRIBUTED AND THEN FROM THERE
IS HOUSING OUTCOMES ARE GONNA
ACTUALLY BEGINNING FROM THOSE
MONIES SEKALI ON WE WANT TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS HAVE BEEN STATED
REGARDING THE TRANSFORM A COMIC
COMMUNITIES WE DO WANT TO SEE
INCREASE. IN THE BUDGET FROM
TWENTY FIVE TO HOPEFULLY HUNDRED
MILLION GIVEN THE NEED OF THE
PROJECTS WE HAVE ALLOCATED THE
MONEY SPECIFICALLY THE GROWTH
COUNCIL HAS ON RECENTLY
ALLOCATED SOME OF THE FUNDS. AND
THE RICH HIGH NEED OF A LOT OF.
A MORE PERMITS BEING FUNDED IN
GOOD PROGRAMS IN REALLY GREAT
DEDICATED TO HOW.
SPECIFICALLY ON THE STATE AGENCY
HAS ACTIVELY INVOLVED COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND THE
BOMBING PROCESS AND WE REALLY
WANT TO USE THAT AS A MODEL
THROUGHOUT THE REST OF THE CD
AGENCIES WHEN THEY'RE
IMPLEMENTING. PROGRAMS WITH
COMMUNITY AND PUT IT ON AND THEN
LASTLY MY LAST COMMENT
SPECIFICALLY ON THE ZERO
EMISSION TECHNOLOGIES.
DISBURSEMENT IS REALLY FOCUSING
ON THIS MARKET.
IF HE BE SEEN LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
ALSO MY MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH THE AND
I WITH WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE.
IN ALSO WANTED TO ADD THAT.
AS PART OF SAY HI AND OUR
ORGANIZATION WE WOULD. LIKE NOT
TO SEE ANY MORE MONEY PUT INTO
THE DAIRY DIGEST OUR PROGRAM
AND.
AT THE VERY LEAST THIS
COMMITTEE IN A STAFF REPORT LAST
YEAR ASARO REPORT BACK FROM CDFA
ON AWARDS GRANTED TO THAT
PROGRAM WHERE THEY CAN. A CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING AND REPORT.
ABOUT THE AWARDS GRANTED THIS
PAST YEAR IN TERMS OF.
INCLUDING VENDOR LOCATION
EXPECTED OUTCOMES OF THE PROGRAM
AN.
EIGHT FIVE NINE WHICH WANTED TO
WHICH WHICH US FOR INVESTIGATION
ASH THE LOCAL AIR AND WATER
IMPACTS
AGAIN LEADERSHIP COUNCIL JUSTICE
ACCOUNTABILITY LOOK WORKS WITH
LOWER INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
SILICON VALLEY IN COACHELLA
VALLEY.
ESPECIALLY THE SAN DIGEST IS OUR
PLACE IS ONE OF
THE MOST IMPACTED AIR BASINS IN
THE COUNTRY. AND GROUND WATER
BASINS AS WELL THANKS SO MUCH.
WHERE DID WE THINK OF THAT?
I'M THE LUCKY FIRST. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MURS MARK FENCE MAKE ON
BEHALF THE NATURE CONSERVANCY IN
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
PURSE WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS PROPOSAL TO CAL FIRE.
SECONDLY WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
THE FOUR MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST
THAT MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
ALREADY SPOKEN TO. TWO QUICK
ADDITIONAL POINTS ONE THE
SCOPING PLAN HAS A TARGET FOR
EMISSION REDUCTIONS ARE NATIONAL
WORKING LAND SECTOR FOR THE
FIRST TIME IT'S I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE START TO
INVEST. IN THESE PROGRAMS NOW AS
WE CAN ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS
SECONDLY WE ARE WITNESSING THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE ON OUR
NATURAL LANDS FROM THE FIRES IN
THE FLOODS IN THE MUD SLIDES.
AND WE NEED TO BE ADDRESSING
THAT IMMEDIATELY WITH ADDITIONAL
FUNDING THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND STAFF.
I'M GONNA MISS BRIAN SHOW THEM
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE AND
AGRICULTURE NETWORK.
THE TO SUPPORT THE.
PROPOSAL FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA FOR FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO RESTORED EUROPE
FUNDING.
TO THE NATURAL WORKINGMAN'S
CLIMATE CHANGE PROGRAMS.
INCLUDING HEALTHY SOILS AND
SWEET.
THOSE TWO PROGRAMS ARE IN HIGH
DEMAND FOR FARMERS AND SHOW THAT
RURAL COMMUNITIES CAN PROVIDE
CLIMATE SOLUTIONS.
THANKS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
JIM HOLLY AT BERKELEY LAB. OUR
LAB COMMUNITIES ARE VERY MUCH
APPLAUDS THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR INCREASING.
CLIMATE AND CLEAN ENERGY
RESEARCH.
WE SUPPORT THE APPROACH.
RICHIE JR GROWTH COUNCIL AND THE
ENERGY COMMISSION OFFER A COUPLE
REASONS FIRST INSURANCE THEY
ENSURE THE BEST RESEARCH.
BY. A THREE SOLICITATIONS THAT
ALLOW ALL CALIFORNIA
UNIVERSITIES AND FEDERALLY BASED
LABS HERE TO COMPETE.
SECOND INJURING CLOSE ALIGNMENT
BETWEEN OF OUR AND THE AN AGENCY
MISSIONS.
AND THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR
ENSURING THE INNOVATIONS BAKER
FROM LAB TO MARKET.
ARE TIMES CALL FOR EVEN YET
BOLDER ACTION.
STAINED MISSION ORIENTED OUR
INDIE CAN ACHIEVE BIG
BREAKTHROUGHS.
THEIR UTILITY BILLS BUT THEY'RE
VERY THEIR OTHER IMPORTANT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STATE
LEADERSHIP ON RESEARCH FOR
EXAMPLE HOW TO ENSURE. THAT OUR
FORESTS AS THE WARM CONTINUE TO
ABSORB CARBON RATHER THAN
BECOMING SOURCES OF THROUGH BOB.
CUP CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES THANK
YOU WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M STEPHANIE
WONG WITH CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP.
AND I'M HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES FOR ALL
COALITION. WERE MULTI SECTOR
COALITION I'M TRYING TO BRING
THE BENEFITS OF INTEGRATING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND
TRANSPORTATION I'M OPTIONS WITH
GREEN INFRASTRUCTURE AND MAKING
SURE THAT WERE REACHING
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
WE HAVE CHAMPION THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING STABLE COMMUNITIES
PROGRAM AND CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
THE CONTINUOUS PREPARATIONS FOR
THAT PROGRAM. OF FOR TRANSIT
INTERCITY RAIL CAPITAL AND FOR
THE LOW.
CARBON.
TRANSIT OPERATIONS PROGRAM.
THOUGHT FOR THE ANNUAL
APPROPRIATIONS.
IN PARTICULAR TODAY I WOULD
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT THE LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM.
AS YOU'VE BEEN HEARING IT'S OF
REALLY ESSENTIAL PROGRAM FOR
REACHING LOW INCOME. HOUSEHOLDS
AND DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
WAS SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED FOR
THAT PURPOSE AND IT'S MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER AS WE AS.
EXTREME HEAT WAVES BECOME THE
NEW NORMAL THE REALLY IMPORTANT
CLIMATE ADAPTATION AND
RESILIENCE PROGRAM.
SOMETHING TO KEEP IN MIND IS
THERE'S NO OTHER FUNDING SOURCE
FOR THIS PROGRAM THINK AT TIMES
THERE'S MISUNDERSTANDINGS THAT
PERHAPS IT'S AND IT GETS
CONFUSED WITH OTHER PROGRAMS BUT
THIS PROGRAM IS SPECIFICALLY
DESIGNED.
TO OVERCOME BARRIERS.
IDENTIFIED THE S. B. THREE
FIFTY REPORT. UP FOR LOW INCOME
AND DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I JOSH WAS START WITH TRANSFORM.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
MATTER AND OTHERS.
I'M HERE REPRESENTING OF COURSE
AT TRANSFORM AND.
AS MEMBERS OF THE SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES FOR ALL COALITION A
COALITION OF TEN I'M VERY MIDDLE
JUSTICE HOUSING TRANSPORTATION
AYE AND IN CONSERVATION
ORGANIZATIONS.
.
WE DO APPLAUD THEIR GOVERNOR ON
CONTINUING THE.
THE APPROPRIATIONS FOR HSC NTR
CP AND LOW CARBON TRANSIT
OPERATIONS AYE WE WOULD ASK.
FOR A ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR FLOOR FOR TRANSIT OPERATE
FOR THAT LOW CARBON TRANSIT
OPERATIONS PROGRAM IN THE EVENT
OF A VERY LOW.
AUCTION RESULTS WE DON'T WANT
TO CUT FUNDING TO ONGOING
OPERATIONS AND SERVICES
ESPECIALLY IN A PROGRAM THAT
SERVES APPROXIMATELY AND SPENDS
APPROXIMATELY HALF OF ITS MONEY
AND DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
FOR THE OF FORTY PERCENT IN
ADDITION TO WHAT MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE MENTIONED EARLIER ON.
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE I AM ONE
RESTORING APPROPRIATE FUNDING
FOR URBAN FORESTRY IN URBAN
GREENING. AS WELL AS A PROGRAMS
THAT INCREASE BIKING WALKING AND
TRANSIT OPTIONS OF THAT. FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS HARM FOR BIKING
AND WALKING AND FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A STUDENT TRANSIT
PASS PROGRAM THAT WE'VE.
I WORKED TO CATHOLIC KIND OF LAY
OUT OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS AND STAFF
HOMONYMOUS STAND GRESHAM OF GOOD
ALTERNATIVES WILDERNESS IS THAT
OF THE STATE'S LARGEST
NONPROFIT.
SOLAR AND RENEWABLE ENERGY
PROVIDER AND SINCE TWENTY
FIFTEEN WE PARTNERED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT COMMUNITY SERVICES
AND DEVELOPMENT AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THEIR
STATEWIDE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THERE. ARE SINGLE FAMILY.
LOW INCOME SOLAR PROGRAM. AND
AND TO DATE HAVE SERVED OVER
THREE THOUSAND. AYE HOUSEHOLDS
THROUGH THAT PROGRAM EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THOSE
INSTALLATIONS HAS INCLUDED JOB
TRAINING AND LOCAL HIRING AYE
PROVISIONS ASO ALONG WITH MANY
OTHER FOLKS HERE WE AND HAVE
SEEN THE NEED FOR INCREASED
INVESTMENT. AYE IN THOSE
PROGRAMS AND NEED IN THE
COMMUNITY A SO I SUPPORT THE
RESTORATION OF THAT AT A MINIMUM
THE SEVEN FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
FOR THE FOR THE LIGHTWEIGHT
PROGRAM THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MISTER BOLAN.
MIGHT NAMES CHECK OF MOSS
MATHIS SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT AND I'LL
KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF
CONSERVING THE LATE HOUR.
AND THE LENGTH OF THE HEARING I
JUST WOULD LIKE TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY. TOM WITH BAY
AREA.
AND.
I JUST MEGA A QUICK POINT ABOUT
AB SIX SEVENTEEN IMPLEMENTATION.
WE HAVE.
.
PUT TOGETHER. A SORT OF A
PRELIMINARY PLAN NOT KNOWING YET
WHAT THE SCOPE OF THE COMMUNITY
AIR PROTECTION DISTRICTS WILL BE
BUT OUR ESTIMATES SHOW THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT A COST OF ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE MILLION PLUS OR
MINUS ANNUALLY. HIGH GOING
FORWARD TO IMPLEMENT THAT
PROGRAM AND
SO SEEING THAT.
THE BUDGET CHAU ZERO DOLLARS
COMMITTED TO THAT IS A LITTLE
BIT CONCERNING THAT'S A THAT'S A
NUMBER THAT APPLIES JUST TO
SOUTH COAST AIR DISTRICT.
SO NOW YOU CAN SEE THE SHORTFALL
IN THE CHALLENGE THAT WERE
DEALING WITH SO THANK YOU FOR
THE TIME.
I MISTER CHAIRMAN OF MISTER
MULLIN BRAND INTO IT ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOCIATION.
AND I WOULD ECHO THE COMMENTS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES FROM THE
SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT IN THE BAY
AREA AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT. AYE HAS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF MULLIN POINTED OUT
THERE'S ONGOING COSTS FROM THE
BAY AREA.
OF AT LEAST FOURTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS AND THEN MY COLLEAGUE AT
FROM SOUTH COAST TWENTY FIVE
MILLION AND THAT'S JUST TO WEAR
DISTRICTS SO YOU CAN SEE ARE
THAT IT'S SIGNIFICANT ONGOING
COSTS. AND AIR DISTRICTS HAVE
BEEN AGGRESSIVELY WORKING TO
IMPLEMENT THAT THAT THE NEW
PROGRAM UP BUT TO MAKE IT A
SUCCESS THE RESOURCES HAVE TO BE
THERE FOR IMPLEMENTATION.
SO WE APPRECIATE YOUR ATTENTION
TO THIS ISSUE AND I THANK YOU.
AFTER DETERMINE BLOOM AND MR
MINUS WHILE THE TRIGGER ENTER
WITH AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT OVER
FIFTEEN THOUSAND FARMERS ALL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. WE VERY
MUCH SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S THAT
INVEST IN AT CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN NOT FOR THE
CLIMATE.
I LIKE THAT CLINIC COMMUNITIES
STABLE COMMUNITIES AND. ALSO THE
FUNDING FOR SHORTLY OF A CLAIM
IT POLLUTANTS AYE CLIMATE SMART
I'D. AND THOSE FUNDS GO TOWARDS
REDUCTIONS AND LOW INCOME
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES ARE
DESPERATELY IN NEED OF THEM. AND
OUR MEMBERS PUT THEM ABSOLUTELY
TICKET USE THAN WE WOULD
APPRECIATE US PARKING.
MICHAEL BOOGER ON BEHALF OF THE
AG ENERGY CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION
ECHO THE COMMENTS FROM.
ON THE SCARE INJURE I LOVE THAT
FUNDING FOR AGRICULTURE FOOD
PROCESSORS AND DAIRY METHANE
REDUCTION. CONTINUES TO PROVIDE
AMONG THE BEST RETURN ON
INVESTMENT OF THE DOLLARS ARE
BEING TESTED TODAY. I I DID WANT
TO RESPOND ON THE DAIRY NOTHING
APARTMENT SETON REFERENCE THE
REPORT THAT IS REQUIRED OF THE
LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR. TO THE
BEST OF MY KNOWLEDGE THAT REPORT
HAS ALREADY BEEN DELIVERED BY
CDFA THE LEGISLATURE AND IT
DOCUMENTS THE SIGNIFICANT
METHANE REDUCTIONS.
IMPORTANT NOTE THAT ALL EIGHTEEN
DAIRY DIGEST OR PROJECTS THAT
WERE FUNDED IN THE.
ROUND OF FUNDING FROM TWO YEARS
AGO ARE ALL PIPELINE INJECTION
TRANSPORTATION FEEL PROJECTS
WHICH MEANS HE'S PROJECTS. ARE
NOT ONLY ON THE
METHANE REDUCTIONS IN THE GRANTS
PETITION FEEL IT'S GOING TO
REPLACE DIESEL AND REDUCE KNOCKS
AND PARTICULATE MATTER.
SEVENTY FOUR ADDITIONAL
APPLICATIONS WERE RECENTLY
RECEIVED FOR OVER A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING
FOR THE FUNDING THAT WAS MADE
AVAILABLE BY THE LEGISLATURE.
LAST YEAR GREATLY OVER.
EXTENDED OTHERS ONLY SIXTY ONE
TO SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
AVAILABLE SO THE FUNDING IN THIS
BUDGET VERY METHANE REDUCTION IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO
CONTINUE.
THOSE IMPORTANT PROJECTS AND
THEY ARE NOT JUST PROVIDING GHG
BUT THE.
OF GREENHOUSE EXCUSE ME THE
CRITERIA POLLUTANT AND
PARTICULATE MATTER REDUCTIONS AT
THE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITY. UP HILL IS LOOKING
FOR IN THE VALLEY THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CALLING WALTER
SACRAMENTO TREE FOUNDATION.
FOUNDED THIRTY SIX YEARS AGO AS
ONE OF THE NATION'S FIRST URBAN
FORCE NONPROFITS
SACRAMENTO TREPANATION WORKS
WITH MUNICIPALITIES. BUSINESS
OWNERS AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS
PLANTING PROTECTING IN TEACHING
ABOUT TREES WHILE TREES ARE
TOOLS OUR GOAL IS TO CREATE MORE
HEALTHY MORE RESILIENT
COMMUNITIES BY OPTIMIZING THE
BENEFITS AND SERVICES OF OUR
INCREDIBLE URBAN FOREST.
WE'VE BEEN VERY FORTUNATE TO
RECEIVE SOME GREENHOUSE GAS
FUNDING DOLLARS RECENTLY WHICH
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO USE TO DO
MEANINGFUL AND IMPACTFUL WORK ON
THE GROUND AND THE COMMUNITIES
MOST DEVOID OF CANOPY.
BUT THE NEED IS GREAT AND
THEY'RE SO MUCH MORE WORK TO DO.
SO FOR THAT REASON WE URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT THE FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION A PROPOSAL FOR NATURAL
RESOURCES.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS
THOMAS LAWSON CALIFORNIA AFTER
HAS VEHICLE COALITION I'M NOT
GOING TO DUPLICATE ANY OF MY
COMMENTS ARE ONES YOU ALREADY
HEARD. I DID WHAT I PUT A FINER
POINT ON THOSE COMMENTS.
WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE
NUMBERS IN THEIR RESOURCE
BORDELLO COOPER TRANSPORTATION.
ASSEMBLY MCLEAN TRUCKS BUSES AND
OFFER FOR EQUIPMENT. AND TWENTY
SIXTEEN I BELIEVE THE
LEGISLATURE FUND THAT PROGRAM
OVER THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A LAST YEAR'S ONE SIXTY
THIS YEAR PROPOSED ONE SIX
AGAIN.
ABOUT THAT'S ABOUT A FIFTY
PERCENT CUT AND WHAT WE TALKED
ABOUT EARLIER WHICH IS AN AREA
THAT'S CAUSING MOST OF THE.
THAT THE THE MISSION PROBLEMS
THAT WE'RE HAVING.
TO PUT A FINER POINT ON THAT IT
AIR BE RELEASED SOME SOME
NUMBERS FOR YEARS AGO THAT
SUGGESTED OF ONE OF THE AREAS
THAT IS HEAVILY IMPACTED SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY. PASSENGER CARS
MAKE UP ABOUT ONE PERCENT OF THE
MISSIONS POSSIBLY THE KNOCKS IN
THAT PARTICULAR AREA AND TRUCKS
BUSES MAKE UP NINETY PERCENT.
WE'VE GOT TO BE ABLE TO PUT
MONEY INTO THE AREA SO WE CAN
GET THIS EXPONENTIALLY OF
REDUCTIONS THAT ARE NEEDED AND
OUT WOULD ASK OF THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. A
REVIEWS THAT PROPOSAL I KNOW
TRUST ME THAT THERE'S NOT OF
MONEY DO EVERYTHING WE WANT TO
DO BUT IF WE'RE GOING TO GET THE
THESE GOALS THAT WE HAVE SOME OF
THEM ARE VERY AMBITIOUS.
WE'VE GOT TO DO AS MUCH AS WE
CAN NOW NOT PUT THAT OFTEN
FURTHER THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
TURN MEMBERS KATHY MUST PROGRAMS
IN THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
FOOD BANKS JUST ONE ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY MISTER MARROW
FOR WITH CALIFORNIA'S AGAINST
WASTE. IN I'M SUPPORTING THE.
THE ITEM ON A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR CAL RECYCLING WASTE
VERSION. AND.
AND FOOD RECOVERY ARE FOOD
BANKS HAVE BEEN THE BENEFICIARY
OF A FEW OF THOSE GRANTS I'M
CERTAINLY THE WORK WE'VE DONE
HAS BEEN REALLY BENEFICIAL. AND
WE SEE THE BENEFIT ON FAIRLY
QUICKLY BUT I THINK.
IT CERTAINLY DOESN'T MEET THE
NEED SO WE WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE WHEN IT'S TIME TO
SUPPORT THE HUNTER MILLION
DOLLAR ASK THINK.
AND PARTNER THE DAVEY RESOURCE.
GROUP PART OF THE DVD TREE
EXPERT COMPANY IN SUPPORT OF THE
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
NATURAL RESOURCES PROPOSAL
SPEARHEADED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA.
OTHER DAVID RESOURCE GROUP.
WAS ESTABLISHMENT EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY WE ARE THE LEADING URBAN
FORESTRY CONSULTANT THROUGHOUT
THE NATION WHERE IN FORTY FIVE
STATES AND RE SUPPORT
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WITH SCIENCE AND
INNOVATION.
TREES WITHIN THE URBAN FOREST
MAKE OUR LIVES AND OUR
COMMUNITIES BETTER FROM CLEAN
AIR AND GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS TO CARBON STORAGE
CALMING TENSIONS AND IMPROVING
NEIGHBORHOODS. TREES PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT BENEFITS TO THE
EXTENT THAT EVERY COMMUNITY.
BENEFITS FROM OUR HEALTHY URBAN
CANOPY.
ARE CALIFORNIA URBAN FORESTS ARE
CRITICAL NOT ONLY TO THE
ENVIRONMENT BUT ALSO TO THE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE ECONOMY OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP IN URBAN
FORESTRY AND ASK THAT YOU
SUPPORT.
HIS REQUEST THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS IZABELLA
GONZALEZ POTTER BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA URBAN FOREST COUNCIL
HERE IN SUPPORT ALSO OF THE FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR GGF
REQUEST. AT ALL OF THE PREVIOUS
COMMENTS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ELENA ORTIZ ON
BEHALF OF PENINSULA OPEN SPACE
TRUST AND BIGGEST OUR LANDTRUST
AND I ALSO WANT TO ALIGN MY
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF THE FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION ASK THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS JUST
GO GAGA WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SANITATION
AGENCIES. WOULD JUST LIKE TO
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONSIDER ALLOCATING A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AND TO THE WASTE
DIVERSION PROGRAM AT CAL RECYCLE
FOR THE REASONS PREVIOUSLY
STATED BY CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
WASTE AND US THE SACK.
MOST M. ON BEHALF OF THE SOLID
WASTE ASSOCIATION OF NORTH
AMERICA AND THE WESTERN POSTURE
WASTE MANAGEMENT AUTHORITY. WE
TWO WOULD URGE AND AN EXPANSION
OF THE ALLOCATION OF CARS CYCLE
FOR WASTE VERSION RECYCLING FROM
TWENTY MILLION TWO HUNDRED
MILLION HAD NO THOUGHT TWENTY
MILLION WOULD BE THE LOWEST
AMOUNT ALLOCATED FOR THIS
PURPOSE SINCE IT SHOULD EUROPE
WAS ESTABLISHED. AND IT WOULD
CUT LAST YEAR'S INVESTMENT IN
HALF ON WITH THE FORTHCOMING SP
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE DEADLINES
WE NEED ASSISTANCE FROM THE
STATE NOW MORE THAN EVER THINK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CORBELS ON BEHALF
OF CAL START.
WOULD JUST LIKE TO START BY
SAYING WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR LOW
CARBON TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS.
BUT I'D ALSO LIKE TO ALIGN
MYSELF WITH.
MR LAWSON'S COMMENTS REGARDING
FUNDING FOR MEDIUM HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES THAT NUMBER IS
SIGNIFICANTLY LOW.
RELATED TO THE TYPES OF THE
AMOUNT OF EMISSIONS FROM IN
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES EACH YEAR
THEY MAKE UP TWENTY THREE
PERCENT. OF ANNUAL MISSIONS OUT
OF THAT FORTY PERCENT THAT COMES
FROM THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
WHILE ONLY MAKING UP THREE
PERCENT OF VEHICLES ON A ROAD SO
THE EMISSIONS REDUCTION BENEFITS
ARE TREMENDOUS. THE CRITERIA
POLLUTE REDUCTIONS.
OUR BENEFITS ARE TREMENDOUS SO
WE'RE GONNA NEED SUSTAINED
FUNDING VERY ROBUST FUNDING THIS
AREA GONNA JUST CONCLUDE BY
SAYING THAT THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD HAS A THREE YEAR
INVESTMENT PLAN SPECIFICALLY
RELATED. TO INVESTMENTS AND
ADVANCED CLEAN VEHICLES FOR
MEDIUM HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES
HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION DOESN'T
EVEN COME CLOSE TO A LINE TO
WHERE THEY NEED TO BE IN OUR TO
HELP THE MARKET SCALE UP AND
TAKE OFF AND ALLOWS FOR. MASS
ADOPTION OF THESE VEHICLES THANK
YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA DAIRIES
INCORPORATED THE CALIFORNIA
COTTON GENERATION GROWERS
ASSOCIATION WESTERN ACT
PROCESSORS ASSOCIATION AND A
COUPLE OTHERS.
SET ASIDE MY FOUR PAGES OF NOTES
AND JUST SIMPLY SAY WE SUPPORT.
HOW THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR?
THE CLIMATE AG PROGRAMS AND THE
SMART TAG PROGRAMS AS WELL AS
THE METHANE REDUCTION MONIES FOR
THE DAIRY INDUSTRY THANK YOU.
YOU GET POINTS THAT MIGHT NOT
GOT TRANSLATE INTO DOLLARS BUT
YOU GET POINTS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOSH
PINE AND BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
REFUSE RECYCLING.
COUNCIL.
HUNDRED COMPANIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE I'D MENTIONED BEFORE
YOU HEARD THOSE REMARKS.
AT WITH A TWO HUNDRED MILLION A
YEAR THAT WE'VE BEEN ASKING FOR.
BE ABLE TO ARE REDUCED OUT ONE
MILLION TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY.
TONS
OUR OF. THIS CARBON GOING INTO
THE ATMOSPHERE.
I THAT WOULD BE SIXTY SEVEN NEW.
PAY AND A ROBE DIGESTION
FACILITIES I AND I THINK THAT I
WOULD URGE YOU TO INCREASE THE
TWENTY MILLION THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING NOW.
MORE LIKE THE HUNDRED MILLION
THAT MISS EGGMAN HAS PROPOSED IN
HER LETTER TO YOU OR THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION. ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS THAT MISTER MIND SHINE
HAS PROPOSED IN A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS FOR YOUR
PATIENCE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU OFFER YOUR
COMMENTS AND.
THIS CLOSES OUT.
THE FIRST INSTALLMENT OF OUR
ANNUAL CAP AND TRADE PILGRIMAGE.
IT DEPENDS AT SUB THREE I REALLY
DO APPRECIATE ALL YOUR COMMENTS
AND WE RECEIVED A NUMBER OF.
FLOOD OF COMMENTS VIA EMAIL AND.
.
I WRITTEN CORRESPONDENCE AS WELL
THEY'RE ALL TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION AND.
SOMEHOW COME THROUGH THIS
PROCESS AND WILL WILL HAVE A
RECOMMENDATION AT THE END OF THE
DAY MISTER MULLIN YOU HONESTLY
BRIEFLY.
MISTER CHAIR.
THERE ARE REFERENCES TO PROP
SIXTY EIGHT ON THE JUNE BALLOT
JUST CURIOUS ABOUT CONTINGENCY
PLANS IF THE PROPOSITION.
DOES NOT PASS.
PARTICULARLY WITH REGARD TO
CLIMATE ADAPTATION OF WETLANDS
WORK.
WHICH IS SO IMPORTANT.
ANY THOUGHTS ON THAT OH YEAH SO
MATT ONLY DEPARTMENT FIND SO.
AS WE TALKED ABOUT I BELIEVE IN
THE PRIOR HEARING ABOUT S. B.
FIVE.
THE BUDGET DOES ASSUME.
PASSAGE OF A.
OF S. B. FIVE WILL JUST HAVE TO
CROSS THAT BRIDGE WHEN WE GET TO
IT A.
DEPENDING ON THE OUTCOME OF THE
ELECTION.
KEEP OUR FINGERS CROSSED.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO WE'RE DONE WITH PART A.
PART B. IS NOT GOING TO BE AS
LONG BACK PROMISE YOU THAT.
WE'VE ALREADY DONE THE OF THE
VOTE ONLY CALENDAR.
BUT I WANT TO ASK MY COLLEAGUES
DOES ANYBODY NEED TO LEAVE.
.
AND THEN THE NEXT A LITTLE BIT.
BECAUSE WE COULD TAKE ISSUE
THREE FIRST THAT'S THE ONLY ONE
THAT WE. OF HAVE A VOTE
SCHEDULED ON.
TO ENTER OUT TWO AND THREE
RIGHT.
WELL LET'S SEE IF FOR.
WE CAN BRING A RB FORWARD.
AND.
REQUEST BRIEF
PRESENTATIONS.
ON EACH YEAR ITEMS.
WE'LL START THEN WITH THE ISSUE
NUMBER ONE. OF FREIGHT
REGULATION.
THANK YOU CHAIR AT GOOD
AFTERNOON CITY PUT THIS YOU'VE
CLEARED OUT THE ROOM AMAZING.
PEOPLE LINE UP A LITTLE MORE FOR
A G. JEREMY DO FOR OUR BUDGET
AGAINST.
A STEEP CLIFF DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
OFFICER AT THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD.
ABOUT FIRST ISSUE IS SAKHAR
BOOK REQUESTS HAVE ONE MILLION
EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME FUNDING FROM THE MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCOUNT. IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINE NINETEEN INCLUDING
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND. AND
CONTRACT FUNDING FOR INITIAL
DEVELOPMENT OF AN INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY PROP PROJECT IN ONE
YEAR FUNDING FOR FIVE TEMPORARY
POSITIONS.
TO SUPPORT IMPLEMENTATION AND
ENFORCEMENT OF CARBS FREIGHT
REGULATIONS.
PROTECT DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES NEAR PORTS AND RAIL
YARDS.
THESE REQUESTED RESOURCES ARE
NEEDED TO DEVELOP MAINTAIN AND
SUPPORT OF REPLACEMENT SYSTEM
FOR THE CURRENT CARP FREQUENT
REGISTRATION PROGRAM. WITH ADDED
FUNCTIONALITY TO MEET RECORD
KEEPING AND REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR A VARIETY OF
FREIGHT REGULATIONS.
THE PROPOSAL WOULD ALSO
IMPLEMENT EFFICIENCIES TO OFFSET
THE UNAVOIDABLE COSTS OF
PROVIDING ONGOING ASSISTANCE TO
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES THAT MUST
COMPLY WITH THOSE REGULATIONS.
WHO ARE LOOKING FOR SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON ONE
ASPECT OF FOR? A OF YOUR
PROPOSAL RECOMMENDATION AND AND
OR CHANGE ARE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS. HOLDING CA.
AND HOLDING THIS ITEM OF.
.
AND ELLIOT WOULD YOU HAVE ME YES
SO.
FOR THIS ITEM AT AS
THE CLIFF MENTIONED THERE'S A
AND IT COMPONENT TO IT AND WE'VE
RECENTLY GOTTEN SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ABOUT THE COST
ESTIMATES FOR THAT SO. I OUR
RECOMMENDATION IS TO
WITHHOLD BATON WITHOUT ACTION
UNTIL WE CAN CONSORTED.
AND WILL DO THAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU PUBLIC COMMENT
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
I'LL BE VERY BRIEF BECAUSE I'M
HUNGRY BY NOW.
WE SUPPORT THIS REQUEST TO THE
FREE STANDARDS THAT CAR IS
WORKING ON ARE REALLY VITAL TO
REDUCING DIESEL EMISSIONS AND
THEREFORE VERY VITAL TO PUBLIC
HEALTH AND. THIS.
KIND OF UNGLAMOROUS PROPOSAL.
PORTS THOSE IMPORTANT RULE SO
WE.
IN DORSET THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
AND TO OF THEM OF FISH NOT FOR
THE COMMENTS LET'S MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER TWO.
THANK YOU I CARP IS REQUESTING
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND TWO POSITIONS TO
IMPLEMENT RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE
FINAL S. B. THREE FIFTY GUIDANCE
DOCUMENT. ON OVERCOMING BARRIERS
TO CLEAN TRANSPORTATION ACCESS
FOR LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
AND CO LEADING THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE.
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE S. B. THREE
FIFTY TASK FORCE.
AT THAT TASK FORCE IS THE MAIN
MECHANISM TO PROMOTE CONTINUED
STATE AGENCY ACTION AND
COLLABORATION ON IMPLEMENTING
THE HIGH PARTY RECOMMENDATION
AND CARBS GUIDANCE DOCUMENT. AND
THE COMPANION ENERGY COMMISSION
STUDY ON IMPROVING ACCESS TO
ENERGY EFFICIENCY WEATHERIZATION
AND RENEWABLE ENERGY
INVESTMENTS.
THESE RESOURCES WOULD STAFF AND
SUPPORT THE TASK FORCE WORK WITH
THE OTHER FIFTEEN STATE AGENCIES
INVOLVED. AND ALLOW FOR ONGOING
IMPLEMENTATION OF CARBS S. B.
THREE FIFTY RECOMMENDATIONS.
TO INCREASE CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
ACCESS ACROSS THE STATE.
AND CARB AGREES WITH STAFF
COMMENTS AND APPRECIATES THE
RECOMMENDATION FOR APPROVAL OF
THESE RESOURCES.
LL.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE A MOTION ON
ISSUES TO.
CURRENT.
HELLO I. FONG.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
THANK YOU EVERYONE ISSUE NUMBER
THREE.
BACK CALIFORNIA RESOURCES BOARD
REQUESTS A TOTAL OF TEN
POSITIONS AND JUST OVER ONE
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS FROM
A P. C. F. THEIR POLLUTION
CONTROL FUND. TO STRENGTHEN AND
BROADEN ITS MOBILE SOURCE
OVERSIGHT PROGRAM AND COVER ALL.
OPPONENTS IN THE BE OFFERED
ENGINES AND AFTERMARKET PARTS
ACTUALLY MEET OR DO NOT
INTERFERE WITH THE STRINGENT
ENGINE EMISSIONS STANDARDS.
THEY ARE CERTIFIED TWO AND NOT
ONLY AT THE TIME OF APPROVAL BUT
ONGOING AS THEY OPERATE IN THE
REAL WORLD. IT'S CRITICAL FOR
CALIFORNIA TO ACHIEVE HEALTH
BASED STANDARDS ADDRESS
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ISSUES AND
MEET STATE AND FEDERAL AMBIENT
AIR QUALITY STANDARDS.
I CURRENTLY THE OFFROAD AN
AFTERMARKET PARTS MANUFACTURERS
DO NOT PAY A FEE FOR THE
EVALUATION APPROVAL OF THEIR
PRODUCTS ONLY ON ROAD ENGINES
AND VEHICLES. ARE ABOUT ONE
THIRD OF THE ENGINES ARE VEHICLE
APPROVAL PAY A FEE WHICH IS
CAPPED.
AT THE TREE A SORRY THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE PROVIDES THE
STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO START
WORKING ON A REGULATION TO
DEVELOP A FEW METHODOLOGY FOR
OFF ROAD. AFTERMARKET PARTS AND
OTHER NON FEE COMPONENTS AND
ENGINES
THE METHODOLOGY WOULD CREATE AT
CALCULATION TO RECOUP THE COSTS
TO RUN THE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION
NOTHING FROM LA OR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND WE HAVE. SOME
PUBLICAN.
ONLY ONETIME KAREN LAYING ON
BEHALF OF THE SPECIALTY
EQUIPMENT MARKET ASSOCIATION
THINK A STAFF FOR ALL OF THEIR
WORK WE URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
ADOPT THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
TODAY. SEEM A HAS BEEN WORKING
WITH A A RP WE'VE REALLY ENJOYED
THE WORK THAT I'M FINANCES DONE
IN PLAIN IN. OF THE PROPOSAL AND
THE PARTNERSHIP THAT WE HAVE
WITH A A RP AND THEY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THE MEMBERS COME IN
AND GET THE CERTIFICATION
CALIFORNIA OCCUPIES THE FIELD
ESSENTIALLY. ANYBODY IN THE
UNITED STATES THAT NEED THE NEO
HAS TO COME TO THE A A RP FOR
THAT SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE MAXIMIZE COMPLIANCE
WE'RE THRILLED FOR THE NEW
BODIES. AND ASK YOU TO APPROVE
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION SAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU AND OUR STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO APPROVE THE
BCP BUT TO HLD OPEN ON THE A
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IF THERE'S
A MOTION TO THAT EFFECT.
THANK YOU HAVE MOTION AND A
SECOND BLOOM BY FONG.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THAT BRINGS OUR HEARING
MERCIFULLY TO A CONCLUSION THANK
YOU OFFER. STICK.
STICKING IT OUT AND WE'LL SEE
YOU AGAIN NEXT WEEK.
STONE.
ACTUALLY ACTUALLY WE WON'T SEE
YOU NEXT WEEK.
WE HAVE A LITTLE RECESS NEXT
WEEK WE'LL SEE YOU IN TWO WEEKS.
WHERE GERMS